GOOD AFTERNOON
WELCOME TO THE JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND MEETING OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO START
I WANT TO JUST THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF WITH ME TO RETURN TO THE
CAPITOL TO HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE
DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE ST
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING THIS HEARING ROOM SO
WE CAN ONLY HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF FOLKS PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON WE ALSO
REQUIRE THE MAST BE WARNED. AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED WEATHER HERE IN A
ROOM OR ATTIC VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
TO YOU IT IS THE CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE OF OUR HOUSE THE
MEMBERS BE PROPERLY ATTIRED FOR
SHARING WEARING A MASK IS THE
REQUIREMENT OF BEING PROPERLY
ATTIRED WE'VE NINE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA I BELIEVE ONE BILLS ON
CONSENT WE'RE ASKING AUTHORS TO
GIVE SESSENTA PRESENTATIONS
EACH BILL CAME UP TO ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. TO MAIN WITNESSES
WILL GET TWO MINUTES EACH AND
THEN THAT WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK TO REGISTER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION WE ASK IN THAT
INSTANCE THAT YOU ONLY SEE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL IF YOU SEE
MORE THAN THAT YOU WILL BE CUT
OFF BY THE OPERATOR UP FOR
TODAY'S HEARING SINCE WE A LOT
ON THE AGENDA WE ARE GOING TO
LIMIT- THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- AS WE
MOVE THROUGH. IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE PHONE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE PORTAL IT
WILL BECOME PART OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE BILL YOU
CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN EMAIL TO
COMMITTEE STAFF NOW WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY FOR MEMBERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM- IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND AGAIN WE
ASK YOU TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS-
LOCATED ON THE NORTH SIDE OF
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. AND THEN
WE HAVE A MODERATE A TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH WITNESSES
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- TO
THIS NUMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ON YOUR
TV SCREEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING
THEN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING THE
BILL PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
BUILT IF YOU'RE CALLING THEM
PLEASE ELIMINATE BACKGROUND
NOISE AND THAT MEANS ALSO
MUTING YOUR BROADCAST AND SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS YOU WILL REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF AND YOUR CALL TO
SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES
YOU CAN CALL MY COMMITTEE STAFF
AT NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO EIGHT FIVE. AND
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
AND UNDERSTANDING AT THIS POINT
ONE TWO THREE FOUR WE HAD
QUORUM BUT I THINK MISS WHICH
JUST STEPPED OUT SO WE ARE
GOING TO START. IN THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM AS A SUB COMMITTEE
WHICH MEANS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HEAR BILLS BUT NOT BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON THEM. AND WITH THAT WHY
DON'T WE START WITH SENATOR
SKINNER WHO HAS BOTH FILE ITEMS
ONE AND TWO. SENATOR WELCOME.
THANK YOU BYE. CHAIR CHIU AND
MEMBERS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START WITH FOUND ONE OR TWO IS
A FILE ITEM ONE S. B. H. SB
EIGHT OKAY GREAT LET'S START
WITH THAT ONE- PUT MY GLASSES
ON THANK YOU SO MUCH SO SB
EIGHT EXTENDS THE PROVISIONS OF
A BILL THAT WE ALL PASSED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN- THAT WAS SB
THREE THIRTY TO HOUSING CRISIS
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT BILL IS
WORKING. MORE HOUSING IS
GETTING BUILT FOR EXAMPLE-
THERE WAS A GREAT PROJECT IN
SAN FRANCISCO CALLED THE
SHIRLEY CHISHOLM VILLAGE SB
THREE THIRTY HELPED SHAPE SIX
MONTHS OFF THAT PROJECT
TIMELINE SO THAT CONSTRUCTION
STARTED SIX MONTHS EARLIER AND
AS WE KNOW TIME IS MONEY SO
WHEN- HOW ARE PROJECTS
ESPECIALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS CAN BE BUILT TO
PROMPTLY THEY ARE BUILT AT MORE
COST EFFECTIVELY NOW. SB EIGHT
EXTENDING THE PROVISIONS OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS ACT FOR THOSE OF
YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
FAMILIAR WITH THAT ORIGINAL
BILL THIS JUST GREEN LIGHTS
HOUSING THAT ALREADY MEETS
LOCAL RULES SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE EXISTING RULES IN
OTHER WORDS- WHATEVER ZONING
RULES LAND USE AUTHORITIES AND
SUCH THAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PUT INTO PLACE ARE RESPECTED.
IT JUST SAYS THAT WHEN A
APPLICANT SUBMITS A PROJECT
THAT MEETS LOCAL RULES IT HAS
TO BE DONE WITHIN A CERTAIN
TIMELINE AND THE RULES CAN'T
CHANGE MID STREAM WHILE THEY'RE
PROCESSING THAT PROJECT- AND
THE BENEFIT OF THAT IS
ESPECIALLY IN THE CRISIS THAT
WE ARE IN NOW THE HOUSING
CRISIS WE ARE IN NOW WHERE WE
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT WE ARE
THREE MILLION FEWER UNITS THAN
IS NEEDED- THIS REALLY IS A BAY
IF IT BECAUSE- IT GIVES
CERTAINTY TO THE APPLICANT. AND
HELPS PROCEED WITH THE HOUSING
WE SO DESPERATELY NEED NOW THE
BILL THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THIS BILL. AND THREE
THIRTY IS THAT THERE'S SOME
CLARIFYING OF TECHNICAL
DEFINITIONS THAT BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCE OF IMPLEMENTING
THREE THIRTY SO FAR SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS INTERACTED WITH US
AND SAID YOU KNOW. A COUPLE OF
THESE DEFINITIONS AND
GUIDELINES NEED CLARIFICATION
SO WE- DID THAT SO THAT IT'S-
THERE GIVES THEIR CERTAINTY IN
NO CONFUSION AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO TURN TO MY WITNESSES
AND I'VE GOT BEFORE YOU DO
COULD WE ESTABLISH A FORM
BEFORE MISS CLARK SILVA WALKS
OUT. I'LL ASK MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CHILL HERE
TO HEAR SAY ARE TELL YOUR C. R.
TO HEAR GABRIEL. KALRA KILEY
KILEY HERE MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SILVA HERE HERE QUIKSILVER HERE
WICKS LOOKS HERE A KIND OF A
MOTION. TO MOVE FORWARD THE
PROPOSED CONSENT ITEM. OKAY SIR
SECOND. ALL RIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY COULD CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT ITEM TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TO AND LET'S
JUST SAY THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN AS BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT
LAYERED. CHU I. CHIU ICE
AIRTEL. AIRTEL I. GABRIEL.
KALRA KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN QUICK SILVA. LICKS
WICKS AT AND WITH THAT
APOLOGIES FOR THE INTERRUPTION
BACK NO WORRIES ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S HAVE ARE MY WITNESSES
PEDRO GALV O. FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
JONATHAN FERN WHO IS THE CITY
OF OAKLAND PLANNING
COMMISSIONER SO TO THE OPERATOR
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES MR
GALVIN- FROM NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND MR FIRM FROM
GREYSTAR. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR THEM TO
TESTIFY. NO LONGER OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR TO BY CHANCE WE
ARE TO OUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I'M
PATRICK OUTBOUND POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
TRUMP SUPPORTERS SB EIGHT BY
SENATOR SKINNER WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO FIX PASSED THE TEST
BETWEEN THIRTY BY MAINTAINING
PREDICTABILITY AND LOCAL
PLANNING. AND LOCAL HOUSING
APPROVAL PROCESS. THE CORPORATE
NINETEEN. HAS X. CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EMERGENCY
AND HOUSING IS ESSENTIAL FOR
COVERT RECOVERY. AS HAVING AN
AFFORDABLE AND STABLE PLACE TO
CALL HOME CREEK COAST
FACETIMING KENTUCKY- AND
PROSPER. WHAT A HOUSING. ALL
OTHER DEVELOPING NEED TO ABIDE
BY LOCAL RULES YET IN THE PAST
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN DELAYED
SOMETIMES FOR YEARS DUE TO
ARBITRARY CHANGES WHEN LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS EVEN AFTER A
PROJECT HAD ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED. SB THREE THIRTY THREE
PREDICTABILITY IN THE HAUNTING
APPROVAL PROCESS BY HOLDING THE
WILL STUDY ONE OF THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
AND CREATING PREDICTABLE
TIMELINE. THESE PROPERTIES HAVE
BEEN CRUCIAL TO GETTING
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOMES BUILT IN RISK
INTERVENTION SURELY CHISHOLM
VILLAGE THANK SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE I JUST HOPING THE PROCESS
THAT THE XIN SIX MONTHS OFF THE
DOCK PROJECT. ANOTHER IMPEACH
MEMBER EVEN HELPING WITH PEOPLE
TO GET SEVENTY AFFORDABLE HOMES
APPROVED AND HE WANTED TO DO TO
SB THREE THIRTY ON THE TENSION
ON THE NUMBER OF HEARING AT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN HAVE
BEFORE. APPROVING OR DENYING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. IS THE
STATE CAN. ON ITS PATH TO RICK
IN IS CRITICAL THAT LED. TO
SUPPORT. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
H. TO NINETEEN PREDICTABILITY
CALIFORNIA. APPROVAL PROCESS
PLEASE. THAT IS SO DESPERATELY
NEEDED TO ADDRESS AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS AMPLIFIED I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I TALKED THANK YOU.
IT'S GOT A NEXT WITNESS. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR CHIU AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JONATHAN KARL TWENTY COMMERCIAL
CITY OAKLAND AND ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CASINO COALITION
ALSO MONOCLE- SENATORS CAN
REMARKS BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS- SB THREE
THIRTY WORKS BY REALLY IS BEING
UTILIZED AND I CAN SAY- THE
JUST LAST EVENING- IT NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED UNIT PROJECT WAS.
APPROVED BY THE CITY OF MENLO
PARK- THAT CAME UNDER SB THREE
THIRTY SO WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT- WHATEVER IS WORKING AS
A RELATES TO OUR HOUSING
CRISIS- IN TERMS OF OUR
BUILDING LEGISLATION. OF THE
CERTAINTY AND CLARITY OF
PROCESS ARE DESCRIBING- OR-
APPLICANTS THE PLAYING FIELD UP
FRONT THAT SB ABLE TO STAND AS
BENEFICIAL NOT ONLY TO
APPLICANTS BUT ALSO TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL AND I
KNOW. THE QUERY PROCESS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY TRY
HARD TO IMPLEMENT- IN THE CITY
OF OPEN AS WELL- THIS CLEAR
PROCESS CAN ENSURE THAT ARE
PROJECTS CONSISTENT WAS ONLY
DON'T GET ME TO SLEEP LATE AT
ARMS SUBJECT EVER ESCALATING
COST IMPACTS THAT CAN THREATEN
THEIR DELIVERY AND DELIVERY OF
HOUSING OKAY SO WHAT I HOPE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN SUPPORT
SB EIGHT AS A KEY TOOL IN OUR
FIGHT AGAINST HOUSING CRISIS.
AND FURTHER OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER MUCH NEEDED HOUSING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THAT- I THINK YOU AND- I
REQUEST YOUR ARTICLE IS ABOUT.
THANK YOU AT THE TIME ONE WE GO
X. THERE ARE NO MAIN. WITNESS
SO LET'S UP THE PHONE LINES.
FOR MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AGAIN- WE'RE GONNA BE
LIMITING TESTIMONY TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES TO EACH SIDE. ARE WE
ASK YOU TO NAME TO EXPRESS YOUR
NAME- YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT. AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE A COUPLE FOLKS IN
THE HEARING ROOM- ASK YOU TO
START. IT MARKS DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR. OUR
STORE IS ONLY HALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
LET'S NOW GO TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS ANYONE AT
THE RTS STATIONS SEE NON LET'S
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE TO THE
MODERATOR. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK OR
WISH TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT. YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. OUR FIRST. COMMENT
COMES FROM NINE THREE OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- I'M NOT IN SUPPORT OF AT
EIGHT IS THAT OKAY I NUMBER
FIVE. IT'S YOU WERE NOT IN THE
RIGHT LINE SO IF YOU COULD
HOPEFULLY CALL AN FOR THE ITEM
THAT YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO THANK
YOU. I'M THREE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN THE
PART AT THE EIGHT THANK YOU.
PRESS NINE TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVENING ZACKS BOWLING-
REPRESENTING IN THE ACTION EACH
DAY IN THE AND ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE IN PORT THANK YOU.
NINE THREE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER THAT I HAVE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT. AND
CHEMICAL COMPLAINING IN URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION HONEST
CALIFORNIA YOU NEED A GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION FACEBOOK
KMG PARTNERS THE COUNCIL OF
INTEL BOULDERS AND CIRCULATE IN
DIEGO THANK YOU. MY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FRAPPENING CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS HOLLY FALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE DAIRY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI A REPRIEVE OPERATE
FROM BERKELEY CALLING INTO PORT
AND ALSO ASKING FOR AN
AMENDMENT THAT THE FAN ON
SYMBOLICALLY PROTECTED UNIT
WITHOUT REPLACEMENT OFFER A
PIPE YOU ANY PROJECT NOT JUST
HELPING THEM OUT LATER HOPE
TANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK IF I COULD
JUST READ WERE A FINE TO
EXPRESS THE FACT THAT YOU
SUPPORT SO AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT THE
SUPPORT. NEXT BIGGER. TWENTY
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I AM ADAM
BOOKBINDER CONCEIVED CAMPBELL
IN EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SAYS THE
INDIANS SCORED SB EIGHT. LINE
FOR TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ALISON
CHALLENGE AND LOS ANGELES I'M
SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNER AND AN
ADVOCATE STORAGE THE PIPELINE.
WHAT PART IN PLACE BUT SB EIGHT
MEGABYTE MUCH. NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I COULD AFTERNOON TO
REMEMBER THIS IS LESLIE VASQUEZ
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE DIFFICULTY BEING-
WITHIN FOR EVERYONE AND YOU MAY
BE ACTION IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ROBERT
FRANKLIN WITH SAN FRANCISCO
UNITY AND SUPPORT WOMEN EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUSTIN HIGHER WHICH IS ALL
ABOUT READERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAROLINE I'M CALLING ON THE
FIGURE CALLED THE EIGHTY TWENTY
FOURTH SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
TENANTS PREVALENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT. THANK YOU SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT TO BE MORE
SHAUNA FROM LOS ANGELES CALLING
ON BEHALF OF WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOUR MIND OF. MINE
THREE SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GABRIEL BASSETT IN CINEMA
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FIFTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KIMBERLY
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. FOUR FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND THREE FORTY EIGHT
AHEAD. HELLO CUANDO LAS ANGELES
I AM CALLING FOR SAVE OUR
SENIORS AND PROGRESSIVE ASIAN
NETWORK FOR ACTION- STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. NINE
THREE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS BOB NAYLOR FOR FEELS
DEAD AND COMPANY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NINE FOUR
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR ELEVEN YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALTHOUGH I THINK I'M IN THE
WRONG LINE AYE OPPOSED SHOULD I
WAIT I WAIT SORRY YES PLEASE.
NINE FOUR FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS
JORDAN CRIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF STA THANKS SO MUCH.
NINE FOUR SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU AS I SAID BEFORE
THERE IS NO. MAIN WITNESS
OPPOSITION LET'S OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO OPPOSE THE BILL-
AND AGAIN STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT THAT
YOU OPPOSE. TO THE MODERATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
FOUR FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD I'M SORRY I JUST
GOT MY NUMBER ANY JUST A SECOND
BEHALF OF THREE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED REVERE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION RESIDENTS
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND THERE IS NO AFFORDABLE
UNITS THAT ARE CREATED IN THIS
BILL WE ACTUALLY OPPOSE IT
RUINS NEIGHBORHOODS. NINE THREE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LEAN BROKEN
SUNSET PARKSIDE DISTRICT SAN
FRANCISCO IN OPPOSITION. MY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE S. TO
LISA SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI WE'RE IN A
BIT OF AN IN BETWEEN POSITION
TODAY WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFTENTIMES FROM THE
DIVISIONAL CLARIFICATION TO THE
LANGUAGE. AND I JUST WANTED TO-
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THOSE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU.
NINE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FIVE
THANK YOU FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MELANIE ALLIANCE I
LIVED IN A RESIDENTIAL AREA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE- SB EIGHT
BECAUSE IT WILL RUIN ANY SENSE
OF SINGLE FAMILY DWELLINGS.
NINE THREE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS THAT JOHN OF COURSE J. I'M
FROM THE ZIP CODE NINETY SIX
SIX ZERO ON BEHALF OF THE
DEFENSE AGAINST. THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATE CONSULTANT
AND SPECIAL INTERESTS THAT WE
OPPOSE THAT WELL. NINE THREE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS THE
ANOTHER DOOR I AM FROM BRANDS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA EVERY
PRETENDING AT LANCE ARE BETTER
BRAND TOWARDS- AWAY OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF THOUSAND OAKS AND
CAMARILLO IN OPPOSITION.
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND ONLY
GAVE ALREADY PASSED NEAR
BURBANK. LITTLE CALIFORNIA SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS. SEVEN BILLION
POLITICAL SB THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS NOT BE CLEO I SAW MY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT. RIGHT. NINE
THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SANDY HUBBARD I'M
ACCOUNT HOMEOWNER IN MAGNOLIA
TREE VILLAGE I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE VALLEY VILLAGE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AS A
BOARD MEMBER. OCTOBER A MEMBER
OF THE UNITED NEIGHBORS WE'RE
STATING OUR OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JOSEPH KLEIN FOR THE
MIRACLE MILE RESIDENTIAL
ASSOCIATION. AND A MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS OPPOSED SB
EIGHT. NINE FOUR SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
MONTGOMERY AND WITH LOW
THOUSAND FOR A LITTLE
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA CITY
FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS LINDA BLANK
WESTWOOD HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS FIFTEEN HUNDRED
HOMEOWNERS WE OPPOSE SB EIGHT.
NINE THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NANCY
O'CONNOR AND WITH THE STATE OF
BOSS FELL EIGHT. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY
CAMPAñA AND I AM WITH. UNITED
NEIGHBORS SENATE-DISTRICT SORRY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY SEVEN
AND- I STRONGLY OPPOSE. AT.
NINE THREE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH HENRY FROM
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA. FROM ST
LAFAYETTE FROM LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA FROM UNITED
NEIGHBORS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
EIGHT THEY NEED TO START
TELLING THE TRUTH. NINE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
PEGGY RICH I AM A HOMEOWNER AND
MOUNT SHASTA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE THREE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NORA DOYLE
FROM STUDIO CITY RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION AND AYE OPPOSED SB
EIGHT. NINE THREE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU I'M DAVID
WHEATLEY A LOS ANGELES I'M A
MEMBER OF THE PARK AVENUE
OWNERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE FOUR
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SUSAN COLLINS JR
TODAY I REPRESENT THE LAFAYETTE
HOMEOWNERS COUNCIL WHICH HAS A
MEMBERSHIP OF OVER SIXTY
HOMEOWNERS GROUPS IN OUR TOWN.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB EIGHT
AND ALSO S. B. NINE AND TEN
THANK YOU. NINETEEN NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM BEVERLY HARLEM FROM
MOUNT SHASTA AND I AND MANY
MANY OTHER MANCHESTER RESIDENTS
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT SUPPORT S. B.
EIGHT. NINE THREE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS MARCELLA SERRANO ARE
FOR MY LADIES- UNAFFILIATED
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB EIGHT AND
ALL THE OTHER WINNER AT ALL
BILLS ON HOUSING. SHE SAID.
NINE FOUR ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SANDY
GABION I'M FROM HOLLYWOOD
FRANKLIN CORRIDOR COMMUNITIES
ARE WITH UNITED NEIGHBORS WE
ALSO SUPPORT LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO IT. I
THINK THESE BILLS WILL DO
NOTHING TO GET IT OUT OF THOSE
CRISIS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE ALL
OF WIENER AND SKINNER BILLS. AT.
MY FOUR OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
ISN'T YOUR CAR FROM LIVERMORE
CALIFORNIA MONTAGE ASSOCIATION
AND WE VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. NINE THREE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIME THREE EIGHTY YOU
MAY BE ON YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS SHE
GOING TO DO WITH LIVABLE
RIVERSIDE IN MARINO VALLEY WE
OPPOSE. THANK TO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL MONIES KIRSTEN AND
KERN COUNTY AND I OPPOSE S. B.
EIGHT ALL. NINE THREE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS KEVIN GUTHRIE
FROM MOORPARK CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NUMBER EIGHT
SB EIGHT. ONE TWO EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS KERRY OKAY
I'M A PLANNING COMMISSIONER. IN
SARATOGA I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
EIGHT. WE GOT IN TROUBLE WITH
ONE OF THESE IN OUR CITY AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT HOW TO RESOLVE
IT WITHOUT PAYING FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DWELLING.
TO THE DEVELOPER WHO WANTS TO
DEVELOP ON A TOXIC SITE. NINE
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VICTORIA GOLD
MOUNT SHASTA AT REPRESENTING
WATER FLOWS FREE. SINCE FOR
QUALITY GROWTH AND NOT SHASTA
TOMORROW PLUS A NUMBER OF
LITTLE CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE. ONE TWO FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB THIS IS RECALL
REPRESENTING LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND THE CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK
LIMITING PUBLIC PROCESS IS
UNCONSCIONABLE OPPOSED SB.
EIGHT I'M THREE TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAFFEY
KNIGHT FRIENDS ATTEND SAID PARK
IN SANTA MONICA- AREA AND- WE
STRONGLY OPPOSES WE DON'T SEE
ANY AFFORDABLE HOUSING LISTED
ON ON THIS BILL AND- WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. MY
TWO SEVENTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. H. JANET
WEST AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
EAST SIDE LOYCE IN LONG BEACH I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT. NINE
THREE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
JILL STEWART- ANGELENOS FOR
TREES AND THE MOBILE CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THAT PROVIDES YOU KNOW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. LINE FOR
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOHNNY MURPHY AND I
STAND FOR MY ENTIRE COMMUNITY
NINE FIVE ONE TWO THREE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND P. EIGHT
THE BILL DOES NOTHING TO GET.
NINE FOUR TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GREETINGS THIS IS BARBARA
BRADY CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
ON BEHALF OF WEST WITHOUT
REPRESENTING THIRTY SIX HUNDRED
HOMEOWNERS AND CONDOMINIUM
OWNERS AND A MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS UNLIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE ROBINSON
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONALITY OF A GOOD
SCRIPT REPRESENTING OVER A
THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS RENTERS
IMPORTANT ALLEY AREA OF THE
CITY OF LAFAYETTE. REMEMBER THE
UNITED NEIGHBORS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT THANK YOU. I'M
FOR FIFTY FIVE YOUR MIND IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS GINA THORNBERG OF COALITION
FOR VALLEY NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT. WE ARE NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED LOCAL RESIDENTS TO
INCLUDE RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS
AND WE KNOW THAT THE GAME IS
BEING PLAYED THERE'S NO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEING
GENERATED ANYWHERE- AND THEN
THE PROJECT TO DO GENERATED IT
YOU'LL GET LIKE ONE OUT OF FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS. AND THIS IS WE
ARE VERY TIRED OF ALL OF THIS
OP HE'S GETTING CHEN AND GAS
LIGHTING THAT IS HAPPENING WITH
BILLS LIKE SB EIGHT NINE AND
TEN. THANK YOU. YEAH NINE FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S JENNIFER KENNEDY I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN PASADENA'S
HISTORIC BUNGALOW HEAVEN IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT.
MY FOR SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TRICIA CRANE
I CHAIR NORTHEAST NEIGHBORS OF
SANTA MONICA WE'RE FIGHTING TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF OUR CITY
AND OPERATOR MINIMUM LATER
LATER MONOMAKH BREEDER AS I
STATED BEFORE WE'RE ASKING
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO JUST
STATE YOUR NAME. AND
ORGANIZATION OF THE FACT THAT
THEY OPPOSE AGAIN AS I SAID
BEFORE WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMMODATE AS MANY PEOPLE AS
WE CAN WITHIN THE FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF TIME HERE SOMEONE
ASKED FOLKS TO PLEASE ABIDE BY
THOSE RULES OR ELSE THE
OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU OFF.
THANK YOU. OKAY I CONTINUED NO
COULD YOU STATE YOUR PLEASE
CONTACT NEXT WEEK NEXT. NINE
FOUR TWENTY SIX YOUR MIND. THE
NEW. HI ALRP ALL MARIN SO SORRY
HUGE RECAP. RIGHT NINE FOR ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MARCY
YEAH I'M NOT FROM THIS HOUSE
DATE SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY THIS TOOK SIXTY SIX WE
HAVE STRONGLY OPPOSED S. B.
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOUR
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
HEATHER KELLER A HOMEOWNER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT.
ONE THREE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAILING STEPHANIE FROM
SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE TWO
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
LAURA BREWER FROM LAKELAND
VILLAGE NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION L. A. COUNTY GOP HE
SIGHED VOICE OF LONG BEACH AREA
REPUBLICANS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SB EIGHT. NINE THREE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S GLENDA MANIAN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY CITY OF LAFAYETTE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S. B- EIGHT
NINE TEN. THANK. NINE FOUR
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR. JERRY
SPRINGER BURBANK CITY COUNCIL
OPPOSE SB EIGHT THANK YOU. NINE
TO FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURELY LAUREN
DELFI FROM DUBLIN CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH CALLIE LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA UNITED NEIGHBORS
TABLETS AND FEEL FREE I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAROLYN
DESK OF THE PRESIDENT OF LAMAR
PARK NINE THOUSAND EIGHT SOUTH
LA STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S. B.
EIGHT THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
GUADALUPE WATERS FROM KERN
COUNTY AND I IS WRONGLY OPPOSE
SB. NINE FOUR SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LEADER WAR BARK FROM
BAKERSFIELD I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT. ONE FOUR NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SUE O'CONNOR
FROM MADERA COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
S. B. EIGHT. NINE THREE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JOHN BLACK FROM
UNINCORPORATED ORANGE COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE THREE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARIELLE HALL
OF BERKELEY I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATHIS
MINIMUM FRAZIER- THAT IS WE'VE
GONE OVER FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
THIS TIME SO WE'RE GONNA BROWN
WE HAVE ONE LAST PARTY OKAY
THANK YOU WE'LL WE'LL DO THAT
ONE LAST PARTY. THANK YOU NINE
FOUR FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY I
GUESS SO. WE ARE CAN NO MORE
COMING THANK YOU GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH THAT LET
US BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS. TO
THE MOISTURE. CENTER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING YOUR BILL TO US
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE BEING
ABLE TO HEAR IT- YEAH I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE COMMENTS I HEARD WERE
ACTUALLY ALMOST ADDRESSING
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE APPROVING
SB THREE THIRTY THAT IS IN FACT
LAW RIGHT NOW. IN ALL THIS IS
AN EXTENSION TWO THREE THIRTY.
BUT MY QUESTION IS THE SUNSET
FOR THAT IS IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. AND SO IT ONLY HAS HAD A
YEAR OF NORMAL OPERATING
ENVIRONMENT. AND THEN COATED.
TO BE ABLE TO GET A FULL FLAVOR
FOR THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT THIS MAY HAVE. OR ANY OF
THE BENEFITS THAT IT MIGHT
HAVE- THAT WAS INTENDED FOR.
AND THAT SO MY QUESTION IS WHY
ARE WE TRYING TO DO AN
EXTENSION FOR SOMETHING THE SUN
SETS. IN FOUR YEARS WHEN WE
COULD WAIT ANOTHER TWO OR THREE
YEARS TO SEE IF THIS IS
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMMER NOT- OR
IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
MIGHT WANT TO BE. ADDRESSED IF
SOMEBODY WANTS TO ATTEMPT TO
EXTEND THIS AND ALSO WHY FOR
THE ENTIRE FIVE YEARS FROM
TWENTY FIVE TO. TWENTY THIRTY-
BECAUSE IT JUST SEEMS A LITTLE
BIT PREMATURE FOR ME- I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION VERY
GOOD QUESTION- WHEN WE FIRST.
THE WHEN I SAID IT DOESN'T
CHANGE LOCAL LAWS. IT
ABSOLUTELY RESPECTS THE ZONING
THE DESIGN REVIEW STANDARDS THE
LAND USE POLICIES THAT ARE ON
THE BOOKS AT THE POINT THAT IT
BECAME LAW WHICH WAS JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY. AND IT IN
EFFECT HOLDS THOSE IN PLACE
WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS BUT IT
HOLDS THOSE IN PLACE THEN FOR
THE PERIOD THE BILL'S EFFECTIVE
AND AS YOU POINTED OUT MY
PURPOSE TODAY IS TO HOLD THOSE
IN PLACE FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS TILL TWENTY THIRTY AND
PARTLY BECAUSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AS MANY OF US KNOW.
MANY OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
PERMIT ISSUING OFFICES IN
EFFECT CLOSEST AND THEY'RE
PLANNING COMMISSIONS- ZONING
BOARDS DID NOT MEET YOU KNOW
JUST LIKE WE DID EVERYBODY WAS
ADJUSTING TO THE PANDEMIC WE
KNOW THAT THERE WAS ALSO A HALT
ON CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES FOR
AWHILE. SO THE REASON I WANTED
TO ALLOW IT THIS BILL TO HAVE
MORE TIME IS BECAUSE THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS STILL HERE
ALL OF THE REASONS WHY THREE
THIRTY WERE NEEDED STILL REMAIN
AND- THAT WHEN WE-
NOTWITHSTANDING THE VARIOUS
CRITICISMS THAT SOME OF THE
CALLERS CALLED IN THIS ONE
REALLY JUST SAYS IF THERE IS A
HOUSING AN APPLICATION THAT
MEETS YOUR RULES LET'S JUST
GIVE IT SOME TIME CERTAIN FOR
THE PROCESSING AND THEY'RE
STILL YOU KNOW LOTS OF PUBLIC
HEARINGS THAT ARE ALLOWED AT
LEAST FIVE FOR EXAMPLE. AND
THERE IS- THE ABILITY TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE PROJECT
APPLE APPLICANT FOR YOU KNOW
THINGS TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS THERE'S
NOTHING THAT PREVENTS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM DOING THAT BUT
WHAT THIS DOES IN THE BENEFIT
OF EXTENDING IT IS IT IT LEAST
GIVES AN APPLICANT THE
CERTAINTY BECAUSE AS WE KNOW TO
PUT ALL THE MATERIALS TOGETHER
THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OFTEN REQUIRED IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE YOU'RE A PROJECT
HEARD ITS THIRD THOSE ARE
EXTENSIVE AND THEN IN THE
PROCESS OF THOSE HEARINGS AS
YOU'RE NEGOTIATING CHANGES TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITY CONCERNS YOU
ALSO SOMETIMES HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD. SO WE
KNOW THAT EVEN WITH THE
CERTAINTY AND THE TIME FRAMES
THAT THIS BILL- PROVIDES. ARE
AT PRIVATE YOU KNOW HOUSING IT
TAKES A WHILE SO IT WAS REALLY
IN RECOGNITION OF THAT WE HAD
THIS PAUSE SO LET'S GIVE THIS
THING THE CHANCE TO REALLY WORK
AND THEN IT SUNSETS. AND IF WE
FEEL THAT IT DIDN'T WORK WE CAN
NEVER BRING IT BACK. OR AS YOU
SUGGESTED IF THERE ARE SOME
SERIOUS ISSUES WE CANNOT JUST
MIDSTREAM BUT SO FAR IN YOUR
RIGHT THERE HASN'T BEEN THE
WHOLE FIVE YEARS FOR IT TO
APPLY BUT SO FAR. THE MAIN
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME UP OR
WORSEN THINGS AROUND THE
DEFINITIONS AND WE INCORPORATED
THOSE IN THE TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATIONS AND WE GOT THOSE
DIRECTLY FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO WE HAVE
ADDRESSED THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE BROUGHT TO US AND AS YOU
HEARD IN THE CALLS YOU DIDN'T
HEAR MANY CITY YOU HEARD.
RESIDENTS COMPLAINING BUT YOU
DID NOT HEAR CITIES OR COUNTIES
CALLING IN OPPOSITION NOW CITY
OF LA WE'RE TALKING THEY HAD A
FEW I GET GAN TECHNICAL.
DEFINITIONS THAT THEY MAY WANT
US TO ADDRESS WHICH WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM RIGHT NOW BUT
OTHER THAN THAT YOU DID NOT
HEAR CITIES. BUT WITH A FEW
EXCEPTIONS SO THEY DON'T HAVE
THE PROBLEM WITH THE BILL THAT
THE- THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CALLING HALF. APPRECIATE THAT
NOW ALSO UNDER THIS UNDER THE
CURRENT BILL- AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE YOUR APPLICATION AND BY
THE LAST DAY OF THE SUNSET
CLAUSE. YOU'RE PROTECTED BY THE
BILL RIGHT RIGHT SO THEY HAVE
TO- TWENTY TWENTY FIVE UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. SO FAR I
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPLANATIONS
YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK YOU CALL
SAID COMMENTS MS WORKS. I THINK
YOU I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD-
I THINK FRANKLY YOU KNOW FIVE
YEARS IS TOO SHORT FOR ITS
ORIGINAL INCEPTION- WE HAVE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS WITH
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE AND
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO INCREASE
MY PRODUCTION ACROSS THE BOARD
I THINK IS CRITICAL- WE HAVE AN
OBVIOUS MENTION. MISMATCH ON
SUPPLY AND DEMAND- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I THINK
IT'S A THOUGHTFUL PIECE OF
POLICY- AND WOULD LIKE TO COULD
YOU SEE T MOVE FORWARD IN AND
HAVE- LOCAL FOLKS BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT. CHECK OUT
TO BE MOTION. OKAY IS OUR
SECOND. OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THE AUTHOR
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK LIKE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY I ALSO
THOUGHT THAT THE INITIAL TIME
FRAME WAS TOO SHORT I THINK WE
ALL COULD WISH THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS WOULD BE OVER IN A
COUPLE YEARS- BUT I THINK WE
ALL KNOW IT'S GOING TO TAKE
MORE THAN A FEW YEARS- BEFORE
IT IS ADDRESS CERTAINLY WITH.
CONTINUED OPPOSITION TO
BUILDING HOUSING AROUND THE
STATE AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SET THE RULES
OF ENGAGEMENT THAT THEY ARE
CLEAR- AND- THAT THEY ARE IN
PLACE FOR MORE THAN A FEW YEARS
SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS AND
LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHU HI CHIU
ICE AIRTEL NUMBER IN THEIR TURN
NOT VOTING GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SILVA. RIGHT QUICK SILVA AYE
WICKES. WICKES I. THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES THANK YOU WE WILL.
WAIT FOR OTHERS TO VOTE. FILE
ITEM TO S. B. TWO NINETY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR SO
THIS BILL. LIKE I FEEL LIKE I'M
JUST A REPEAT PERFORMANCE OF MY
LAST BILL WAS IN EFFECT TO
EXTEND SOMETHING THAT WE HAD
ALREADY PASSED THIS ONE IS A
BILL THAT SUCCESSFULLY PASSED
YOUR FLOOR LAST YEAR WITH SIXTY
SEVEN. VOTES THIS IS THE EXACT
SAME BILL THE ONLY ISSUE WAS
THAT IT DIDN'T IF WE WERE
UNABLE TO VOTE ON IT IN THE
SENATE ON THAT LAST DAY BECAUSE
WE HAD THE MIDNIGHT DEADLINE-
BUT IT IS EXACT SAME BILL SO I
HOPE THAT YOU WOULD-
APPRECIATED AND SUPPORTED AS
WAS DONE LAST YEAR. AND IT
MAKES JUST SOME TWEAKS TO OUR
DENSITY BONUS LAW TO HELP-
IMPROVE ITS EFFECTIVENESS AND
INCORPORATE THE ABILITY TO
INCLUDE STUDENT HOUSING IN THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW. AND WITH
THAT I WILL ASK MY WITNESSES
DAVID GARCIA FROM UC BERKELEY
STERN- CENTER AND PATRICK
KENNEDY FROM PANORAMIC INTEREST
TO- PERCENT. TO THE WITNESSES.
AND THE OPERATOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
GARCIA I AM THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT THE JURORS ENTERPRISING
INNOVATION AT UC BERKELEY WE
ARE HOUSING RESEARCH AND POLICY
ORGANIZATION AT BERKELEY THE
FOCUS IS REALLY ON ALL MATTERS
OF HOUSING RELATED ISSUES FROM
OUR THANK YOU THE COST OF
BUILDING- TO- TO BARRIERS TO
CONSTRUCTION. AND TODAY I'M
HERE TO TEST. THERE SKINNER IN
PRINCIPLE BECAUSE OUR WORK HAS
SHOWN THAT THE DENSITY BONUS
LAW SHOULD BE REFORMS TO
ENCOURAGE GREATER USE
SPECIFICALLY. SOME RESEARCH WE
PUBLISHED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTIAL LAND
USE SURVEY. FOUND THAT FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA JURISDICTIONS
REPORTED TO US THAT THEY HAD NO
GET THE BONUS USAGE WHATSOEVER.
AND OTHER CITIES AND COUNTIES
THAT TOLD US THAT THEY DID HAVE
FIFTY DOLLARS PROJECTS MOST OF
THOSE JURISDICTIONS REPORTED
HAVING. ONLY ONE OR TWO
DOCUMENTS PROJECTS DURING OUR
THREE YEAR SURVEY PERIOD- IT'S
ALSO CLEAR THAT CHANGE TO THE
DENSITY ONCE ARE NEEDED TO
INCREASE ITS USAGE TO DRIVE NOT
JUST MORE HOUSE CONSTRUCTION
OVERALL. BUT ALSO DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT CRITICAL
TO NINETY. IMPORTANT TARGETED
STEPS TO IMPROVE THE
UTILIZATION OF THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW BY EXPANDING OUR
HOMEOWNERSHIP CONCERT HOUSING
PROVISIONS WHICH ARE BOTH.
CRITICAL AREAS OF NEED THESE
ARE REALLY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD REFORMS THAT
COULD HELP NUDGE MORE BUILDERS
TOWARDS USING THE DENSITY BONUS
IN MORE PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE. WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
MISSING PART OF THE CHANGES
BECAUSE MOST DON'T HAVE
SELECTED THANK SENATOR. AFTER
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER KENNEDY. YES
THANK YOU MY NAME IS PATRICK
KENNEDY AND I'M THE OWNER
PANORAMIC INTERESTS-
DEVELOPMENT FIRM THIS BEEN
DEVELOPING INFILL HOUSING IN
THE BAY AREA SINCE- NINETEEN
NINETY- I WAS FIRST DEVELOPER
TO USE THE DENSITY BONUS IN
BERKELEY IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT THE FIRST OF ALL OF HER
TO USE THAT THE PRODUCTS AND
CISCO. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN- AND
I'D LIKE THAT AND THE RESULTS
IN BOTH CITIES HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
DEVELOPMENT OF OTHER DEVELOPERS
THAT HAVE USED THE DENSITY
BONUS TO BILL- MORE HOUSING
AFFECTED BERKELEY HAS SEEN
SEVERAL HUNDRED IN FACT I THINK
CLOSE TO TWO THOUSAND NEW UNITS
OF HOUSING FELT. ALMOST ALL OF
WHICH WERE A DENSITY BONUS AND
I THINK THE LAST FIFTEEN
PROJECTS IN SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
YOU THAT'S THE BONUS LOS WELL
SO IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL-
AND IT'S SIMPLE TO ADMINISTER-
IT'S IT SUCCEEDED BEYOND I
THINK ANYONE'S MACHINATIONS.
ALTHOUGH IT WAS SMALL SLOW IN
COMING THE REVISIONS THAT- THAT
SENATOR SKINNER ARE PROPOSING
TODAY ADDED ADDITIONAL VALUE TO
THE DENSITY BONUS ESPECIALLY IN
THE AREA STUDENT HOUSE- I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WHICH DID NOTHING
AT BUILT IN BERKELEY AND SAN
FRANCISCO ARE KIND OF
MASTERPIECES WITH UC BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF THE ARTS
DISCARDED INSTITUTE AND OTHERS
AND A SIGNIFICANT- I THINK. IN
DENSITY BONUS LAW HAS BEEN THE
INABILITY OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT ARE
CREATED WITH THE DENSITY BONUS-
SENATOR SCANNERS- REVISIONS-
CORRECT THAT AND PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT INCENTIVE. TO BUILD
DEDICATED STUDENT HOUSING IN
CITIES THAT MADE. IT OUT
BERKELEY IN PARTICULAR. I HAVE
40% OF ITS UNABLE TO LIVE WITH
THE- TO OF. AND THERE ARE WHO
IN CARS- IT- THIS LAW SB NINETY
TO A WONDERFUL. AND EFFECTIVE
JOB OF ENCOURAGING DEVELOP OF
STUDENT HOUSING IN PARTICULAR
AND OTHER HOUSING GENERAL AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU. SO WITH THAT LET'S
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ON TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR- MEMBERS THAT
WISH TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
LET'S START HERE IN THE
CHAMBER- WE'VE TO INDIVIDUALS-
PLEASE YOURNAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND- THE FACT YOUR
SUPPORT. AFTER GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR CHRISTOPHER KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL NINETEEN NINETY
THANK YOU. ALEX WAS ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
IN SUPPORT. UNLESS I GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS. AND
NOW LET'S OPEN UP PHONE LINES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FOUR NINETY THREE
ONE FOUR NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
PICK ME FAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HELPING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
NINETY THANK YOU. FOUR TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANASTASIA
KOWALCZYK WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
VISORS ON BEHALF OF FELLOW IN
SUPPORTER SB TWO NINETY THANK
YOU. THREE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. AFTERNOON MISTER
KERRY MEMBERS OF THE NOT A LOT
LIKE A PUBLIC AFFAIR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT AT THE
END OF THE COMPLAINING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
HONEST BURKE CALIFORNIAN BEAT
GMG PARTNER THE COUNCIL
THEMSELVES OTHERS. CIRCULATE
SAN DIEGO AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
FIVE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI DON ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL CLIENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE SEVEN TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EARLIER THIS
IS RUN I'M SORRY THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR- REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD
AND COMPANY STRONGLY SUPPORTING
S. B. TWO NINETY. FOUR TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALISON
SELLAR AND LOS ANGELES I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
NINETY AND- HUNDREDS OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND HUNDREDS UPON OUT
PEOPLE NEED HELP THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL YOUR. THREE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
BERKELEY INTO PORT THANK YOU.
FIVE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
MELISSA HI ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THANKS
SO MUCH. THREE FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- THIS PROBLEM
PROGRAM TO PUT SAN FRANCISCO
UNIQUE. WHAT THANK YOU. FOUR
FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TWO
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. WHAT NOT
RESPONSIBLE BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
FOR THIRTY FOUR FOUR THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN- HI MY
NAME IS IN THE WET AND A POOL-
SB TEN- BECAUSE OF THE REGION'S
LOCATION. THIS IS SORRY WE'RE
ON SB TWO NINETY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU CAN TESTIFY- WHEN
WE BRING UP SB TEN LATER IN
TODAY'S HEARING. BACK TO THE
OPERATOR. FOR TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BACKING CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE AUTOMATICALLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. LET'S
NOT RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I ADD TO THE
MARSH HONORED CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES ON BEHALF OF WEBSITE
FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TWO SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI ADAM BOOKBINDER
FROM CITY OF CAMPBELL AN EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHT SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF SAP THE INDIAN SUPPORT SB
TWO NINETY. BEFORE WE OPEN FOR
NINETY NINE AS A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WANT TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE TO THE
EURO AT THIS TIME. FOUR NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. A
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MARCUS
ALLEN TELL THEM SANTA CRUZ-
CALLING IT QUITS. THANK YOU.
THREE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. I'M A BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER FOUR THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. H. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MANY OF REPRESENTING FOUND THEY
EVER GREEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
FOR SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR ONE FIVE A CLEAR LINE
ITSELF. CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU YES HELLO. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU I WASN'T FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROCESS PLEASE DON'T
SOUND ANGRY OR CONDESCENDING- I
WAS A FIND IT AND I DIDN'T KNOW
IF I WOULD READ THE REFINED A
NUMBER EACH WITH EACH BILL- I
AM ELIZABETH MONTGOMERY I'M
WITH PORTABLE CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS- CALIFORNIANS FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILLS AND PROCESS IT IS.
NOT AS TRANSPARENT AS I WOULD
EXPECT OF MY ELECTED GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR ONE FORTY SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT IT SEEMS THAT YOU GUYS
BLACK PEOPLE FROM INDIA ARE
PEOPLE WHO OPPOSE TANK TOP
PLANTS PEOPLE FOR SO I'M
TREATING MELANCHOLIC AND OF THE
OPINION OF VALIANTE ON BEHALF
OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY SB I AM
A STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE TO SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO SIX FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN ORDER
WITH NO RESPONSE WILL RELEASE
THE LINE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LETTERS NOW
GO TO THE OPPOSITION THERE IS
NO MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESS SO
LET'S OPEN UP THE LINES FOR.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO WISH
TO OPPOSE SB TWO NINETY AGAIN
WE ASK YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT
THAT YOU OPPOSE. TO THE
OPERATOR. WISH TO OPPOSE SB TWO
NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THREE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW I THOUGHT I
WOULD GET ASSIGNED ANOTHER
NUMBER FOR THE BILL BUT- DID
YOU CAN BE ON A CONTRACT FONG
WOULD OPPOSE THAT A. B. NINETY.
AND I HOPE THE AND THE
BENEFICIAL DUMP AGAIN THAT NOT
THAT THE FACT THAT RESIDENTS
AND A COMPLETE. JOHN OUT OF
THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
NUMBER THE PUBLIC POLITICS MY
APOLOGIES ONE FOUR SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU I LOOK
AT MY CAMERA AGAIN WITH A
COUNTLESS OPTIONS FOR LEVEL
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS FOR LOCAL CONTROL ON
STRONGLY OPPOSE I'M SORRY IF I
WAS IN THE WRONG QUEUE BEFORE
THAT WITH AN ERROR ON MY PART
THE LET ME CORRECT THAT NOW.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN-
HIGH- NATURAL PRODUCTS.
SUSTAINABLE OSTALIH STRONGLY
ABOUT THANK YOU. FIVE TO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. FIVE TO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
MIND IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. THIS IS SEAN JAMIE.
MISTER KING ARE YOU THEY'RE
ABLE BONTA MY NUMBER TO. THANK
YOU LET'S JUST MOVE ON THANK
YOU. NINE TO FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH LAURA BREWER
LAKE WOULD DILIGENTLY OVERHEAD
ASSOCIATION EAST SIDE VOICE
LONG BEACH AREA REPUBLICANS
OPPOSE SB. TWO NINETY. LINE
THREE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO DISTRO CONTRA COSTA
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THREE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MATURING
CHANGE LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND AYE OPPOSED TO NINETY. SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
NINE THREE SIX THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOU'RE MUTED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. I'M SORRY I
THOUGHT I WOULD BE CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW. YES MA'AM. OKAY
ELIZABETH HENRY LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. STRONGLY OPPOSED FROM
LIBERAL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND SAY
LAFAYETTE. AND THERE IS NO
AFFORDABLE IN THIS BILL EITHER.
NINE FOUR SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HEY THERE THIS IS
SANDRA WALLACE FROM THE
MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENT THAT
THE ACTION OF SILICON VALLEY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THREE NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF YOU MUTED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. NO RESPONSE BERMAN
BONTA LINE NUMBER THREE TWENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DAVID
WHEATLEY MEMBER OF PARK AVENUE
OWNERS ASSOCIATION LA LIVABLE
CATALYST IN CALIFORNIA CITY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. TWO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
COMPANY'S KIRSTEN IN KERN
COUNTY BAKERSFIELD KERN COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL S. B.
TWO NINE ZERO. TWO FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE CALL
WILL BE CALIFORNIA'S AND
CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK FIFTY
TO NINETY REDUCE THE PORTABLE
HOUSING. BETWEEN PRACTICE WE
ARE CLOSE. THREE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AB JUST
AFFECT ON BEHALF OF THREE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED REVERE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION RESIDENTS
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
THE PUBLIC CALIFORNIA AND LIKE
ALL OF THESE TERRIBLE
ACCOUNTING BILLS THEY DO NOT DO
WHAT THEY PRETEND TO DO THIS IS
NOT ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO NINETY.
FOUR EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YES HI THERE THIS IS
TED TO PERISH WITH LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION AND I HOPE
THE MEMBERS- OUR
REPRESENTATIVES LISTEN TO THE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. FOUR FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RESIDENTS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TWO NINE
ZERO. FIVE THREE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS GREAT
LOWER RIVER CATALYST I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. TWO NINETY. FIVE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THIS IS MARCH SECOND FROM LOS
ANGELES MIRACLE MILE-
NEIGHBORHOOD I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
GIVEAWAY TO DEVELOPERS THANK
YOU. ONE TWO FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. TWO FOUR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO HUNDRED.
ONLY WHITES- SANTA MONICA
RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO NINETY. ONE THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MIKE VAN
DYNE CITY OF ALAMEDA LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED. FIVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
SRI JENNIFER KENNEDY PASADENA
L. A. COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI EDDIE WE CLEAN WATER
GOALS CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
RESIDENT- AND NOT SHORT TERM
RENTAL SPECULATOR I AM IN
OPPOSITION. AT FIVE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. CAROLINE
DECKS NUMBER PART RESIDENTS
FORMALLY OPPOSE. S. B. AND A
LOT BETTER FOR TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TRADEMARK HI I'LL
PRODUCT I'M IN STRONG AT
EVERYTHING IT'S ASKING. BILL A
HOUSE. AS DON'T LIVE IN A
PEOPLE THAT ARE AFRAID THEIR.
NINE THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE NINE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MA'AM. YOU HEAR ME WE CAN-
THANK YOU I DIDN'T REALIZE WE
HAD A MEMBERS BECAUSE HE HAD
TOLD ABOUT CATHY CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING- FIFTEEN FOR
QUALITY BOTH THREE AND ONCE
AGAIN A MEMBER OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BILL ON THE FIRST FLOOR OF
HOMEOWNER LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO NINETY.
THREE EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LIME THREE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR MIND
IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU THREE SIX. AND WITH NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER FOUR NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE FOUR ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WHILE OUR
LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN'T. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN. BUT IT'S GOING
TO BE WHAT IT FROM BIGGEST WILL
CALIFORNIA. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON
TO MY NUMBER THREE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THREE
EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES SIR-
MY NAME IS GLEN SO MANY
UNKNOWNS CONTRAST COUNTY
LAFAYETTE- I STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO TWO NINETY THANK YOU. ONE
THREE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I NEED LOGIN CENTER PARKS
I DISTRICT SAN FRANCISCO IN
OPPOSITION. LINE FOR SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER HOLDEN I AM
WITH MEGAN PARK NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
NINE AND ALSO A GLOBAL
CALIFORNIANS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO NINETY. ONE FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE KERN COUNTY BAKERSFIELD.
ALLMODERN STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWO NINETY. NINE FIVE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND FIVE
TO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN YEAH
HI THANK YOU THIS IS DAN
GREENSPAN FROM THE NORMAL
ASSOCIATION IN SANTA MONICA OF
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND MAKES
RESIDENCY- WE SUPPORT TRULY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PART OF
MOBILE CALIFORNIA UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO NINETY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE FOR FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
GINA THORNBERG WITH COALITION
FOR VALLEY NEIGHBORHOODS WE
OPPOSE ALL FORMS OF TRICKLE
DOWN ECONOMICS- BILL AND
THEREFORE WE OPPOSE THIS ONE
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE OPEN LINE
THREE EIGHTY FIVE AS A REMINDER
IF YOU LIKE TO OPPOSE SB TWO
NINE ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO NINE THREE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KRISTEN
RASMUSSEN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE VALLEY
NEIGHBORHOOD STRIP BURKE IS
RUNNING A THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS
RENTERS AND THE BIRD BALLY.
AREA CODE NINE FOUR FIVE FOUR
NINE. WE ARE MEMBERS UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FOUR TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
BARBARA GRADY FROM BLACKS
ANGELES REPRESENTING WEST WITH
SELF MADE UP TO THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS UNLIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND WE DO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FIVE TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. CAN HEAR ME.
YES JOHN CHENEY WITH ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA A CONCERNED CITIZEN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO NINETY
THANK YOU. BLIND TO SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
LISA MORRIS THAT THE QUESTION
OF VALLEY AND REPRESENTING-
CRESCENTA VALLEY COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AND THINGS
THAT INCREASES OUR ENCOURAGES
DENSITY BONUSES- WE ARE AGAIN
THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH
THAT LAW. A NINE FIVE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
PATRICIA GANNON ALAMEDA
CITIZENS TASK FORCE I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO NINE OO IT
PROVIDES NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR FOUR FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE FOR
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO. HELLO WEEK WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY THIS IS MONEY
CAMPAIGN FROM SAN JOSE STRONGLY
OPPOSING- SB TWO NINETY AND I
AM WITH APPLICABLE CALIFORNIAN
UNITED NEIGHBORS. BEFORE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES DANNY
GEGEN WITH HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN
CORAL COMMUNITIES UNITED
FAVORITE RECORD CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T NEED ANYMORE DENSITY
BONUSES WE NEED REAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESS CRISIS IT
DOES NOT WORK. THANK YOU. WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN I'LL SUPPORTING
SB TWO NINETY PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET IS NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COLLEAGUES ANY DISCUSSION.
THERE'S BEEN I'M THE MOTION
MOVING TO SECOND- LET ME JUST
SAY TO THE AUTHOR I THINK MANY
OF US SUPPORT OF THIS BILL LAST
YEAR GLAD THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT
IT BACK AND- I THINK I WILL SAY
THIS CONTRARY TO. MANY OF THE
SUGGESTIONS- FROM SOME OF THE
FOLKS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
DENSITY BONUS HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ACTUALLY
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION
IT SO IT'S A UNIQUE TOOL THAT
INCENTIVIZES FOLKS TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- TO
ENCOURAGE THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- IN THE WAYS
THAT IT'S BEEN STRUCTURED SO
THAT REALLY IS THE GOAL OF
THIS- SO I HAVE TO MATT I WAS A
LITTLE CONFUSED BY SOME OF THE
COMMENTS- BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY THAT- LET
ME ASK IF THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS MISS CORK SILVA. YES I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING IN THE SPACE RELATED TO
HOUSING- THERE IS QUITE A BIT
OF CONCERN AS WE HEARD ON THE
LINES BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN WE LOOK AT
HOUSING AS A WHOLE AND WE LOOK
AT WHETHER IT'S MARKET RATE
WHETHER IT'S AFFORDABLE. AND
EVEN WITH THE HOMELESS CRISIS
SHELTERS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE KNOW FOR SURE. IS THAT WE'RE
NOT BUILDING ENOUGH. WE HAVE
PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS. ARE ON
ALMOST EVERY CORNER IN
SACRAMENTO BUT THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. BUT THIS ALSO ADDRESSES
STUDENT HOUSING AND MORE AND
MORE WE'RE SEEING EVEN IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I REPRESENT
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY- WITH
FULLER TEN COLLEGE. IN MY CITY
THAT I LIVE IN THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS CYPRESS
COLLEGE. AND THE PRESIDENTS OF
THOSE COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
ASKING. US FOR QUITE A LONG
TIME FOR US TO START TO
ADDRESS.UP COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WE THINK ABOUT FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES R. C. ISSUES ARE UC'S
AND MANY TIMES THEY HAVE
HOUSING ON CAMPUS. MANY TIMES
THEY WORK FOR PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS. BUT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE STUDENTS ARE MANY
TIMES ARE LEFT OUT OF THESE
EQUATIONS- MANY TIMES WE ASSUME
THAT. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS OR JUST GOING TO
REMAIN LIVING AT HOME. AND AS
WE'VE SEEN THAT IS NOT ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STUDENTS HAVE BEEN HIT
EXTREMELY HARD THIS YEAR WITH
ENROLLMENT ACTUALLY WAY DOWN.
PART OF THE REASON IS BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO GO BACK TO WORK.
BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES HAVE
LOST JOBS SO THIS BILL I THINK
CAN AND WILL ADDRESS SOME OF
THIS HOUSING THAT WE SO
DESPERATELY NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
BACK TO THE CENTER FOR ANY
FINAL WORDS. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND- IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THOSE
WHO WERE CALLING IN JUST NEVER
EVEN SUPPORTED THE ORIGINAL
CALIFORNIA'S ORIGINAL DENSITY
BONUS BILL. I WOULD SAY THAT
THEIR COMMENTS REGARDING THIS
BILL WOULD REFLECT NOT A
CAREFUL READ BECAUSE THE
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT THE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT FEATURE OF
THIS BILL IS TO ALLOW. STUDENT
HOUSING TO BENEFIT FROM THE
EXISTING LAW AND THE ONLY
REASON STUDENT HOUSING COULDN'T
BENEFIT IN THE PAST IS BECAUSE
STUDENT HOUSING IS CONFIGURED
DIFFERENTLY AND OUR LAW OUR
REGIONAL ALWAYS BASED ON-
SOMETHING WITH A KITCHEN. AND
YOU KNOW EITHER STUDIO OR OR-
ONE OR TWO BEDROOM OR WHATEVER
BUT IT HAD TO HAVE A DISTINCT
KITCHEN. AND OF COURSE WE KNOW
THAT STUDENT HOUSING IS OFTEN
CONFIGURED WHERE THERE IS A
COMMON KITCHEN FOR MULTIPLE
FLOORS OR KITCHEN PER FLOOR.
AND THAT THE UNITS ARE REALLY
MORE LIKE STUDIOS BUT WITHOUT A
KITCHEN AND SO THIS BILL JUST
ALLOWS FOR WHAT WE KNOW IS THE
CONFIGURATION OF STUDENT
HOUSING. TO BE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM DENSITY BONUS AND IF THEY
IF THE PROJECT IS DEDICATING A
CERTAIN PERCENT OF THE UNITS.
OF IN THAT PROJECT FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS FOR LOW IT YOU
KNOW MOVED PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THEN IT
WOULD BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW SO IT'S
REALLY IT'S KEY FEATURE AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHIELDS HI CHIU AYE
SEROTONIN FARED THEY ARE TO AYE
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I KALRA. KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN. A QUICK
SILVA ALL RIGHT QUICK SILVA AYE
WICKS. THAT BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
YOUR BILL IS PASSED. THEY HAND
WITHOUT THANK YOU SENATOR LET'S
NOT GO TO FILE ITEM THREE SB
NINE BY THE SENATE. AS A
PRETEND TONI ATKINS- HERE WE
HAVE TO PRESENT THE BILL- THE
CHAIR OF THE- SENATE GOVERNMENT
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE CENTER
MCGUIRE SOME OF OUR GOOD TO
HAVE YOU. MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON GET SITUATED HERE.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR GOOD TO
SEE YOU MISTER CONSULTANT GOOD
AFTERNOON I WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR SINCERE ENGAGEMENT IS
ALWAYS ON ALL LEGISLATION AND
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
VERY CAPABLE HOUSING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. AND MEMBERS I KNOW THAT
THIS BILL MAY LOOK VERY SIMILAR
TO LAST YEAR AS THE PROTEIN-
ADVANCED SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY LAST SESSION- WE TOOK A
GOOD BILL THAT MET THE FATE OF
A HARD DEADLINE LAST YEAR AND
AFTER LISTENING TO FEEDBACK
FROM HOMEOWNERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SHE IMPROVED UPON.
SB NINE PROMOTES SMALL SCALE
NEIGHBORHOOD DRIVEN RESIDENTIAL
OPTIONS STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS FOR A HOMEOWNER TO
CREATE A DUPLEX OR SUBDIVIDING
EXISTING NOT IN RESIDENTIAL
AREAS AND TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOR UP TO FOUR UNITS YEAH RIGHT
NOW STATE LAW PROVIDES FOR THE
ABILITY TO BUILD THREE UNITS
SINGLE FAMILY HOME JD YOU AND
EIGHTY U. S. B. NINE STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL IN
CREATING THE ENVIRONMENT IN
OPPORTUNITY- UP FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF A SMALL SCALE
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE SO. BADLY
NEED TO BE A COMBAT OUR STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS WE NEED ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
HOMES EVERY YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
TO KEEP UP WITH CURRENT DEMAND
RIGHT NOW WE'RE BUILDING EIGHTY
THOUSAND HOMES IF WE TOOK AB
TAKE A LOOK AT L. A. COUNTY
ALONE IN THE NEXT RINA CYCLE L.
A. COUNTY WILL NEED ONE POINT
THREE MILLION. UNITS NOW THERE
ARE SOME EXEMPTIONS IN THIS
BILL THAT I LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
OUTLINE. NUMBER ONE THIS BILL
WILL NOT APPLY TO HISTORIC AND
AS WELL AS LANDMARK DISTRICTS.
CAN'T BUILD ON WETLANDS ON
PRIME AG LAND YOU CAN'T BUILD
CAN'T BUILD IN FLOOD ZONES IN
IF YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
POTENTIALLY DEVELOP AN INTERNAL
CORPORATE AREA YOU HAVE TO LOOK
FOR PROGRESS. PERCOLATION TEST.
NOW THI BILL ALSO PROTECTS
NEIGHBORHOODS FROM SPECULATION.
AND GENTRIFICATION AND IT COULD
OPEN UP THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL
UNITS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO
INTO THAT MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU
DON'T MIND. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COULD DEED RESTRICT THESE UNITS
TO ENSURE THEIR AFFORDABILITY.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT. AFFORDABILITY
IN THIS BILL BUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNDER THIS BILL
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE
TO DEED RESTRICT. ANY OF THE
DUPLEXES ON FOUR PLEXUS AT THAT
WOULD BE TRANSITIONED- IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THAT WOULD MEAN
CITIES AND COUNTIES COULD COUNT
THESE UNITS AT TOWARDS THEIR
NEXT AFFORDABLE HOUSING CYCLE
OVER THE NEXT DECADE. MISTER
CHAIR THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AS
WELL AS BRIDGE HOUSING ONE OF
THE LARGEST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS. IN THE STATE
SUPPORT SB NINE. NOW THERE'D
BEEN SOME STUDIES ON- EIGHTY
USER LIKE TO DISCUSS BECAUSE-
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ARE
ALMOST THE EQUIVALENT TWO
DUPLEXES. I'D LIKE TO FIRST
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SAME DISCO
BAY AREA AND LOOK AT SEVEN
CALIFORNIA. SO THERE IS A STUDY
ON THE AVERAGE RENTAL PRICE OF
AN EIGHTY YOU IN THE EAST BAY
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
AND WHAT THAT STUDY SHOWED IS
THAT EASY TO USE ARE AFFORDABLE
HAVE AFFORDABLE RENTS TO
SOMEONE MAKING 62% OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME. NOW WHY IS THAT
CRITICAL WELL RIGHT NOW UNDER
OUR STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WITH THE ADDICTION NOR
MORATORIUM. WE PROVIDE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE UP 280% OF AREA
MEDIAN INCOME FOR TENANTS
LIVING IN HOMES. AND IF WE LOOK
AT SOMETHING CALIFORNIA IN THE
AFFORDABILITY. IN L. A. COUNTY
RIGHT NOW SIXTY FIVE PERCENT.
TWO THIRDS OF ALL ALL. USE IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
COULD BE RENTED BY A RESIDENT
WHO IS IN THE LOWER INCOME
CATEGORY. TWO THIRDS IF WE LOOK
AT ORANGE COUNTY IT 68% OF ALL
EXCESSIVELY DWELLING UNITS IN
IN THIS BUDGET THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I TO BE
ABLE TO HELP FINANCING OF
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY USE THIS BILL
ALSO FOCUSES ON STRONG TENANT
PROTECTIONS- YOU CAN'T TURN TO
TRANSITION A SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSE TO A DUPLEX IF A TENANT
HAS LIVED IN THE DWELLING FOR
THREE YEARS YOU CAN'T EVEN DO A
LOT SPLIT- IF A TENANT HAS
LIVED IN THE SINGLE FAMILY HOME
FOR THREE YEARS. INCREDIBLY
STRONG TENANT PROTECTIONS
LOADED INTO THIS BILL IT'S BEEN
A PRIORITY FOR ME SACKINGS NO
ONE MODIFICATION IS THAT THIS
BILL COMPARED TO LAST YEAR
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
AUTHORITY TO ENACT AN OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS THAT'S
BEEN A VERY CLEAR AND LOUD-
PIECE OF FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
SO THERE IS AN ABILITY FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO
ENACT A OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS ANOTHER AMENDMENT
MADE MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE
NUMBER OF UNITS ARE ALLOWED ON
THE LOT. IS FOR IN ONLY FOUR.
SO THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
THAT YOU COULD BUILD FIVE YOU
CAN BUILD SIX YOU COULD BILL
TEN. UNDER THIS BILL. THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE ENCOURAGE
FOLKS TO LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE
YOU CAN BUILD FOR IN ONLY UP TO
FOUR. YOU CAN'T DOUBLE DIP. IF
A HOMEOWNER HAS A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME A. G. EIGHTY YOU AND IN
EIGHTY YOU ON A LOT NOW YOU
CAN'T GO BUILD ANOTHER FOUR
UNITS. IT'S CLEAR IN THIS BILL.
IN THIS BILL IS ALSO OPTIONAL
IT DOESN'T FORCE HOMEOWNERS TO
DO ANYTHING IT'S AT THEIR OWN
DISCRETION. THIS MERELY OFFERS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR HOMEOWNERS
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE WORKFORCE
HOUSING THAT WE ALL TALK ABOUT
EACH AND EVERY DAY THAT EACH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES IN BIG CITIES
AND SMALL SO DESPERATELY NEED.
AND I'D SAY TO THOSE WHO MAY
ARGUE THAT THIS COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE LOOK OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD. I THINK WE SHOULD
LOOK AROUND US IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THERE ALREADY ARE
BEAUTIFUL DUPLEXES- IN EXCESS
OF THE DWELLING UNITS NEXT DOOR
TO TRADITIONAL SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES IN SOME OF OUR STATE'S
MOST SOUGHT AFTER ZIP CODES.
EITHER CHARMING HOUSES THAT ARE
NOT ONLY A BRIGHT SPOT ON THE
BLOCK BUT A COMFORTABLE PLACE
FOR NOT JUST ONE. BUT TWO
FAMILIES TO CALL HOME. ALONG
WITH SAFEGUARDS IN THE PRO OUT
OF THE PROTEINS BILL AND I TO
QUICKLY DISCUSS THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDES FOR FAMILIES TO HAVE
MORE OPTIONS TO BUILD MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOUSING. AND BUILD
MULTI GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
INTERJECTION G.
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH IS A
CURRENCY WE ALL KNOW- THAT IS
CRUCIAL TO COUNTERING THE
INEQUITY- IN CREATING SOCIAL
MOBILITY. AND WHAT WE ALSO KNOW
IS A SINGLE FAMILY HOME IS A
CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER ONE
MISTAKE. AND NOW THIS IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WERE OUTDATED
ZONING LAWS HAVE CREATED
BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND OF LED TO
OVERCROWDING. THIS BILL
PROVIDES HOMEOWNERS WITH
OPTIONS PROVIDE RENTAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER WORKING
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
TO FIND A HOME IN THEIR PRICE
RANGE OR WHO MAY BE LOOKING FOR
THEIR OWN PATH TO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP. OR
CANDIDLY SOMETHING THAT MY WIFE
AND I ARE LOOKING AT A
POTENTIALLY MOVING IN OUR AGING
MOM TO BE ABLE TO LIVE RIGHT
NEXT DOOR. THIS BILL IS THE.
EXPANSION FOR OPPORTUNITIES.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. HOMEOWNERS
RENTERS IN FAMILIES ALIKE. THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
IS SO LARGE IN THE STATE
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A
SINGLE SOLUTION NO BILL WILL BE
A SILVER BULLET. BUT THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY SENATE BILL
NINE IT'S A CRITICAL PIECE TO
THE HOUSING PUZZLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE PROGRESSIVE
AND POSITIVE CHANGE IN STRENGTH
IN THE FABRIC OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH EQUITY
INCLUSIVITY MOST IMPORTANTLY
AFFORDABILITY MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE THE STATEMENT TODAY I HAVE
WITH US TODAY A LEASE BUTTE.
WITH UNITED WAY LA AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT WARRANTY VALENCIA
SANCIOUS IS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS. FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANKS VERY MUCH
OUR CENTER DID YOU SAY WANT TO
WIN ASSISTANCE ACTUALLY EUROPE
THE PROFESSION BE ON A
TELECONFERENCE ON THE
CONFERENCE SIGNS TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ALLOW THEM TO SPEAK. THIS IS
ONLY AIR CANADA KAY THANK. YES
YOU CAN. OKAY GREAT I THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME MY NAME IS THE
LEAST BE WRECKED I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND THE CEO OF UNITED
WAY OF GREATER LOS ANGELES AND
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE- THE WAY THAT OUR
RELATIONS WITH THE BUSINESS WE
NARROW THAT LAND USE POLICIES
ESPECIALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAS DRIVEN RACIAL
CONGREGATION AND WEALTH
DISPARITIES FOR DECADES. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IS DRIVING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. AND THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING
THESE BURDENS. MOST IMPORTANTLY
EVERY CENT REPORT LAST MONTH BY
THE LA CITY PLANNING DEPARTMENT
FOUND. THAT IN HIGH INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS ONLY 20% OF
DOWNING IS ALLOWING MULTI
FAMILY HOMES WHERE THEY LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS THAT'S
EIGHTY PERCENT. WE THINK THAT
THERE IS A DISPARITIES ARE NOT
MUCH LOCKED AND. AND WHAT ARE
NEIGHBORHOODS A BOOK LIKE. WE
BELIEVE THAT AS NINE ON BALANCE
BETWEEN RESPECTING LOCAL
CONTROL. AND CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SMALL SCALE
NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL BENEFIT THE BROADER
COMMUNITY. WE RECOGNIZE SB NINE
WILL NOT SOLVE OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ON ITS OWN
AND SO WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
CONTINUE TO PRESS FORWARD ON
ALL FRONTS. FROM INCREASING
RENTER PROTECTIONS TO
INCREASING PUBLIC FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO SUBSIDIZE HOUSING
FOR WORKING AND LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND WE'RE PROUD TO BE
WORKING ON MANY OF THOSE ISSUES
WITHIN YOU. UNITED WAY OF
GREATER LA STANDS WITH LEADERS
HERE WILLING TO REJECT THE
STATUS QUO AND ENVISION A
FUTURE WHERE EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A SAFE AND
STABLE HOME WITH THE DELEGATE
TRIED. SO I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO FOR THAT
PER TEN TINY ACTIONS FOR YOUR
COURAGE ENERGY THING THIS BILL
AND TO EACH OF YOU WHO IS GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. AND IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LAUREN TABLE ANTI ARE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO JOIN SENATE PRO TEM ATKINS
AND TODAY PLAN TO ACQUIRE IN
SUPPORT OF THE NINE. HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
CONTINUE TO BE AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRESSING
ISSUES ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY
CAUSES OF THE HOUSING CRISIS.
WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS SOME OF
WHICH PLANNERS HAVE CREATED
PLAY A PART. UNDER CURRENT LAW
A MAJORITY OF RESIDENTIAL AREAS
CAN ONLY BE FOUND FOR SINGLE
FAMILY DWELLING THAT'S WHEN IT
HOUSING SUPPLY AND EXCLUDES
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FROM
HOUSING. THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. WE
BELIEVE SB NINE CAN BE PART OF
AN EFFORT TO EXPAND HELPING.
YOU MAY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERY. SB NINE DOES NOT
PROHIBIT SINGLE FAMILY HOMES OR
SONY IT SIMPLY PROVIDES WITHIN
SUCH AREA PROPERTY OWNERS MUST
ALSO BE ALLOWED TO CREATE SMALL
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING OPTIONS.
SB NINE CREATED BY RIGHT
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR THE CREATION OF TWO TO FOUR
HOMES AND SINGLE FAMILY ABOUT.
ALLOWS PARCEL MAPS TO CREATE A
LOT FROM ONE INCREMENTAL TO TWO
HOMES FOR A LOT. YOU OUGHT TO A
TWO YEAR EACH BACK. A YOU ARE
ALREADY ALLOWS UP TO THREE
UNITS PER A LOT BUT THIS IS AN
INCREMENTAL CHANGE BUT THE KEY
IS TO PERFORM OUT PROVISION
THAT ALLOWS NEW HOMES TO BE
SOLD WHICH WILL HELP CREATE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES NOT
AVAILABLE UNDER OTHER HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILLS. AND ALTHOUGH
THE APPROVAL PROCESSES
MINISTERIAL THE MAJORITY OF
OBJECTIVE PLANNING STANDARDS
WILL CONTINUE TO APPLY TO NEW
DEVELOPMENT BUT THERE'S A FEW
ACTION TO EXPEDITE THE ADOPTION
OF NEW IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS
THIS APPROACH HELPS BALANCE
STATE AND LOCAL INTERESTS SB
NINE DEFINES MINIMUM
PERFORMANCE TARGETS BUT IT
LEAVES THE GROUND FOR LOCAL
PLANNERS TO DEFINE AND APPLY
CONTACT SPECIFIC STANDARDS.
FINALLY AND OUR HOPE THAT
INCREASING HOUSING CHOICE
ANYTHING A FAMILY FILMS ON THE
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES MORE INCLUSIVE BUT
WE BELIEVE THAT SHOULD NOT COME
AT THE COST OF DESTABILISING
EXISTING HOME AND THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORT THE BILL SAFEGUARDS TO
PREVENT THE LOSS OF EXISTING
HOUSING AND THE DISPLACEMENT
AFFORDABLE TENANTS. APA
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT ZONING
REFORM TO END THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING ONLY SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES ON A MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTIAL LAND WE ARE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB NINE AND
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THIS THIS
POINT LET'S OPEN UP TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. B.
NINE ALLOWS THE OPERATOR TO
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES AND
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA ASK FOLKS TO
JUST STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT OF
YOUR SUPPORT SO DAVID CHIU SAN
FRANCISCO SUPPORT OF FOR
EXAMPLE- BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT
I'M GOING TO ASK IF THERE
MEMBERS SECURE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM WE DO HAVE ONE
NUMBER THE PUBLIC PLEASE STATE.
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND THE
FACTOR SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS ALEX OR AS A STRATEGY
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION AS
WELL AS THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
THE REGIONAL TESTIMONY STATIONS.
SEE NON LET'S GO TO THE
OPERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWENTY EIGHT IN Q. LOCAL
TO MY NUMBER THREE OH ONE THREE
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AND IF YOU'RE CARE NUMBER
BECAUSE THE MAN AT WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. MEDICAL PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
NOTICED BURKE FACEBOOK THE KIDS
KEEP THE COALITION GMG PARTNER
TEMPLE OF INFILL BUILDERS
CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO. HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA. AT THE
AT HOME. OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF AND. FEEL BAD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. TWENTY FOUR NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON A LITTLE DROP OF
QUANTUM PUBLIC SANTA CRUZ
YOU'LL BE CALLING IN SUPPORT.
ONE FIVE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS NORMAN APRICOT
CARPENTERS FEVERS REPRESENTING
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT.
BY FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN
HIGHER WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHECK NUMBER FOR US
BUT WE ON BEHALF OF STOCK NOW
MAYOR DALE STANFORD AND WILL
OPEN. FOR TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EVENING TACKLING
REPRESENTING EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE- EASTBURY P. FABIAN B.
GAME ARE IN THE ACTION AND
ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER THEIR NAME OFF
THE BRIDGE HOUSING IMPORTANT.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR HONORABLE
MEMBERS ARE RICHARD LONGER
CHEER GLOBAL SUNNYVALE ON
BEHALF OF LITTLE SUNNYDALE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
FIVE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS KATIE
KING I'M CALLING FROM UNION
CITY IN THIS ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY AND. I FOR TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MANY OUT RIGHTLY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING SOMEONE ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNSEL AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI I'M CHAMOMILE WITH AN
ANSWER FOR EVERYONE HOW OFTEN
EIGHTY TWENTY FOURTH SUPPORT SB.
NINE FIVE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AMY HìNH SHAKE WITH
ROUTE TAX CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
PETITION ON SB NINE FOR TWO
SMALL TWEAKS TO CONTEMPLATE
THAT CLP MODEL THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS CAROL KELLY
WITH NEIGHBORLY SANTA CRUZ
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT. FOUR TO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS ALLISON SCHALLER CALLING
FROM HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA I AM
IN FONG SUPPORT MY
ORGANIZATION'S STORAGE ON THE
PLOT MINUS IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND OUR UMBRELLA ORGANIZATIONS
HOLLYWOOD FOUR EIGHT. CONCEPT
POINT REPRESENTING THIRTY FOUR
O'CLOCK CALLING LET THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK
CHANGE. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RYAN
O'CONNELL CALLING FROM HOW TO
READ YOUR INSPIRED IT USE ANY
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE THREE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ROBERT JAMES
FRANCISCO YOUNG BEACON SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BRIAN PRESS GET CALLING
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA THE
NUMBER OF SOUTH NAY UNIQUE I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE TWO SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I AM ADAM
BOOKBINDER FROM CITY CAMPBELL
AN EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHT SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF SOUTH BAY YOU'D BE
PROBABLY SPORTING SB NINE. LINE
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS JORDAN CRIMES POLITICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS AND EIGHTY TWENTY TWO
HERE TO SHARE ORGANIZATIONS
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB NINE.
ONE FIVE SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MONICA GALA
CRUISE WITH YOU BE DEMOCRATS
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS EVERYTHING
LOOKING CLEAN UP LINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE FOUR NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS PAUL
DICK MORA CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE FIVE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARKETS OF ARCTIC HERE-
PRESIDENT EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA- WITH-
YOU'LL BE ACTUALLY STAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE FIVE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
WELL NELSEN OF PALO ALTO
NETWORKS WERE EVERYONE CLING
INTERCOURSE THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
RIGHT FOR NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JOHN
CORRECT OF NORWALK CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF AND ON BEHALF OF THE
NEXT GENERATION OF CALIFORNIANS
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE. ONE
FOUR FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KATHY BEING CALLING WITH MEN
BUT FOR EVERYONE ANY OF THE
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
NINE THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS TONYA
LEE I'M A RECENT COLLEGE GRAD
LIVING IN BEAUTIFUL EIGHTY
FIFTY THREE AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT- SB NINE. ONE
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR REPRESENTING FEELS
CERTAIN COMPANY HOWARD AHMANSON
JUNIOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS CRUCIAL LEGISLATION. ONE
FIVE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS HEATHER
BROUGHT FROM CINEMA AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JAN MORE FROM
WALNUT CREEK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIVE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS DOCTOR
BROUGHT CALLING FROM YEAH BE
ACTION OPINION COUNTY HOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. THANK
YOU. FIVE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
MARYLAND WELL AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'M A SINGLE FAMILY
HOMEOWNER AND LOS ANGELES AREA
I REPRESENT MY ORGANIZATION
STORIES FROM THE FRONT LINE. I
DID WAY AND HOLLYWOOD. FORWARD
WHICH IS A COALITION OF FORTY.
GROUPS THAT WORK ON
HOMELESSNESS AND HOLLYWOOD AREA
WE SUPPORT. NINE FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN MINOR
HOMEOWNER IN FAMILY ANDRO IN
STRONG SUPPORT- A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME IN TWO. THREE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE UNIT
SIX UNITS SEVEN NUMBER ONE.
OKAY YOUR LINE IS CURRENTLY
OPEN ONE THAT HAVE- CAN YOU.
BLINDED EIGHTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. SEVEN ZERO TWO YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF SANTA CRUZ GAMBIAN
PICKING IN SUPPORT. NINE FIVE
FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS MARKET ORIENTED-
SEMINAL CAUGHT RESIDENT WHO'S
HOPING NOT BE A PRICE OUT OF
THE CITY THAT REDUCE YOUR
PORTABLE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ESPIONAGE ACT. THREE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GABRIEL
BASSETT IN CINEMA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE PLUS BILLS
MOUNTING. NINE TWO FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS YOUR PAGAN I
REPRESENT THEIR P. AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LINE FIVE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I YES I
MY NAME IS JIMMY- WITH GREAT
MELLEY COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BUT I'M AN APPLICATION SB NINE.
I THINK I'M ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF THE YOU ARE IN THE WRONG-
THE WRONG LINE BUT THANK YOU
FOR REGISTERING OPPOSITION.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT BIGGER.
THANK FORTY SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
TRACY MULHOLLAND AND I
REPRESENT WILL REPRESENT SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY OR ETHNICITY
AND BEING AN CALIFORNIAN BE AN
ABUNDANT HOUSING LA AND- AS A
CITIZEN OF THE CITY OF AND YOU
KNOW I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. BUT NOT RESPONSIBLE
BONTA MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHT
SEVEN MARCHAND A CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES ON BEHALF OF
WEBSITE FOR EVERYONE INSTRUCTS
THE PORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE FIVE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
AMERICA GROUP OF MINE I WOULD
GENERATION HOUSING BASED ON MY
COUNTY CAN TRANSPORT. NINE FIVE
NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DO THAT IF YOU GO WITH NO THE
NEIGHBORS OF SAN FRANCISCO-
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
FIVE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS MATT ON
FOR TRACK- PART OF PENINSULA
FOR EVERYONE I LIVE IN
BURLINGAME CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING AND Q. VOICE ON A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS M. PAULSON
FROM LOS ALTOS ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ALTOS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE. NINE FIVE NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE SIX ZERO
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MORE A TOP ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO MAYOR TODD GLORIA IN
SUPPORT. ONE SIX ZERO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I HAD A CUSTOMER
FROM HAPPENING DIRECT RESIDENTS
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH WILL POUR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. SIX ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
MY AREA OF SAN FRANCISCO
GATEWAY ASSOCIATION STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. BEFORE
WE OPEN LINE SIX ZERO NINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THE
TIME. SIX ZERO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LAURA
SCOTT CALLING COMMUNITY ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT ALSO IN
SUPPORT NORTHERN NEIGHBORS
MOUNTAIN VIEW YEMENI. PEOPLE
FOR HOUSING ORANGE COUNTY
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE STREETS
FOR PEOPLE SAN FRANCISCO YIMBY
URBAN ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND
SOUTH BAY MD THANK YOU. ONE
THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. NOT RESPONSIBLE BONTA
LIKE NUMBER THREE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. AND ARE
RESPONSIBLE RELEASED A LINE. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH R. LET US
NOW GO TO THE MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH I WILL NOTE WE HAVE-
MADELEINE BARBER A MEMBER OF
THE ALTADENA TOWN COUNCIL AS
WELL AS BLANCA PACHECO WHO IS
THE MAYOR PRO TEM OF THE CITY
OF DOWNEY. TO THE OPERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME MEMECREATOR IF YOU
GO TO THE MAIN WITNESSES. SO TO
WONDER ABOUT OKAY. HIS BARBER
OR. MAYOR PROJECT NEAR NOW CAN.
YES I'M I'M ON THIS IS AMERICA
CZECHO- GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRAND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS BLANK
CHECK ON THE MAYOR PRO TEMPORE
THE CITY OF DOWNEY AS WELL THE
PROCESS THE PRESIDENT OF THE L.
A. COUNTY DIVISION OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
REPRESENTING EIGHTY SIX CITIES
IN THE COUNTY I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
ON BEHALF OF CAL STATE HE'S IN
THE L. A. COUNTY DIVISION SB
NINE AS PRESENTLY DRAFTED WOULD
REQUIRE CITIES TO MINISTER
EARLY APPROVED WITHOUT
CONDITIONS DISCRETION FOR
PUBLIC INPUT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT CONTAINING TWO
RESIDENTIAL UNITS. ON AN
INDIVIDUAL PARCEL IN SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS
ADDITIONALLY THIS MEASURE WOULD
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MINISTER EARLY APPROVED ON
URBAN LOT SPLITS THAT'S
CREATING TWO INDEPENDENT LOT
THAT MAY BE SOLD SEPARATELY
CALATHES AND THE ALLEY DIVISION
HAVE WORKED WITH THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF FOR SEVERAL MONTHS ON
AMENDMENTS. THAT WOULD HAVE
ADDRESSED OUR PRIMARY CONCERNS.
I'M FOR. WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT. HOWEVER WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
ARE AMONG THE MOST CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA'S
CITIES AFFORDABLY PRICED HOMES
OUT OF REACH FOR MANY PEOPLE
AND HOUSING IS NOT BEING BUILT
FAST ENOUGH TO MEET THE CURRENT
OR PROJECTED NEEDS OF PEOPLE
LIVING IN THIS STATE. WELL
CITIES DO NOT BUILD HOMES WE
LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION BY PLANNING AND
ZONING NEW PROJECTS BASED ON
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC INPUT AND
ENGAGEMENT STATE HOUSING LAWS
AND THE NEEDS OF THE PART OF
THE BUILDING INDUSTRY. FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS CALYCES IN THE
CITY OF DOWNEY HAVE
PERSISTENTLY PURSUED SOLUTIONS
TO THE HOUSING SUPPLY AND
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT IS
GRIPPING MANY REGIONS OF THE
STATE. THESE SOLUTIONS INCLUDE
STREAMLINING THE HOUSING
APPROVAL PROCESS CREATING A NEW
STATE AND LOCAL FINANCIAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. AND CONSOLIDATING
IMPORTANT HOUSING PROGRAM GRANT
APPLICATIONS. SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS ARE FALLING SHORT AND
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL ACTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR.
IN DOWNEY WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING TO OUR STATE MANDATED
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE WHICH
INCREASES ARE PLANNED HOUSING
PROJECTION FROM A THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN UNITS IN
OUR CURRENT PLANS. 260-005-0020
FIVE IN OUR NEW. EIGHT YEAR
PLAN COMMENCING JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THUS WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED NEW HOUSING AND
REZONING OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
OUR CITY TO ABSORB DAY
INCREASED DENSITY AND
ADDITIONAL UNITS. WE FOCUS
THESE EFFORTS ADJACENT TO A NEW
METRO LIGHT RAIL STATION
FACILITATING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
AND ADJACENT TO EXISTING HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT AREAS WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR SHOPPING
CENTERS WHICH COMBINED PROVIDE
IN EXCESS OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY
ACRES. TO INCORPORATE NEW
HOUSING WE'VE ALSO RECORDED
STEADY INCREASE OF ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT DEVELOPMENT CITY
WIDE WITH A FORECASTED AVERAGE
OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY USED
PRODUCED ANNUALLY. OUR CITY
COUNCIL EMPHASIZED THEIR
COMMITMENT TO INCREASING ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE OF THEIR FIRST
ACTIONS WAS TO INITIATE AN
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE
STUDY. WITH THE GOAL OF
CODIFYING THE ORDINANCE WITHIN
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS. CALATHES
AN ALLEY DIVISION APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
ATKINS DESIRE TO PURSUE A
HOUSING PRODUCTION PROPOSAL.
UNFORTUNATELY SB NINE WILL NOT
SPUR MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION IN A MANNER THAT
SUPPORTS LOCAL FLEXIBILITY.
DECISION MAKING AND COMMUNITY
INPUT. STATE DRIVEN MINISTERIAL
OR BY RIGHT THE APPROVAL
PROCESS IS FAILED TO RECOGNIZE
THE EXTENSIVE PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
ASSOCIATED WITH DEVELOPING AND
ADOPTING W. ORDINANCES AND
HOUSING ELEMENT SENATE
CERTIFIED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. SB NINE
WOULD IGNORE THIS LONG STANDING
STATE MANDATED HOUSING PLANNING
PROCESS AND INSTEAD FORCES
CITIES TO APPROVE NEW HOUSING
THAT MAY CONFLICT. WITH
CERTIFIED HOUSING PLANS. THIRTY
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE ON SB NINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S NOT GO TO THE NEXT
MAIN OPPOSITION WHEN THIS. HI
THERE MY NAME IS MADELEINE
BARBER. GET AFTERNOON MISTER
SHARON STATUS CAME ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. I
AM AN OPERATIONS SPECIALIST FOR
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT. I AM
ALSO AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
OFFICIAL SERVING AS A MEMBER OF
THE OPPORTUNITY COUNTY COUNCIL
IN LAND USE COMMITTEE. TODAY
I'M THINKING OF THE BLACK HOME
ON MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER. TWO
FIFTY JIM CROW DURING THE GREAT
MIGRATION MANY BLACK FAMILIES
CAME TO CALIFORNIA FOR BETTER
JOBS AND BETTER LIVES. SB NINE
IS A WOLF IN SHEEP'S CLOTHING
MUCH LIKE FDR'S NEW DEAL
PRECLUDED REDLINING IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS SH MANY BLACK
FAMILIES THAT MAC MIGRATED FROM
THE SOUTH OUR STORIES ARE THE
SAME. WE UNDERSTOOD THAT ONE OF
OUR ONLY OPTIONS TO BUILD
GENERATIONAL WEALTH FOR
FAMILIES WITH TO HOMEOWNERSHIP.
OUR HOMES ARE SANCTUARY IN OFF
THE PLACES WE KNOW WE CAN BE
RETURN FEELS WHEN AND IF OUR
PATH TO ECONOMIC STABILITY
TAKES A DETOUR SH AND SOME
INSTANCES KEEPING PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN OTHERWISE THINGS WOULD BE
ON HOW. SCHLEPPING OPENS THE
DOOR WHY DEVELOPERS MANY AT
HOME A REGULAR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTORS TO LOCAL AND STATE
POLITICIANS. THEY TAKE NO
CONSIDERATION OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LIVING IN THESE COMMUNITIES
OR GENERATIONAL DISPLACEMENT OR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF
GOOD PAL THING. THE HOUSING
THEY SEEK TO BUILD IS NOT
AFFORDABLE IT IS LUXURY. THE
HOUSING THEY SEEK TO BUILD IS
NOT AFFORDABLE IT IS LUXURY.
THE AGENDA IS TO PRICE OUT THE
MIDDLE WORKING CLASS RESIDENTS
DIGIT THREE GENTRIFICATION AND
IT'S QUITE CREATE LIFELONG
RENTERS WILL HAVE LITTLE TO NO
ECONOMIC STABILITY. SH MY OWN
HOUSEHOLD INCLUDES THREE
GENERATION HONESTLY IT WOULD BE
FOR IF WE HAD ONE FROM ANOTHER
SH BECAUSE I REFUSE TO ALLOW MY
SON TO START HIS OWN FAMILY BY
PAYING AT THE VERY LEAST THREE
TIMES THE AMOUNT OF THE
MORTGAGE RATE. WE NEED MORE
BLACK HOMEOWNERS NOT MORE
RANCHERS. WE NEED MORE FIRST
TIME BUYER PROGRAMS FOR MIDDLE
AND WORKING CLASS FAMILIES TO
HELP WITH THAT INCLUDES THE
DOWN PAYMENT. WE ALSO NEED
INCREASED FAIR HOUSING INTERNET
LEGISLATION TO FEND OFF
PREDATORY AND FRAUDULENT
BEHAVIOR. I WISH I HAD TIME TO
TELL YOU MY STORY THE WHAT OUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN THROUGH TO KEEP
OUR HOME OF OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. BECAUSE BUYING OUR HOME
TURNED OUT TO BE NOT THE
HARDEST PART SH AND ONE CASE
RESULTED IN A COURT CASE.
BARBERS LEVINE UNDERSTATEMENT
MEREKA SHE IN ANOTHER CASE.
ADAM SCHIFF OFTEN INTERVENE ON
OUR BEHALF WITH THE CORRUPT
LENDER. LASTLY UNINTENDED BY
POLITICIANS LUDICROUS TRICKLE
DOWN LIFE. PLEASE STOP
INSULTING OUR INTELLIGENCE WITH
MATH UNICORNS SHELL GAMES
INCLUSION. WE ALL KNOW WHEN
HELPING GET OLDER DEVELOP
RESPECT WE TEAR IT DOWN AND
BUILD DANCE HOUSING FOR THE
MOST PART LAND DOESN'T LOSE
VALUE IN CALIFORNIA'S. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY STORY. AND THINK WENT
FOR IN ADVANCE FOR VOTING NO ON
SB NINE. THANKS VERY MUCH NOW
LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WISH TO STATE YOUR OPPOSITION-
AGAIN AS WE'VE BEEN DOING ALL
AFTERNOON. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME YOU ARE
AFFILIATION AND THE FACT THAT
YOU POST SO FOR EXAMPLE DAVID
CHIU SAN FRANCISCO OPPOSE.
WE'LL START WITH A COUPLE FOLKS
HERE IN THE CHAMBER- FOR
SPEAKER PLACE. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IS HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE. THANK
YOU PERFECT MODEL NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBER SHARON CAN SOLVE IS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
EASTVALE CORONA BELMONT AND
FOSTER CITY IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
WHO IS AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS. C.
NINE TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES AGAIN
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT
THAT YOU OPPOSE. THANK YOU WE
CURRENTLY HAVE EIGHTY FIVE IN
Q. BUT IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
PLACED YOURSELF IN Q. TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO THE EURO AT THIS
TIME. NINE TO NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHARACTER
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
MARCOS GLENDALE BURBANK AND
PASADENA AND THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE AND NUMBER AND COUNCIL
COUNTY OF MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. NINE FOUR OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN MEANING IN
SUCH CITY CALIFORNIANS IMITATOR.
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE THREE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A MAJOR SETBACK ON BEHALF OF
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED REVERE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR
LOCAL CONTROL AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS BECAUSE VIRTUALLY NO
HOMEOWNER COULD GET FUNDING TO
BUILD LIKE THIS IS JUST FOR
DEVELOPERS. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS UNDERESTIMATED ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND TALAADO
LAFAYETTE CUPERTINO HALF MOON
BAY IN THE TRI VALLEY CITIES OF
DUBLIN LIVERMORE PLEASANTON SAN
RAMON AND DANVILLE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE FOR SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COLD WATER
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ONTARIO IN OPPOSITION. FIVE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL YES THIS IS A GREAT LOVER
WITH CATALYST I OPPOSE SB. NINE
THANK YOU NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU THE
HONORABLE CARE AND MEMBERS LIKE
TO MAKE. I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION. SB NINE. ONE
VOUCHER THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION. INE FOR TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN FLANAGAN
PRESIDENT OF THE BROKE WOULD
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN LOS
ANGELES. WE REPRESENT SEVEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL UNITS. AND
WE'RE ALSO MEMBER OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND WE ARE. POSTED SB. NINE
NINE TO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MELANIE WISE-
AND MONARCH- HOMEOWNER AND AYE
OPPOSED. THE NIGHT. FIVE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DEBATABLE CHAP I AM A LOCAL
COORDINATOR REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE HOMEOWNERS
IN THE CITY OF LA VERNE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FORTY ONE WE ALL
FIRMLY OPPOSE SB NINE AND ARE
ASKING THAT YOU PLEASE HELP A
SINGLE SAVE A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME NEIGHBORHOODS WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT CHAIR
CHIU AND ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
VOTE NO ON SB NINE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. TWO EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- MY NAME IS
JENNIFER TANNER AND ON BEHALF
OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA GREEN
JEANS THE MANY INDIVISIBLE AND-
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA STILL CALLOUSLY
FIFTY AND PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS
OF AMERICA DEADLINE ALERT THE
COMPETITION JOINED IN OPPOSING
SB NINE AND WE EXPLAIN WHY IN
OUR LETTERS THANK YOU. THREE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI THANK YOU SORRY I
WOULD NEED IT- THE PATERNITY
AND THAT'S ANOTHER FROM BRANDS
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I WOULD
PRESENT A UNANSWERED A BACK UP
PLAN WHAT WITH OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. RESIDENTS AND MEMBERS
AND WE'RE SAYING NO TO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL AND PLEASE BOTH. NOW
AND OPPOSE SB NINE. YEAH SIX
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS JIMMY WITH GRAY I
LIVE IN EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR I AM
A MEMBER OF L. A. COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND I LIVE IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. NINE
THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MARIA CALVIN SHERMAN
OAKS HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
CHAIR OF UNITED NEIGHBORS BOB
SPLITTING IS ON AFFORDABLE
OPTION FOR MOST HOMEOWNERS WE
OPPOSE. THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JENNY HUBBARD REPRESENTING THE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBER
VALLEY VILLAGE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF THE
UNITED NEIGHBORS STATING OUR
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE. THANK
YOU. FIVE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. I AM BEVERLY GARLAND
FROM MANCHESTER I AN MANY
OTHER MUCH AFTER RESIDENTS ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
DISASTROUS SB. NINE FOUR
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
HOLDEN OF THE MANGAN PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION AND
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT NINE MEMBER OF LITTLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE
FORTY SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
KATIE TWENTY I'M A CONCERNED
RESIDENT INVESTOR IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB NINE THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS CHERYL AND
CAPLETON CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE LARGEST IN
THE NATION STRONGLY OPPOSED
BECAUSE OF NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SIX FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LORRAINE
KIRSTEN I'M A THIRTY FOUR YEAR
RESIDENTS QUESTION HIGH IN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB. NINE ONE TO NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS
THERESA ALTERADO AND PAUL
BABCOCK WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
EAST SIDE VOICE IN LONG BEACH
AND HOMEOWNERS WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB NINE. LINE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS MICHAEL STEINER OF THE
WESTERN HIGHLANDS NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SAN FRANCISCO ON
THE WEST OF TWIN SPEAK
COMMUNITY COUNCIL AN UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATION OF EIGHTEEN
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS AND
SAN FRANCISCO STRONGLY OPPOSED
SENATE BILL NINE. ONE FIVE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU CLAUDIA ERICKSON. IN
FRENCH WOULD CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. IT SHOULD BE FINE BURKE
REPRESENTING THE MONITOR
STATION IN SANTA BARBARA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE HI
FIRED SOUND ARE NOT INCLUDED
AND NO SEQUEL REVIEW. ONE FOUR
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SH HEY THERE THIS IS SANDRA
WALLACE FROM THE MIGHTY
MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION OF SILICON VALLEY
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE SB. NINE LINE
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AT FIVE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIVE TWO THREE
LIKE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU SIR.
HE SEAN CAME WITH PLASTER
COUNTY MALL HOMEOWNER RESIDENT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE
I DON'T NEED MY NEIGHBOR
BECOMING A SLUM LORD ON. THE
STATE SUBSIDIES THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HI MY NAME IS DOROTHY
RIGHTS REPRESENTING L. A.
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH
VOTED TO OPPOSE SB NINE AND THE
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO VOTED
TO. LET ME TO SIT ON THAT BODY
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE NOW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK YOU
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WHAT MY TWO SIX WHAT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
LINE TO SIX ONE WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
RATE THAT PRO NINE ZERO ZERO
TWO EIGHT ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
IT THE. NINE NINE FIVE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
RACHEL OXMAN SAN MATEO COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE. NINE
FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YOU'LL LANDA PERSONAL ARE
HOMEOWNERS LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. NINE THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. FINE FOR EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FORTY FOUR IF
YOUR MIND IS MUTED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. BUT IN OUR
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO MY TWO
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. NINE TWO EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT'S
NOT RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE
NUMBER THREE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT IT WAS ALREADY
MUTE UNMUTE IT- ELIZABETH HENRY
A MEMBER OF ST LAFAYETTE-
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA ALSO LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA UNITED NEIGHBORS
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE.
EVERYTHING THAT EVERYBODY SAID
IS TRUE LISTEN TO THOSE
SPEAKERS. TWENTY SIX ZERO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES HI THE MOVE
OFF THE STATE ONE FROM CULVER
CITY NEIGHBORS UNITED
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
NEIGHBORS IN CULVER CITY AND A
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE. NINE
FIVE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH MONTGOMERY AND I'M
WITH A FALCON FOUR LOVABLE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS CITY FOR
LOCAL CONTROL AND CATHOLIC AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE TRULY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IT
DESTROYS THE ABILITY TO OFFER
MEANINGFUL LOCAL CONTROL. NINE
THREE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHARLES
DATE I'M WITH THE HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION OF THE
GREATER SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE
THANK YOU. ONE THREE FIFTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ADULT AND
ELECT I LIVE IN A WILDFIRE
PRONE AREA SAN MATEO COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE FIVE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR ENJOY OF LOS ANGELES
HOMEOWNERS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
NINE THANK YOU. WHY TO FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS CLINTON STILL PAYING
NINE MEMBER OF THE SB IS ABOUT
RESPONSIBLE PLANNING IN LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA. STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE. TWO FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHANE
KENNEDY LIVABLE RIVERSIDE AND
MORENO VALLEY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES TERRY TRUST YOUR LONG
TIME SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA EMB
AND ADVOCATE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I NOTE THAT SB NINE
DOES NOT PROVIDE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND EVERYTHING VERY
MUCH SIR YOU KNOW HONESTLY NINE
AS I SAID BEFORE WE- WILL ASK
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO ONLY
STATE THEIR NAME. THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT THEY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. SIX OH FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS COREY PRINTER I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN BURLINGAME
CALIFORNIA AND I AM STRONGLY
AGAINST S. B. NINE AND I KNOW
THAT ARE OUT CITY COUNCIL. MY
TO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LARA BREWERS- REPRESENTING
LIQUID VILLAGE NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION LONG BEACH ERROR
REPUBLICANS AND MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES WHO REALLY WANT A
DECENT SIZE BACKYARD AND WILL
BE FORCED TO MOVE OUT OF STATE.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE TWO SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVENTY FIVE
IS YOUR LINE IF NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. JANET WEST
A MEMBER OF THE EAST SIDE
POLICE- I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB.
NINE TWO FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE EMILY GABEL LUDDY PATH
NEAR BURBANK LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CREEK
THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS. THE
URBAN WHAT STATE DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY CONSTRUCTION OF ADA
COMPLIANT SIDEWALK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
WE HAVE NOW PASSED THE FIFTEEN
MINUTE TIME LIMIT OF FOR ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT DID NOT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY YOU ARE MORE THAN WELCOME
TO. SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
OUR- MANY AND THAT WILL BECOME
PART OF THE PUBLIC RECORD BUT
AT THIS TIME I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION. MR KILEY. THANK YOU
AND- LET ME SAY THE OUTSIDE-
NINE I KNOW YOU'RE ON THE OTHER
I GUESS YOU'RE WHAT JOIN AUTHOR
CO AUTHOR IS- AND- TO YOU KNOW
TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL- ARE TRYING
TO- CREATE. SERIOUS POLICY- TO
ADDRESS HOUSING BECAUSE I WANT
TO- A KNOWLEDGE THAT BEFORE
SOME OF MY MORE NEGATIVE
COMMENTS- WHICH- THE OUT TO
START WITH I'M- I'M I'M PRETTY
ANNOYED AND FRUSTRATED WITH A
LOT OF THINGS RELATED TO THIS
BILL STARTING WITH THE FACT
THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING IT ALL
THIS YEAR. YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
THIS PAST WEEK PASSED IT PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY PASSED THE SENATE.
BUT HE DIDN'T GET TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T GET IT BACK TO THE
SENATE FOR A FINAL CONCURRENCE
VOTE BEFORE THE MIDNIGHT
DEADLINE IF WE HAVE FIVE MORE
MINUTES WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
AND I THINK THIS IS.
UNACCEPTABLE AND EMBARRASSING
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
PARTICULARLY SO WHEN WE TOOK
SEVERAL MONTHS LAST YEAR OFF
WHERE WE JUST DIDN'T SHOW UP
HERE AT ALL AND YOU CAN'T BLAME
ALL ABOUT UNCOATED BECAUSE WE
WERE WE TOOK SEVEN WEEKS OFF
AND WE ARE HERE- AND THEN WE
LEFT AGAIN FOR FIVE WEEKS FOR A
SUMMER RECESS AND SO. IT'S
PRETTY FRUSTRATING TO ME THAT
WE ARE HERE RE LITIGATING. A
VERY CONTENTIOUS ISSUE.
GENERALLY BECAUSE OF THAT
DERELICTION AND DYSFUNCTION OF
THIS LEGISLATURE. YOU CALLS
FROM. LEGISLATORS IN THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE OUTREACH- BUT
I'LL SAY ON A WHEN IT COMES
THAT LATE IN THE GAME ON A
MAJOR PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
DOESN'T REALLY SUGGEST TO ME A
GENUINE DESIRE. TO COLLABORATE
ON POLICY AS A POINT OF
CONTRAST THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO REACHED OUT TO ME
WELL OVER A WEEK BEFORE THIS
HEARING WE'VE HAD LENGTHY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HIS BILL AND
I WAS ABLE TO GIVE HIM A GOOD
SENSE. OF WHERE I STAND ON EACH
OF HIS THREE BILLS ACTUALLY-
PRIOR TO THIS HEARING. TURNING
TO THE YOU KNOW THE MERITS OF
THE LEGISLATION. I HAVE SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE IN. OVER THE
LAST FOUR AND A HALF YEARS I
SUPPORTED. EVERY BILL THAT I
COULD THAT THAT I'VE SEEN- THAT.
I BELIEVE IT WOULD CREATE AN
ADVANTAGE EXPAND OUR HOUSING
SUPPLY IN A MEANINGFUL WAY AND-
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THAT'S EVEN
BEEN INTENTION WAS SOME OF THE
OTHER VALUES THAT GUIDE BY
POLICY MAKING BUT I THINK THAT
THE ISSUE IS THAT IMPORTANT
IT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE QUALITY OF
LIFE HERE WHEN IT COMES. TO OUR
STATE'S FUTURE AND YET WE HAVE
SEEN NO IMPROVEMENT THE PROBLEM
HAS GOTTEN WORSE THE LAST TWO
YEARS THE NUMBER OF PERMITS HAS
DECLINED BURKE WE'RE BUILDING A
VERY VERY SMALL FRACTION OF
WHAT WE ULTIMATELY NEED. AND IF
THERE WERE REAL POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP IN THIS STATE AND WE
WOULD ADDRESS THAT ISSUE IN A
WAY THAT IS URGENT IN A WAY
THAT IS COMPREHENSIVE WE HAVE A
SPECIAL SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEAL WITH STEEP
WHAT TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT
COST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS- TO BUILD IN GOVERNMENT
CREATED COST BEFORE. YOU EVEN
BREAK GROUND AND MANY OTHER
COMMONSENSE SOLUTIONS THAT
REASONABLE PEOPLE CONCERNS JUST
WITH IMPLEMENTING GOOD POLICY
WOULD BE ABLE TO AGREE ON. BUT
WE'RE NOT DOING ANY OF THAT
INSTEAD OF THE ONE LEVER THAT
WE'VE BEEN WILLING TO TRY TO
PULL IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES
WHICH IS TO ADDRESS- THE ZONING
RELAX SOME OF THE RESTRICTIVE
NIS- OF ZONING AND YOU KNOW YOU
YOU GOT ASKED WHY IS THAT WHY
IS THIS THE ONE THING. THAT
WERE REALLY WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT MY READ ON THE
SITUATION IS YOU HAVE IN FAVOR
OF A BILL LIKE THIS SOME VERY
POWERFUL INTERESTS THAT HAVE. A
LOT OF PULL ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE FRANKLY- AND ON THE
OTHER SIDE AND THAT'S ENOUGH
THERE'S ENOUGH OLITICAL MUSCLE
TO OVERCOME THIS STRONG
OPPOSITION AND QUITE LEGITIMATE
OPPOSITION IN SOME CASES- OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT- AND SO
BECAUSE IT'S SACRAMENTO.
INTEREST ON ONE SIDE AND JUST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON THE OTHER
THAT'S ABOUT A WERE WILLING TO
FIGHT TO SOME EXTENT BUT IN
ORDER SHOULD PRESS ANY OF THE
PARTS OF THE HOUSING PROBLEM.
SUDDENLY THEN YOU HAVE
SACRAMENTO SPECIAL INTERESTS ON
BOTH SIDES AND YOU'RE EVEN MORE
POWERFUL SPECIAL INTEREST. ON
THE OPPOSITION SIDE AND SO
WE'RE NOT WILLING TO FIGHT
THOSE BATTLES. AND SO I'VE
SUPPORTED MEASURES LIKE THIS
BUT I'VE ALSO STARTED TO ASK
MYSELF. AM I YOU KNOW- ENABLING
A STRATEGY OF AVOIDANCE WHERE
WE LOOK LIKE WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS HOUSING
HOUSING BUT ACTUALLY AVOIDING
THE MUCH BIGGER ISSUES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR US HAVING. BY
FAR THE WORST HOUSING
SITUATION- IN THE COUNTRY. SO
THAT'S WHY I FEEL VERY
CONFLICTED ABOUT MY VOTE TODAY-
BUT I AM GOING TO VOTE YES I'M
GONNA SEE I WANT TO SEE. HOW
THIS WORKS I THINK IT'LL HELP I
DON'T KNOW THE WHOLE GREAT
DEAL. BUT I'LL ALSO SAY I THAT
I'M GONNA BE VERY RELUCTANT TO
FULL THE PULL THIS PARTICULAR
LOVER AGAIN. INTEL WERE WILLING
TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND A MUCH
MORE. COMPREHENSIVE WAY THANK
YOU. PLEASE OKAY LET'S GO
OTHERS MIX WORKS ACTIONS ARE
MISSED WHICH HAD HER HAND UP
FOR SENT TO MISS WORK SO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL BACK AGAIN THIS YEAR
AND THANK SENATOR REQUIRE FOR
COMING PRESENTING TODAY. I HAVE
A QUESTION AND SOME COMMENTS-
YOU KNOW IT WAS RAISED BY A
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION THAT WAS
CALLING IN THE CONCERNED ABOUT
A FIRE SAFETY WITH REGARD TO.
THIS BILL I JUST WANTED TO SEE
IF YOU COULD CLARIFY. SENATOR
MCGUIRE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- FIRST S. B. I. S. B. NINE
SORRY GOES FURTHER THAN AND
THEN EXISTING EIGHTY LAW IN
TERMS OF FIRE SAFETY. SO
FURTHER I THINK MAKING IT
SAFER. TO IT- SB NINE COPIES
EXISTING LAWS FOR BY RIGHT
HOUSING VIS A VIS SB THIRTY
FIVE WHICH SAYS THAT VERY HIGH
FIRE SAFETY SEVERITY ZONES ARE
EXEMPT FROM THE BILL. EXCEPT
WHERE LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALREADY
ALLOWS FOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ZONE AND THE DEVELOPMENT MEETS
THE STATE STANDARDS FOR FIRE
MITIGATION WHICH INCLUDES I
THINK OF THREE THINGS ONE.
BUILDING STANDARDS TO REDUCE
COMBUSTIBLE THE AN EMBER
INTRUSION INTO HOMES SECONDLY
THE BORDER FOR STATE
REGULATIONS FOR ROAD STANDARDS
WATER SUPPLY FOR FIRE. FIGHTING
SIGNAGE AND FUEL BREAKS AND
THIRDLY DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REGULATIONS AND THEN THE THIRD
THING I BELIEVE AND I'M GLAD
YOU'RE PRESENTING THIS BILL IS.
MY UNDERSTANDING THE STANDARDS
WOULD BE STRENGTHENED UNDER S.
B. TWELVE CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THAT THIS ISSUE A LITTLE BIT.
YES MA'AM THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- GRATEFUL
FOR THE QUESTION. SO ONE OF THE
POSITIVE ASPECTS ABOUT THIS
BILLS LOCAL CONTROL. TO RIGHT
NOW IF A CITY OR COUNTY WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO BAN DEVELOPMENT
IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES IT COULD DO THAT. AND
WHAT. THE PROGRAM'S BEEN VERY
FOCUSINGON IS PRESERVING LOCAL
CONTROL LOCAL CONTROL IN
REGARDS TO WHERE LOCALS. CAN
BUILD HERE- BASED OFF OF
AFFORDABILITY SO FOR EXAMPLE-
AFFORDABLE COVENANTS COULD BE
PLACED UNDER THIS BILL AS WELL.
ALONG WITH THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS. SPECIFICALLY ON
THE HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES SO WE DO NOT SPECIFICALLY
IS EXEMPT THAT BECAUSE LOCALS
CAN DO THAT RIGHT NOW EVEN AS
WE SPEAK. WHAT WE WOULD. HOPE
IS THAT. NOT JUST FOCUSING ON
FOR. BUT LOOKING AT MANSIONS AS
WELL RIGHT IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES. IN SO BRING
INTO THE CONVERSATION ABOUT SB
TWELVE. RIGHT NOW- WHAT WE KNOW
WITH THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF
FIRES IN THE STATE. IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT BUILDING MATERIAL
ANYMORE. IT'S ABOUT WHERE WE
BUILD. IT'S A REALLY TOUGH
CONVERSATION. AND IT'S WE'VE
HEARD FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEADERS IN THE STATE CALLERS
CALLING IN TODAY HOUSING IS
REALLY DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE TO
TACKLE. IN ANYTHING DIFFICULT
IS WORTH MOVING ON. SO WHILE
WE'RE ADVANCING A COMPREHENSIVE
IN ITS LED BY THE PRO TEM.
ADVANCING A COMPREHENSIVE
HOUSING PACKAGE THE HOUSING
BOND FOCUSING ON FOUR OTHER
BILLS PLUS SB NINE WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT SENATE BILL TWELVE
SO THE MORE YOU BUILD IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY AREAS. THE
MORE REGULATIONS AND SAFEGUARDS
ARE PUT ONTO IT YOU CAN NO
LONGER HAVE JUST ONE WAY AND
ONE WAY OUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE IN
INGRESS AND EGRESS YOU HAVE TO
FOCUS ON. MANDATED DEFENSIBLE
SPACE IT'S- YOU CAN'T BUILD AT
THE VERY. PEAK OF THE SLOPE YOU
HAVE TO TAKE IN MORE FIRE SAFE
ZONE TO BE OF THE BUILDING.
THAT BILLS ALSO CONTROVERSIAL-
BUT- SO THIS IS THIS BILL IS
PART OF A LARGER SWEET OF
BILLS. SENATE BILL TWELVE IS A
COMPLIMENT TO THE HOUSING
PACKAGE. AND THE LAST PIECE
IT'LL SAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
DON'T MEAN TO GO ON THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY RIGHT NOW EVEN AS
WE TALKED IS CURRENTLY UPDATING
THEIR STANDARDS. UP IN THEIR
STANDARDS ABOUT WHERE FOLKS CAN
BUILD IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
ZONES- INTO THAT IS
SIMULTANEOUSLY HAPPENING IN
ADDITION TO THE LEGISLATURE
MOVING- ON SENATE BILL TWELVE.
FINALLY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL-
THE SIM THE RINGS UP A GOOD
POINT BECAUSE MANY OF OUR-
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN RAVAGED BY
FIRES. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT THE PREVIOUS ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND NOW THIS CURRENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL- THERE ARE.
THREE DIFFERENT AREAS OF
LITIGATION WHERE THE PER OF
JESS HERE IN THIS OR FOR. ON
ONE IN SANDY. AND ANOTHER IN
LAKE. BASED OFF OF THE I. R.
THAT- ARE NOT- ATTICA. WHEN IT
COMES TO SAY STAND. SO THE
JOURNALS OFFER IS NOW. THOSE TO
THE- TO FOR- ENHANCE STANDARD
FOR SAFETY IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
ZONES THERE'S ANOTHER
DEVELOPMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS. A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT CHALLENGE-
THAT. THAT OFFICE IS ALSO
FOCUSING IN ON SO THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE- AND THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS. WE HAVE TO
BUILD HOUSING. IT TOOK
EVERYTHING THAT I HAD. PLUS MY
WIFE TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE
COMMUNITY THAT I GREW UP IN MY
FAMILY'S BEEN IN FOR THREE
GENERATIONS ON THE FOURTH. AND
WE HAVE TO FOCUS EVEN THOUGH
HOUSING BILLS ARE HARD WE HAVE
TO FOCUS ON MOVING FORWARD AND
I'M SORRY. AT MENACINGLY BY ONE
ON FOR SO LONG BUT- HOPEFULLY
THAT ANSWERED THE QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO TWELVE AND ARCHITECT.
I APPRECIATE THAT A SENATOR
REQUIRE- YOU THE OTHER ISSUE I
JUST WANTED TO ALSO COMMENT ON
AS IT WAS RAISED BY OPPOSITION
A COUPLE TIMES AT THIS BILL HAS
NO. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS TO IT I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE CURRENT
STATUS QUO OF SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING HAS NO AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO IT. AND A
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING IS ROOTED
IN REDLINING AND IT IS CREATED
HUGE PROBLEMS AND- YOU KNOW IT
RESULTS IN. A EXCLUSIONARY
HOUSING AND AT LEAST THIS BILL
THESE UNITS CAN BE A DEED
RESTRICTED SHOULD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DECIDE WHICH I
THINK IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD I THINK THIS BILL WILL
CREATE MORE. HOUSING WHICH WE
OBVIOUSLY NEED IT NEEDS YOU
SAID- INCREASE DENSITY IN A WAY
THAT I THINK DOESN'T
FUNDAMENTALLY ALTER THE
CHARACTER OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
WHICH I KNOW WAS IMPORTANT FOR
SOME PEOPLE. IT GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE ABILITY AS YOU
SAID TO PREVENT BUILDING AND
HIGH FIRE SOUNDS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT FOR PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT BERKELEY OAKLAND AREA
WE HAD A FIRE THEIR NINETEEN
NINETY TWO- THIS BILL IS
OPTIONAL IT ALLOWS. HOMEOWNERS
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO BUILD
SMALLER UNIT SHOULD THEY CHOOSE
TO- AND I THINK IT SUCKS AND I
WAS A BIG SUPPORTER OF SB
ELEVEN TWENTY AT THE END OF
SESSION LAST YEAR I SPOKE ON
THE BILL IN THE WEE HOURS OF
THE DAY. I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I THINK WE
NEED TO LEGALIZE DUPLEXES WE
NEED TO CREATE MORE HOUSING WE
NEED TO BE A MORE INCLUSIVE
STATE. AND HAVE OUR HOUSING
POLICIES MATCH OUR PROGRESSIVE
VALUES BY ENSURING THAT WE
REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESS
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE I'M HAPPY.
TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR VERY MUCH.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION WITH THE
BILL'S SECOND. THIS MAN A
SECOND AND NOW LET'S GO TO MISS
CORK SILVA. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL I KNOW
ITS- A- DIFFICULT CONVERSATION
AND- I DO HAVE A QUESTION AND
IF YOU COULD I KNOW IT WAS JUST
ADDRESSED BY MY COLLEAGUES
HERE. BUT DOES THIS BILL- DO
ANYTHING REGARDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. DOES THAT ADDRESS IT
BECAUSE I WILL BE HONEST I'VE
IN MY DISTRICT RECEIVED
MAILERS- SENT OUT SAYING THIS
BILL DOES NOTHING TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SOME NUMBER AND I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
BROUGHT THAT UP. SO PUTTING A
HEADLINE ON THE MAILER IS ONE
ISSUE. BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE OUR
DECISION BASED OFF OF DATA SO
LET'S TALK ABOUT DATA TODAY. SO
ACCORDING TO THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. 65% OF ALL EIGHTY
USE THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT IN THE
COUNTY OF LA- PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE RANGE. FOR FAMILIES
THAT WOULD FALL INTO THE LOW
INCOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CATEGORY. SO YOU HAVE VERY LOW
LOW AND MODERATE- 65% OF ALL
EIGHTY USE WOULD FALL INTO THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CATEGORY 68%
OF ALL EIGHTY USE IN ORANGE
COUNTY AN INDIVIDUAL FAMILY
THAT FALLS INTO THAT LOW INCOME
CREDIT CATEGORY CAN AFFORD THE
AVERAGE RATE OF EIGHTY YOU. THE
REASON WHY I BRING THAT UP BUT
THESE DUPLEXES ARE VERY SIMILAR
SIZES TO EIGHTY USE. SO THE
SECOND PIECE IS WE ENCOURAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PUT DEED
RESTRICTIONS UNDER THESE
DUPLEXES. AGAIN WHAT WE REALLY
TRY TO FOCUS IN ON IS AN
ELEGANT APPROACH THE LOCAL
CONTROL. SO IF AND IF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
PUT DEED RESTRICTIONS.
COVENANTS ON TO EACH OF THESE
DUPLEXES THEY COULD. THEY DON'T
NEED THE STATE SIMPLY TO TELL
THEM. CANDIDLY I WE HEARD ONE
OF THE ELECTED OFFICIALS TRUMP
WITH THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
ABOUT TO BUILD A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHTY USE. THEIR
MINISTERIAL. JUST LIKE THIS
BILL. SO THAT WAS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL GOING TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE'RE LITERALLY
SEEING THOUSANDS OF EIGHTY USE
IN PERMIT. BEING BUILT OR BUILT
THAT NOW ARE AFFORDABLE BASED
OFF OF WHAT WE KNOW FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS. THERE IS NO
SPECIFIC AFFORDABILITY
COVENANTS IN THE BILL BUT THAT
DOES NOT STOP- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM DOING THAT
OTHERWISE THANK YOU SOME NUMBER
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. YES AND THEN I HAVE
SOME FOLLOW UP COMMENTS GUESTS
PLEASE AND AGAIN BECAUSE WE'RE
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND WE KIND
OF SPEAK HOUSING LANGUAGE A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
A DO YOU MEAN YES AN EIGHTY YOU
MEANS A AS AN ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT ALL ARE. AN OLDER
TERM WOULD BE A GRANNY FLAT OR
EVEN A MOTHER IN LAW CAN WE
KNOW THAT. IN THE PAST SO I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE PAST THE
PRESENT AND THE FUTURE OF
HOUSING IN THE PAST- THERE WERE
OFTEN EIGHTY USER GRANNY FLATS
BUILT EXACTLY FOR WHAT IT SAYS
EITHER AGING PARENTS- MOTHER
LOVE WHICH IS A LITTLE.
NEGATIVE BUT THOSE WERE BUILT
AND THEN THEY STOPPED. AND THEY
STOPPED BECAUSE THERE WERE MANY
REASONS- BARRIERS FOR SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCE WHETHER THEY'D
THEY WERE A FEES FROM THE
CITY'S. OF OTHER REASONS BUT
EIGHTY USE ARE NOW BECOMING.
ARE COMING BACKIF YOU WANT TO
SAY OLD SCHOOL NEW SCHOOL. AND
THERE IS NO MANDATE FOR A
SINGLE FAMILY A HOMEOWNER TO
CHOOSE TO DO THAT MATTER FACT
UP THERE ARE AND STILL SOME
BARRIERS AS FAR AS COST BUT
THIS BILL- IT TALKS ABOUT. WHAT
HAVE WE DONE IN THE PAST AND
NOW WHAT ARE WE DOING IN THE
FUTURE AND RIGHT NOW IN THE
PRESENT WE SEE WE HAVE A
PRODUCTION OF. CRISIS A
PRODUCTION CRISIS THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO SAY LET'S LOOK AT UP
WHERE ARE NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
CURRENTLY AND CAN WE LOOK
TOWARDS. THE FUTURE AS FAR AS
PROVIDING OTHER FORMS OF
HOUSING WITHIN THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD. I COME FROM
ORANGE COUNTY TO SACRAMENTO I
WALKED THROUGH SACRAMENTO AND I
AM AMAZED AT SOME OF THE
BEAUTIFUL NEIGHBORHOODS. HERE
THAT THAT IN MANY TIMES WE'LL
SEE A SINGLE FAMILY BUT THEN
EIGHT DUPLEX MAYBE FOUR UNITS
MAYBE EIGHT UNITS AND THEN
SOMETIMES EVEN A- OF MORE A
TALLER BUILDING THAT MIGHT HAVE
THAT UP EVEN MORE RESIDENTS.
THEY SEEM TO CO EIST UP VERY
NICELY AND THESE HAVE BEEN
BUILT NOT JUST IN THE LAST
DECADE BUT MANY DECADES AGO SO
I THINK THAT IF PEOPLE REALLY
DRIVE THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS AND-
LOOK TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
THE PAST. AND HOW WE CAN TAKE
SOME CUES FROM THAT BUT THIS IS
NOT THE BILL. THAT IS AS- AS
PEOPLE ARE MAKING IT OUT BUT I
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TWO OR
THREE THINGS. BECAUSE I HAVE
RECEIVED CALLS AND OPPOSITION
FROM SOME PEOPLE MY- AND MY
AREA AND I KNOW THEY'RE VERY
PROTECTIVE OF- THE COMMUNITIES.
NOT IN THE SENSE OF OVER
BUILDING BUT IN THE CHARACTER
FOR THE BEAUTY OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND I'M VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT SO IT SAYS
THE STATE OR LOCAL HISTORICAL
DISTRICT. OR PROPERTY AS
DEFINED MEANING THIS BILL WOULD
NOT APPLY TO THAT- THIS HOW THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WILL NOT
REQUIRE DEMOLITION OR
ALTERATION OF ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING TYPES OF HOUSE.
HOUSING AND THEN IT LISTS BUT
THIS BILL IS ELEVEN PAGES LONG
THAT WE HAVE HERE SO I REALLY
PLEAD WITH THE PEOPLE WHO'VE
CALLED TO READ IT CAREFULLY
BECAUSE THE MAILERS THAT YOU
RECEIVE. JUST TALK ABOUT
GENTRIFICATION- AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY OF A VERY
LIMITING AS FAR AS THE PEOPLE
WHO PUT THOSE MAILERS OUT
BECAUSE THIS SIMPLY SAYS. UP
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE STOCK
OF HOUSING WE HAVE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD LET'S GIVE SOME
ZONING OPTIONS NONE OF THEM ARE
MANDATES- AND LET'S MOVE
FORWARD WITH BUILDING IN
CALIFORNIA SO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR.
BEING THE- INTERMEDIARY OR AS
FAR AS PRESENT IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR L. COURTS IN
NUMBER. THANK YOU TO OUR VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR OUR CONVERSATIONS
THE PREVIOUS REGARDING THIS
BILL AND SOME OF THE OTHERS. SO
MY CONCERNS ARE THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS THAT I HAD THAT OTHERS
EXPRESS I'M NOT GONNA REITERATE
DOES IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
BUT YOU KNOW COMING FROM AN
AREA- IN IN MY DISTRICT. IS AN
AREA WHERE PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
TO- JUST LIKE UP HERE IN THE
BAY AREA IF YOU ARE FOR THE BAY
AREA FOLKS ARE FLEEING TO THE
OUTSKIRTS OF SACRAMENTO. AND
YOU GO OUT AND YOU LOOK AT. DID
THE ROSE BILLS LINCOLN'S EL
DORADO HILLS FOLSOM'S. AND
WHAT'S GOING ON OUT THERE
THEY'RE BUILDING A LOT OF
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES THEY'RE
ALSO BUILDING A LOT OF MULTI
FAMILY HOMES. THESE ARE ALL
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE BUILT ON
MASTER PLANS. THEIR MASTER
PLANNED COMMUNITIES THAT WENT
THROUGH A PROCESS THAT WENT
THROUGH THE STATE'S PROCESS. TO
EVEN BE ABLE TO BUILD WHAT THEY
HAVE TO GET THEIR GENERAL PLANS
APPROVED. AND WHAT THIS
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS TO HAPPEN IS
A DOUBLING OF THE POPULATION
VIA EVERY RESIDENTIAL BEING
ELIGIBLE TAB TWO INSTEAD OF
ONE. AND WITHOUT A SEQUEL IT
WITHOUT THE STATE'S OWN SEQUEL
PROCESS. IT WOULD PUT IT OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SEQUEL
PROCESS DEVELOPED BY THE STATE.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS PEOPLE
MOVE OUT THERE IS BECAUSE IT IS
MORE PLAN. IS BECAUSE THE AREAS
THEY MOVED FROM AND I CAN I'VE
WORKED IN THOSE AREAS YOU CAN'T
EVEN DRIVE DOWN THE STREET
WHERE YOU HAVE THESE ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS AND THEN ANOTHER
ONE OR THEY DECIDE TO BUILD TWO
HOUSES ON ONE LOT. AND THERE'S
NO INCREASE I MEAN THERE'S NO
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR INCREASED
VEHICLES AND END UP VEICLE
MILES TRAVELED OR WHATEVER DID
FORMULA IS THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO USE. AND THE OTHER PART IS
ESPECIALLY ON AREAS LIKE OURS.
THERE ARE NO JOBS FOR PEOPLE
OUT THERE. SO IF THEY COME OUT
THERE ARE TENTATIVE TO BE ABLE
TO AFFORD IT. AND THAT'S YET
ANOTHER ISSUE THIS IS NOT BY
ANY STRETCH OF IMAGINATION-
GUARANTEE AFFORDABILITY. BUT IF
THEY'RE ABLE TO AFFORD.
SOMETHING OUT THERE MORE THAN
THEY ARE- IT TOWARDS. THEY
MOVED THERE AND THEY JOIN THE
CAN CROWD. AND INSTEAD OF FOR
OUR COMMUTE TURNS IN FIVE SIX
HOUR COMMUTE VERY EVERY. DAY
AND THAT'S THAT'S NOT WITHIN.
OF OUR C. THE ALLOW THEIR
STEVEN THIS PLAN OR THE PLAN.
APPROVED IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO
WHEN I LOOK AT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN DOING THIS.
WHERE THEY'VE TAKEN A LOT AND
SAYING HEY YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
USED TO BE A SINGLE FAMILY LOT
BUT- WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW TWO
OR THREE UNITS TO BE BUILT ON
THAT- INSTEAD OF. TWO OR THREE
UNITS I MEAN IT'S NOT A ONE
UNIT THE COST. THREE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS. THEY HAVE
THREE UNITS THAT COST TWO AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS EACH. GO
TO PALO ALTO I CAN GIVE YOU AN
ADDRESS AND YOU CAN GO LOOK AT
IT. IT DID NOT CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT JUST
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOMEBODY TO MAKE THREE TIMES AS
MUCH ON THE MARKET VALUE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO. I DON'T SEE HOW THEY
CAN SAY THIS IS GOING TO
SOMEHOW MAKE A BIG SPLASH. IN
THE AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE INFILL HOUSING IN
AREAS THAT WE HAD ABSOLUTELY
ZERO PLANS TO DO SO. AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU HEAR A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION FROM PEOPLE AS THEY
DON'T WANT THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
RUINS LIKE THAT. THEY MOVED OUT
THERE IN THE PLANNED AREAS SO
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN
IN THE FUTURE. AND THEY DON'T
WANT THAT RUINED. I DON'T BLAME
THEM. THEY SHOULDN'T. SORRY DID
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE ISSUES. THAT COME WITH
RETROACTIVELY COMING IN. AND
THEN ADDING POPULATION IN THE
AREAS. THAT WE WERE TOLD WE
COULDN'T. IF WE IF WE BROUGHT
THAT IS A PLAN TO THE- HOUSING-
FOLKS. THEY WOULD THEY WOULDN'T
TURN IT DOWN. THEY WOULD HAVE
TOLD US NEVER VOTE REDO THIS.
SO WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO THAT THE ISSUE WITH
HOUSING IS NOT. THAT. WE'RE NOT
BUILDING ENOUGH INFILL HOUSING
ISSUE WITH HOUSING IS THAT WE
HAVE CREATED SUCH A REGULATORY
MONSTROSITY. TO BUILD A HOUSE A
SIMPLE HOUSE. THAT IS NOT
AFFORDABLE WE'VE AFFECTED HOW
MUCH MATERIALS COST IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE AFFECTED HOW
MUCH LABOR COSTS IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE AFFECTED EVERY ASPECT OF
BUILDING A HOME. AND THEN WE
HAVE THIS ENORMOUS COST AT THE
END. AND THEN WE SAY WELL IT'S
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FAULT BECAUSE
WE GIVE THEM A BAG OF
REGULATORY ITEMS THAT THEY HAVE
TO MAKE EVERY DEVELOPER GO
THROUGH. TO BE ABLE TO EVEN SAY
HERE CITY COUNCIL DO APPROVE
THIS CITY COUNCILLORS ARE NOT
NOT APPROVING PROJECTS. CITY
COUNCILS ARE APPROVING PROJECT
IT'S JUST A FIVE TO TEN YEAR
PROCESS IT TAKES EVERY
DEVELOPMENT TO GET THROUGH THAT.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO CHECK OFF
EVERY SINGLE BOX OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE HAS CREATED.
FOR THEM TO COME TO BUILD A
HOUSE. SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET OUT OF THIS. BY GOING INTO
EXISTING NEIGHBORHOODS
RETROACTIVELY ALLOWING THIS
DOUBLING OF THE POPULATION. AND
THEN SAYING HEY YOU KNOW NO BIG
DEAL ABOUT OUR ENVIRONMENT
BAYERN MENTAL QUALITY. THAT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN AND THEN ALL
WILL HAVE IS OVER DENSIFY
NEIGHBOURHOODS. WITH PEOPLE
THAT NEED TO COSTS CONTINUE TO
COMMUTE IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE
DRAWING IN A BUNCH OF JOBS INTO
THE INLAND EMPIRE AREAS. THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE COMING AND NOBODY
WANTS TO COME HERE. SO I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW WE THINK
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS
BY DOING INFILL DEVELOPMENT
THAT INCREASES DENSITY
NEIGHBORHOODS INCREASES ALL OF
THE IMPACT. AND TAKES IT BEYOND
WHAT EVEN ARE APPROVAL WAS
GIVEN TO US FOR. SO EVEN THAT'S
THAT'S JUST A TIP OF THE
ICEBERG SURE ASSEMBLY ISSUES
THAT I HAVE WITH THIS APPROACH.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK IF I
WERE GOING TO WORK I'D BE ALL
OVER. BUT IT WON'T I'VE SEEN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT THIS
HAPPENS IN. AND IT JUST DOESN'T
WORK. AND I KNOW WHY PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID OF. TO THE JOINT IT WITH
A VERY MATURE YEAH- IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR TAKING
YOUR TIME IN YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION- PRIOR TO HEARING
IN JUST WANNA SAY. I MEAN THIS
IS A SAID TO YOU FEEL REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND JUST WANT
TO SAY HELP WE SHOULD OF I AM-
NUMBER ONE WE LOOK AT WHERE OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IS ACCORDING
HOUSING CAN BE DEVELOPMENT IT
IS GOING TO BE THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABLE RENTALS WE NEED TO
DO ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
AFFORDABLE RENTALS ACROSS THE
STATE BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. I'M IN
ITS REALLY FOCUS ON WORKFORCE
HOUSING. AND AT. ONE I HEAR YOU
IN REGARDS TO SEQUEL- IN ONE OF
THE BARRIERS I CERTAINLY GET
THE ONLY BARRIER IT'S ALSO HIGH
PERMIT FEES IN CONNECTION FEES
AS WELL RIGHT BUT RIGHT NOW IF
YOU'RE TO BUILD A DUPLEX
WEATHER'S MARIANNA OR IF IT'S
IN HEALDSBURG WHERE I LIVE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO USE ON A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME IN TOWN YOU'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE TO GO THROUGH SEQUEL
YOU WON'T EVEN HAVE TO GO
THROUGH AND NAY DECK AND IF
YOU'RE TO BUILD A DUPLEX RIGHT
NOW I NEED YOU YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE TO DO THAT. SO I DO THINK
ON THE SECRET PEACE I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE AND NOT APPLYING
THAT TO THIS ISSUE- WHERE WE
REALLY ARE. NEEDING TO FOCUS.
IN THIS IS ALL STATE DATA. IS
AN ISSUE OF WORKFORCE HOUSING.
BECAUSE IF WE CAN BUILD WHERE
PEOPLE WORK ESPECIALLY ON THE
SERVICE RELATED JOBS. AND
WORKFORCE HOUSING WE ARE GOING
TO SEE A REDUCTION VEEAM TEAS.
IN THE LAST PIECE OF SAY IS
THIS. IN A MONEY ITEMS THAT-
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU THE VICE
CHAIR FOR SERVICES. TO THE FIRE
SERVICES WELL INTO THE CITY
COUNCIL- I LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT WAS BUILT IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. MY HOUSE IS
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SQUARE
FEET. MY PURCELL IS A QUARTER
ACRE. I'VE ONLY BURKE PURCHASED
OUR HOME- ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO.
WE'RE THE ONLY ONE PRETTY MUCH
ON THE BLOCK THAT DOESN'T HAVE
AN EIGHTY YOU. OR EIGHTY YOU
ENERGY DO YOU. IN THE VICE
CHAIRS RIGHT WE DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CARS AND WE ACTUALLY
HAVE KIDS ON THE BLOCK- BECAUSE
THEY CAN AFFORD TO BE ABLE TO
LIVE THERE ARE ANY HAS NOT
CHANGED THE FACE OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT WE- KIND OF
STUCK IN REGARDS TO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO WITH HOUSING ANY
BILL THAT WE BRING FORWARD IS
GONNA BE DIFFICULT WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING I THINK THAT
THIS TAKES A NEIGHBORHOOD
DRIVEN LEVEL I UNDERSTAND YOU
MAY NOT SEE EYE TO EYE ON THIS
AND AGAIN I AM SO GRATEFUL FOR
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY. AND LAST NIGHT BUT THE
LONGER WE WAIT THE MORE
DIFFICULT IS GOING TO BE IN
CANDIDLY OR THE MIGRATION IS
OUT OF THE STATE PART HIGHER
WITH INDIVIDUALS IT'S FOLKS
THAT CAN'T AFFORD RENT. SO THAT
THEY AND I THINK THAT THIS IS
REALLY A FOCUS BUT AGAIN MISTER
VICE CHAIR I'M SO APPRECIATIVE.
OF THAT THE DIALOGUE. DIRECTLY
PLEASE SIR SO. IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE WE HAVE THE
ECONOMIC CYCLE YES SIR
INDISPENSABLE URINARY. HARDER
THAN NORMAL. WHEN WE ARE DOWN
CYCLE. BEFORE THE FINALS FOR.
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS DOLLARS
REALLY WORKING FIFTY. AND THEN
THE DOWNSIDE OF A JOB DOWN
THERE HAVE A LINE FOR- ALLOW
THE EIGHTY SPECULATOR COMMENT
PURCHASE THE HOUSES THERE. YEAH
BILL TO SMALL HOUSES AND KIND
OF JUST UNDER THIS LAW WITHOUT
ANY. ANY MINISTER ARE. YEAH ON
HERE FIRST AND FOREMOST- ONLY
SEVENTEEN PER. OF IN IN THE
STATE ACTUALLY CORPORATE OWNED
SO THE VAST MAJORITY OF UNITS
IN THE STATE ARE OWNED BY HI
SINGLE FAMILY- OWNED BY
FAMILIES. OR HAVE A FAMILY HAS
A FEW RENTAL SO I THINK ON THE
CORPORATE SIDE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GIVING ISSUE WHEN IT
COMES THE I. EIGHTY USE ONLY 8%
EIGHTY USE ARE CORPORATE OWNED.
SO THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW LARGE
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS ARE
GONNA COME IN AND SWEEP THESE
UP THE NUMBERS. DON'T SHOW THAT
I AND I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO SHOW IN THE FUTURE NOW ON IT
IN A DOWNTURN- EVEN WITH WHAT
WE SAW IN THE PREVIOUS DOWNTURN
BACK IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
EXAMPLE WERE STOCKTON AND
MANTECA HIT SO HARD. THERE WAS-
SOME CORPORATE OWNERSHIP BUT
EVEN AFTER ALL OF THAT IT'S
STILL 17% OF TOTAL HOUSING
STOCK IN THE STATE ARE
CORPORATE OWNED SO I DON'T SEE
THAT HAPPENING. RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THAT- THE LAST
DOWNTURN WE HAD WE HAD SO MANY
FORECLOSURES ISN'T THOSE OF ALL
BEEN TURNED INTO A LOT OF
RENTAL UNITS YES SIR THERE ARE
NONE NONE OF THEM ARE
AFFORDABLE ANYMORE. SOME I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS IS GOING
TO AFFECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FASTER. THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
ROBUST DISCUSSIONS- I'M GOING
TO PROVIDE A COUPLE OF MY OWN
COMMENTS AND LET ME JUST START
BY THANKING. SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM FOR CHAMPION THIS BUILD
NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT LAST
YEAR REINTRODUCE NET. COURSE
WANNA THANK SIR MCGUIRE FOR
YOUR DOG ED ADVOCACY AND FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL ANSWERING
QUESTIONS TODAY. LET ME JUST
START WITH WITH THE OBVIOUS
COLLEAGUES WHICH IS THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE WE
ARE HERE. BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE MIDST OF TE WORST.
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AND STATE'S HISTORY YOU KNOW
THE STATISTICS OF HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF UNITS WERE LACKING
YOU KNOW. HOW SKYROCKETING OR
HOME PRICES ARE ARE RENTS ARE-
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE-
LARGEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE LIVING ON THE STREETS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY WHO DON'T HAVE
A PLACE TO CALL HOME. AND HOW
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD
SOLUTIONS IN THIS SPACE. I DO
WANT TO IT TO RESPOND TO OUR
VICE CHAIRS PERSPECTIVE OF
WHETHER THIS WILL WORK I WANT
TO PROVIDE. EXPERTS SAID I HAD
WHICH IS- THIRTEEN YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS FIRST ELECTED TO THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE WERE STARTING TO
SEE THE BEGINNING OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR CITY MY
CITY WAS GROUND ZERO FOR THE
HOUSING CRISIS. AND THE FIRST
BILL THAT I WROTE- WOULD HAVE
LEGALIZED IN LAW UNITS AND SAN
FRANCISCO EIGHTY YEARS. THIRTY
THOUSAND OF THEM IN OUR CITY
AND AT THE TIME IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. I WAS TOLD THAT I WAS
CRAZY. THAT IF WE WERE TO
CONSIDER DOING THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE CHARACTER OF OUR
CITY- THAT IT WENT. UP CREATE
UNITS OR NOT AFFORDABLE- AND-
AND LITERALLY DESTRUCTION
UNITIES. I DID MOVE IT THAT
YEAR. IT TOOK A COUPLE OF YEARS
BEFORE I AUTHORED ONE OF THE
VERY EARLIEST LOCALIZED. TO
ALLOW THE CREATION OF EIGHTY
USE. AND SINCE THAT TIME I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY WE'VE
ALL SEEN THE POSITIVE IMPACT.
OF EIGHTY LAW ON OUR STATES
WE'VE SEEN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
UNITS. TUCKED AWAY IN GARAGES
AND BACKYARDS WERE MOSTLY
AFFORDABLE TO FOLKS. OF AVERAGE
TO BELOW AVERAGE INCOMES. AND
IT'S MY PERSPECTIVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL BUILD ON THE SUCCESS
OF THAT. AND WILL HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO HAVE SIMILARLY
BENEFICIAL IMPACTS.
PARTICULARLY AND ESPECIALLY.
FOR LOWER INCOME PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO THROUGH. LOT SPLIT
PROVISIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
REALIZE THE VALUE OF THEIR
PROPERTY WITHOUT HAVING TO MOVE
AWAY- I WANT TO. ASO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE. YOU KNOW A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL BUT I
WOULD ASK FOLKS WHO OPPOSE THIS
BILL TO JUST CONSIDER WHETHER
EIGHTY LAW. WHICH HAS BEEN IN
PLACE NOW FOR GETTING CLOSE TO
FIVE YEARS- HAS LED TO THE
IMPACTS THAT THEY'RE DESCRIBING
ABOUT. THIS BILL- I THINK THAT
SB NINE IS ABOUT MAKING A
DIFFERENCE ONE UNIT AT A TIME-
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
ALSO NOTE. THE FACT THAT THERE
IS AN OWNER OCCUPIED
REQUIREMENT WHICH MEANS THAT
HOMEOWNERS WILL HAVE FULL
CONTROL OVER THEIR SPACE AND
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS OPTIONAL
MEANS AT THE STATE WE ARE NOT
FORCING ANYTHING IT'S UP TO
AGAIN. BLOCK BY BLOCK HOME
OWNER BY OWNER TO DECIDE WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO- I KNOW OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ROCKLAND IS NO
LONGER- HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM TODAY BUT I JUST WANT TO
SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT LAST
YEAR. I THINK WE'RE ALL
FRUSTRATED THIS DIDN'T GET DONE
LAST YEAR- BUT THAT'S NOT A
REASON FOR US TO NOT DO IT THIS
YEAR IN FACT IT'S- ALL THAT
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT WE HAVE TO
GET IT DONE THIS YEAR. AND I
THINK MANY OF US WOULD
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH WHAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR LAST YEAR WE
HAD THE WORST PANDEMIC IN A
HUNDRED YEARS. IT REQUIRED
TEMPORARY SHUTDOWNS PANDEMIC
RECESSION WILDFIRES SOCIAL
PROTEST MEMBERS WHO GOT CODED.
THAT'S WHAT CHALLENGES LAST
YEAR BUT- I THINK IT'S OUR JOB
TO DO THE PEOPLE'S WORK AT THIS
POINT- ONE FINAL THING I WANT
TO SAY IS- YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION AROUND. WHAT
INTERESTS ARE SORT OF DRIVING
THIS AND- I WOULD SAY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THERE ARE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AROUND THE STATE
OR INVOLVED IN HOUSING. EVERY
STAKEHOLDER HAS THEIR
PARTICULAR. IDEA OF WHAT WE
NEED TO DO. AND IT'S MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT I THINK THE
REASON WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
IS THAT FOR EVERY REAL PROPOSED
SOLUTION LIKE THIS ONE. THERE
ARE MANY OPPOSITION- LOT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
UPSETTING THE STATUS QUO. AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN FOR YEARS
AROUND HOUSING POLITICS IN THE
STATE IS THAT NOTHING HAPPENS.
OR PUT ANOTHER WAY. DIFFERENT
INTERESTS OR FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SAY NO. I THINK WE HAVE A
CHANCE TODAY TO SAY YES I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW VOTING. TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD WILL TAKE
COURAGE BUT I APPRECIATE THE
COURAGE THAT IT TAKES TO SAY
THE STATUS QUO IS BROKEN. TO
SAY THAT WE'VE GOT TO TAKE SOME
HARD STEPS TO ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS AND WITH THAT I'M NOT
ONLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. BUT
I'M HAPPY TO RECOMMEND THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD IN WITHOUT A CERTAIN
FINAL COMMENTS. LIKE TO ASK THE
GOOD CENTER TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS THIS IS HERE AGAIN-
SINCERELY MEANNESS I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP- YEAR IN YEAR. YEAR
AFTER YEAR ON ALL ISSUES O
HOUSING NOT JUST HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT WALKING THE WALK
IN YOUR HOMETOWN OF THECITY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO. NUMBER
TWO- JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
TO EACH OF THE COLLEAGUES. FOR
THIS ROBUST DIALOGUE TODAY- AND
I KNOW THAT AT THE SECONDS IS
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR YOU
TAKING THE TIME TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION TODAY
AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE IT WITH
HER HERE OVER THE PAST. SEVERAL
DAYS LAST PIECE OF SAY IS THIS-
WHERE THE- CHAIR WAS. JUST AT.
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT WORKING.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO BE
ABLE TO BRING POSITIVE CHANGE
TO LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES. I KNOW THAT
HOUSING IS DIFFICULT. BUT IT'S
NECESSARY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF
THE SECONDS. THANK YOU CENTER
WITHOUT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WITH THEIR
MOTION. THERE WAS A MOTION BY I
BELIEVE BY MS WEEK SECONDED BY
MISS CREEK SILVA- THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. BY
XU ICE THEY ARE TO NOW FAIR TO
KNOW GABRIEL. APRIL NOT VOTING
KALRA. KILEY MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SILVA QUICKSILVER I LICKS HI
WIXII WE WILL HOLD THE WORLD
OPEN AND CENTER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. AT THIS TIME
I THINK. THE DO NOT SEE SIR
WINNER SO WHEN WE GO TO FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
CENTER RUBIO
- GOOD AFTERNOON.
AB AGAIN THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO COME I
PRESENT MY SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO FOCUS ON
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
DESPITE MAKING UP NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF HOMELESS ADULTS
NATIONWIDE THERE ARE NO
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON THEIR
NEEDS AND EXPERIENCES THE FIRST
STEP TO SOLVING OUR HOMELESS
PROBLEM IS HAVING ACCURATE
DATA. WHO WHO IS ON HEALTH AND
WHAT ARE THEIR NEEDS AND WHAT
PROGRAMS WE CAN DO TO HELP THEM
AND THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
80% OF THIS GROUP REPORTED
TRAUMA OR ABUSE AS THE RESULT
OF THEIR HOMELESSNESS SO WHEN
PEOPLE USUALLY ASK VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHY DON'T YOU
LEAVE. THIS IS PART OF THE
ANSWER THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
BETWEEN CONTINUE TO GET
ASSAULTED OR POSSIBLY END UP
HOMELESS THAT'S NOT MUCH OF A
CHOICE THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND PASSED WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORTED
EVERY PREVIOUS COMMITTEE IT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE L. A. COUNTY
DELEGATION AS A PRIORITY BILL-
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE TO SET
SHAW FROM SKIP ROPE A SKID ROW
ACTIVIST TO TESTIFY AS WELL AS
ZAKRI WARMOTH WITH THE DOWNTIME
WOMAN CENTER. WHICH IS A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU. CAN I
SPEAK PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
EUROPEAN ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS TO THAT SONG I AM A
SECOND ROW RESIDENTS ADVOCATE
AND POTUS I WRITE AN ADVOCATE
YOU'D GROWN FROM A WOMAN'S
PERSPECTIVE TODAY I SHARE MY
TESTIMONY AS IT RELATES SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND TWO THOUSAND
THREE I WOULD PLAY FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OUT THERE
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THAT TIME
SPENT ON THE PENINSULA SILICON
VALLEY I ENDED UP BACK IN MY
HOMETOWN IN THE DESERT OF
ARIZONA WHERE I HAD LEFT THE
SUMMER I GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO TO GO AWAY
TO COLLEGE. AND TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE I WOULD TO PLAY FROM MY
HOMETOWN LONG STORY SHORT I
ENDED UP IN SKID ROW WHERE I
NOW RESIDE. ALTHOUGH I NOW OWN
ALTHOUGH I HAVE WORKED THREE
JOBS MOST OF MY LIFE- HAVE BEEN
A CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF
SOCIETY AND ENOUGH TO SKID ROW
LITERALLY CHANGED MY LIFE.
BEFORE BEING DISPLACED TO SKIP
BROWN. I WAS A STRUGGLING
MIDDLE CLASS- A SINGLE WOMAN
WHO WAS FINALLY WORKING WITH A
LOAN OFFICER TO PURCHASE A HOME
BUT I LOST MY JOB TWO YEARS
PRIOR. IF GET GROWN I WOULD
SPACE WITH THE TRUTH OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE A BLACK WOMAN IN
AMERICA ESPECIALLY ONE ENDURING
POVERTY I LEARNED QUICKLY-
COUNTRY VALUES AND WHO DOES
NOT. BLACK MIDDLE AGED ELDERLY
WOMEN CONTINUE TO TRACK OF ONE
OF THE NUMBER ONE DEMOGRAPHIC
DISPLACEMENT OF POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS BY HUGE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS AND
THIS IS NOT JUST YEAR AFTER
YEAR BUT IT'S LITERALLY DECADE
AFTER DECADE. THAT IS WHY SB
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT. SEVENTY
EIGHT AUTHORED. BY THE DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER- IT'S SO
IMPORTANT- SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT. EXCUSE SB SEVENTY EIGHT
WILL MAKE HELLO THE FIRST-
STATE TO RECORD UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN WHO HUMANITY HAS BEEN SO
LONG OVER. AND DENIED I MUST
TELL YOU MANY OF THE WOMEN THAT
I'VE MET ALONG THE WAY THEIR
STORIES INTERTWINED WITH MINE
BY SINGLE THREAD. WALKING WE
ARE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
WE ARE TRAUMA SURVIVORS
THINKING TO TRY AND HE'LL- AND
WE ARE MIDDLE AGED AND ELDERLY.
BY REQUIRING THE STATE TO
CREATE STRATEGIES TO END
HOMELESSNESS FOR UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN WE CAN TAKE REAL STEPS
TOWARDS MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF. FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
WHO ARE WITH OUT HOMES IN THE
STATE TODAY. SIMPLY PUT WE CAN
NO LONGER TALK ABOUT EQUALITY
AND EMPOWERMENT WALK YOU CAN
YOU WING WENT FORTH IN EQUITIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. TO THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- LET'S GO TO THE
NEXT MINUS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN CHIU AN HONORABLE
COUNTY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ACTUALLY WARM UP AND THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER AT
THE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER IN
LOS ANGELES THE AUTHOR OF THE
LEGISLATION UP FOR YOU TODAY.
SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT THE
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ACT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A NATIONAL LEADER IN
THE FIGHT AND WEBER COUNTLESS.
THREE SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT.
CALIFORNIA BECOME THE FIRST
STATE TO DESIGNATE
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WITHOUT CHILDREN OR OTHER
DEPENDENTS AS UNIQUE ALMOST A
POPULATION. WILL ALSO REQUIRE
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
FINANCING COUNCIL TO USE THE
DATA COLLECTION A SUBPOPULATION
AND THEN INPUT INTO THE
RECENTLY RELEASED ALMOST DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM TO SET
MEASURABLE GOALS FOR PRODUCING
AN ENDING ON A COOKING
EQUIPMENT HELPLESSNESS.
HISTORICALLY INVISIBLE TO
POLICYMAKERS AS HOT ONLY BEGAN
TO SEGREGATING DATA BY GENDER
TWENTY FIFTEEN. UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN'S HOMELESSNESS HAS SURGED
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
INCREASING BY 20% NATIONALLY.
WHILE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF ON
HOUSE WOMEN HAS REMAINED FLAT.
TODAY MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
WOMEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
NATIONALLY ARE NOW DOING SO BY
THEMSELVES. YOU'RE IN
CALIFORNIA UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
MAKE UP 33% OF ALL OUR
HOUSELESS NEIGHBORS. AND 40% OF
INDIVIDUAL. A TOTAL OF FIFTY
THREE. FIVE HUNDRED WOMEN A
POPULATION TWICE OUT OF ON
HOUSE FAMILIES AND THAT OF ON
HOUSE VETERANS AN UNACCOMPANIED
YOU COMBINED. AS GOVERNMENTS TO
WORK TO CALL OUT SPECIFIC
HOMELESS SUBPOPULATIONS THE
PAST DECADE AND THEN PROVIDE
RESOURCES TAILORED TO THEIR
UNIQUE MAKE. UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC AND INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. BUT INELIGIBLE FOR
PROGRAMS DESIGNED FOR FAMILIES
HAVE LARGELY FALLEN THROUGH THE
CRACKS. SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
BEGINS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
CONTINUED GENDERED INEQUITIES
FACED BY UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN.
THE WAIT ON AVERAGE MORE THAN
TEN YEARS TAXES STABLE HOUSING
AT A RATE TWICE THAT OF MATCH
AS IT WILL COMPEL THE STATE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME. WHEN EXIST AND HAVE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED WE ARE SO DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR CENTER SINGING
RUBIO INTRIGUING AND
CHAMPIONING SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT.
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF
THE STATE SENATE AS WELL FOR
FORTY FIVE LEADERS IN
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OPEN DOORS THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF TESTIMONY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
UPDATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT. WISH TO REGISTER
THEIR. SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. MISTER
SHURMUR'S RENMARK ON BEHALF OF
AIDS HEALTH FOUNDATION AND THE
HEALTHY HOW. FOUND A VERY
STRONG. THANK LET ME ASK ANYONE
FROM. TESTIMONY STATIONS. AND
ON THAT THE OPERATOR LINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. WHAT ARE
MY NUMBER SIX FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HEMY SIX
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NO POSITION. K. NINE FOUR
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FOUR ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. LET'S NOT
RESPONSIBLE ALONG TO LINE SIX
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SO WE HAD
HE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE- CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU LETTER TO THE- FOR
THE PLEASURE. NINE SIX SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALICE KESSLER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI ALISON
SELLAR BOX AND CLICK CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK. CHANGE. LINE THREE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE TERM
MEMBERS MARKET GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ACTUALLY MARSHON ECONOMIST
ANGELES WEST LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT THANKS. NINE SIX FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS JENNIFER POTS OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LINE SIX TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MAILING STAFF AND FROM
SUNNYVALE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS GEORGIA
ROSENBERG WITH BRASS I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ONE FOUR THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THE
JAPANESE WERE CALLING FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M WITH THE
AIDS HEALTH FOUNDATION AND I AM
IN SUPPORT. NINE FIVE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
I'M HAVING A THE HUMAN RIGHT
SUPPORT. ONE FIVE EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SH MY
NAME IS MARYLAND WELL AND I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M
CALLING IN FOR SUPPORT. ONE
FIVE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH. I'M SIXTY NOT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HERE ARE IN YOUR
OWN STATE WILL TURN ON THE HALF
OF THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
FOR WOMEN- HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. FIVE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SB
SIX SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SANDY
HUBBARD AND I'M SUPPORTING THE.
SIX SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TRACY
MULLIN DILATED I AM TRANSPORT
WITH THE CELL AND DINNER
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. FOR
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
FOR SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU LINE FOR
SEVENTEEN. I'M SO SORRY THANK
YOU MY NAME IS VERONICA BRISCOE
WITH AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND- NINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS KEREN
VERY WITH THE UNITED NATIONS
ASSOCIATION OF SANTA BARBARA
AND THE MONITOR THOSE PATIENTS
STRONGLY SUPPORTS ITSELF.
BEFORE WE OPEN LINE FOR FIFTY
FIVE LADIES GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. LINE FOR FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. JANUS ARBOR
COALITION FOR VALLEY NEIGHBOR
HOOD IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT. MY SIX OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO COVER CITY INTO
COURT AT SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR HONORABLY. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IS GOING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION WITNESS- LET'S OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO ANYONE HERE IN
THIS HEARING ROOM SEEN NONE ANY
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
SAY NONE. ARE GOING TO THE
OPERATOR LINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE THREE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THANK
YOU YEAH THIS IS- DAVID I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS UNLESS IT
INCLUDED THE MAN OF ALL MEN
ALSO BETTER DIFFERENT THAN THEY
SHOULD BE OUT OF THE TO BE IN
HOUSING. THANK YOU FOR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS MS
WORKS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORD I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AND I THINK I MOVED TO
THE BILL. BUT IF I'M GONNA DO
IT AGAIN. ESTERBROOK YEAH I
WILL. GLADLY SECOND THE BILL I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE- THE
AUTHORED APPRECIATE YOU FOR SO
OFTEN. GIVING VOICE TO FOLKS IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHO DON'T HAVE A
VOICE AND LIFTING THEM UP AND
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. WITHOUT ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. FNF'S FRIEND I WILL
THINK SHARE ADVOCACY FOR THIS-
MADAM SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
CHIO HI TO YOU I SAY OUR
TELETHON HERE TO AYE GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN QUICK SILVA HI
QUICK SILVA I LICKS AYE LOOKS
BACK. THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
YOUR BILL PASSES THANK YOU
THINK. I JUST WANNA MAKE OUT
ONE CLARIFYING REMARKS I KNOW-
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO
CAN FLOAT AROUND DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES WILL CALL THEM BACK
TO VOTE HOPEFULLY BY THE END
AND UNTIL THEN- A NUMBER OF
BILLS- THAT. WE ARE ON CALL
INCLUDING FILE IN THREE FIVE
AND ONE. WITH THAT. LET'S BRING
UP CENTER HERTZBERG TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM NINE SB. SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THINKS THE FIRST TIME
IT BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE MY
RECOLLECTION IS CORRECT- THANK
YOU THREE FOUR EIGHT I'M
CARRYING THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
REQUEST FROM HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY TO FIX THAT THE CORK
SO TO SPEAK IN THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW THAT THE
CLARIFICATION ALLOW NONPROFITS
LIKE HABITAT FOR HUMANITY TO
SERVE FAMILIES WITH LIMITED
INCOMES BY ALLOWING THEM TO
PURCHASE A PROPERTY FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP- WHICH CURRENTLY
IS NOT IN THE CASE IN THE LAW
WITH THAT- HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR- ANY MEMBER. YES
WHEN WE GO TO YOUR ONE WITNESS-
ON THE PHONE LINE TO JAMES
JARRARD HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAMES
GERARD AND I AM THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS COORDINATOR AT
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY OF ORANGE
COUNTY. IN MY ROLE I WORK WITH
CITIES AND LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS.
TO HELP FIND NEW WAYS TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE AND WORKFORCE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
HABITAT IS CONTINUALLY LOOKING
FOR INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
BUILD NEW AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP HOUSING. WHEN
HABITAT IS NOT THE DEVELOPER
THEMSELVES IN ONE OF THESE
SOLUTIONS IS TO PARTNER WITH
LOCAL DEVELOPERS USING THE
DENSITY BONUS AND ASSIST THEM
IN PROVIDING. THE AFFORDABLE
UNITS REQUIRED UNDER THE
DENSITY LAW ESSENTIALLY HABITAT
WOULD ACQUIRE THE AFFORDABLE
UNITS BUILT UNDER THE DENSITY
BONUS AND SELDOM TO QUALIFIED
HABITAT PROGRAM FAMILIES. UNDER
OUR MODEL HABITAT ACQUIRES THE
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND PLACES ARE
FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL COVENANT
ON THE HOME. THIS ALLOWED
HABITAT TO PURCHASE THE HOME
BACK FROM THE PROGRAM FAMILY
WHEN THEY ARE READY TO PURCHASE
A FAIR MARKET RATE HOME WITH
THE EQUITY ACCRUED UNDER THE
HABITAT MODEL. HOW DID THAT
THEMSELVES THE HOME TO A NEW
INCOME QUALIFIED PROGRAM FAMILY
IS FOR FIRST READING REFUSAL
INSURERS THAT ARE HOMES REMAIN
AFFORDABLE IN PERPETUITY. THESE
PARTNERSHIPS COULD HELP HABITAT
BUILD MORE HOMES FOR FAMILIES
THAT ARE READY FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP HOWEVER UNDER
CURRENT DENSITY BONUS LAW
LANGUAGE HABITAT IS NOT AN
ELIGIBLE PURCHASER AT THE
NONPROFIT WHICH HAS LIMITED OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE QUALITY
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. TO
LOW AND VERY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. BECAUSE HABITAT TAKES
POSSESSION OF THE UNITS IN THE
INTERIM WHILE WE QUALIFIED
BUYERS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
BEEN HESITANT TO APPROVE THIS
MODEL. THIS IS FLOOD HABITATS
ABILITY TO BUILD THESE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH DEVELOPERS
AND TO PROVIDE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. SB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PROVIDE THE
CLARIFICATION ON WHO WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A QUALIFIED BUYER.
AND THAT NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
LIKE HABITAT CAN HELP MAXIMIZE
THE FOR SALE AFFORDABLE UNITS
BUILT UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT FOR CELL UNITS
BUILT UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS
WON'T BE LOST TO MARKET RATE
WHICH UNDER CURRENT LAW IS
TRIGGERED IF UPON RESALE. THEY
ARE NOT SOLD TO ANOTHER INCOME
QUALIFIED BUYER WITHIN SIX
MONTHS SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
ENSURES THE HABITAT COULD
PURCHASE THESE UNITS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR AFFORDABILITY
PROVIDING LOW AND VERY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WITH THE
STATE'S. DECENT PLACE TO CALL
HOME FOR THESE REASONS I HAVE
LISTED HABITAT APPS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR HERTZBERG AND THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- THAT WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. HERE AND
THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM. THE
FUTURE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IS HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. STORES ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE END OF THE ROPE TESTIMONY
STATIONS SEEN NONE GOING TO THE-
OPERATOR PLACE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN TO EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIX SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MONITEAU THIRTIETH IN
HERE AND BURNS THE PART THANK
YOU FOR THIS BILL. THREE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
TURN MEMBERS OF THE NOT IN
ATLANTA PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS PER
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIX SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK MY NAME IS SANDY
HUBBARD AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. SIX THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE ONE PAIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AT WORK.
FOUR TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR- THREE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHY NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. LET'S
NOT RESPONSIBLE THE LONG LINE
SIX AT NIGHT AND WIND UP AT.
SURELY LEARN OUT THE SUPPORT.
FOR TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHARACTERS WRITING LOS
ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT. SIX
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY AT THE TRACY MILLER CALLING
WITH SAN FERNANDO IN B. ABOUT
TO HAPPEN LAYING IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU. TO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. UNLIKE ABLE A PATH PER-
EVERYTHING TIME VALLEY LIVE
LOOK. STRONG SUPPORT OF
ATHLETES. TO SEVEN TWO EIGHT
THANK YOU. THE COMMISSION
BEFORE WE ARE LINE THREE TWENTY
NINE PLAYS AND GENTLEMEN
DEBORAH. IF YOU WISH TO HELP
FOR SB SEVEN TWO EIGHT MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE AT THIS TIME.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE YEAR
LIGHTED OPEN. YOUR CALENDAR
SHOULD OAKS HOME ASSOCIATION
HERE WE NEIGHBORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ELIZABETH HENRY
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA FROM SAVE
LAFAYETTE- LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS IN SUPPORT.
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE WANTS
SUPPORT AT THE TIME THANK YOU
NOW LET'S GO TO- THERE IS NO
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESS LET'S
GO BACK TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO
STATE THEIR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO ONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. NO ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION AND TO THE
OPERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVEN
TWO EIGHT TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI DAVID LATELY IN
OPPOSITION ANALYSTS CLARIFIED
TO ME THAT BROTHERS WITHOUT THE
DOWN PAYMENT NOW IT'S BEEN
FOUND TO BE WITHOUT THE DOWN
PAYMENT LATER. THEY NEED TO BE.
TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I TO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. READ IT OKAY MY
APOLOGIES- MELANIE WISE JANET
LONG AGO AT NINE OH FOUR OH
FIVE ON AYE OPPOSED. SEVEN TWO
EIGHT. NINE FIVE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I OPPOSED SEVEN
TO EIGHT MARCECA LOS ANGELES.
BEFORE WE OPEN OUR NEXT LINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SHOW UP
IN THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS SANDRA WALLACE
FROM THE MAGNOLIA AVENUE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION OF
SILICON VALLEY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND I SHOW NO
ONE ELSE ON OPPOSITION. GREAT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
COMMENTS. OUR MOTION OF THE
BILL FOR. THEIR SECOND. YEAH TO
THE CENTER PRESS EIGHT YOU
BRING THIS FORWARD I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE SUPPORT IN
THIS COMMITTEE- BUT ALSO JUST
AGAIN PREFIGURE GAUGE PENTAGON
DENSITY BONUS LAW WITH REGARDS
TO NON PROFITS THAT ARE DOING
GOOD WORK IN THE SPACE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHERISHED WATER PURSE
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I NOTICED ON
THE CALL THAT THE FORMER CITY
MAYOR OF BURBANK- MAYOR GAVE
THE LADY WAS ON AND- MY FOLKS
FROM SHERMAN OAKS WHICH I DID
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ON I
JUST WANT TO THE POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO REACH OUT
TO THEM. AND I WANTED TO SAY TO
THANK AGAIN THE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY WHICH IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY ORGANIZATION AND
LASTLY TO TELL YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS THEY SAY IN THE
MOVIES ALL BE BACK I'M WORKING
HARD AT A HOMEOWNERSHIP PLAN
THAT IS GOING TO BE AS BIG AS
BIG CAN BE AND WILL BE BACK
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ON IT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASK FOR HIGH VOTE ALL I
WOULD SAY IS. HOSTILITIES THE
BABY. AND WITH THAT MANAGE-
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CHIU HI
CHIU I SAY ARE TO. ARE THERE TO
ALL RIGHT GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KALRA KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN PORK SILVA
QUICKSILVER I WITH X. THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES YOUR BILL PASSES
AND WITHOUT OUR FINAL ALL
THROUGH THE DAY SIR WE ARE
WELCOME YOU HAVE THREE ITEMS-
AND HAPPY TO TAKE UP THE ADDAMS
IN ANY ORDER THAT YOU WISH. I
HAVE A FEW EXTRA BILLS IF YOU
WANT TO DO FIVE OR SIX
DIFFERENT. HEY IF YOU WANT TO
START WITH FIVE AND SIX- TO GET
THOSE ON THE WAY IT'S UP TO YOU.
FIVE OR SIX BILL. I WAS THERE-
FIVE OR SIX BILLS ARE SAME FILE
ITEM FIVE OR FILE ITEM SIX.
OKAY I'M SORRY WHAT WAS THE
ORDER AGAINST IT IT'S UP TO
YOU- YOU TELL US WHAT YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT FIRST. GRADE I'LL
START WITH US SENATE BILL TEN.
FILE ITEM FORESTS SB TEN CENTER
GREAT- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'D- FIRST LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND IT'S UP FOR OUR
WORKING WITH US AS ALWAYS- AND-
I APPRECIATE YOU- TAKING WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS HAD WE- COME UP
WITH- OR FINALIZE THEM EARLIER.
AND TAKING THEM AS AUTHOR
REQUESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
IS I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS- I- PROBABLY CYNICAL
TIMES A- REINTRODUCTION OF LAST
YEAR'S SENATE BILL NINE OH TWO-
IT HAS BEEN IT IS A LITTLE
NARROWER THAN LAST YEAR'S-
BILL- BUT OVERALL VERY SIMILAR-
TO THE BILL- THIS BILL. WHICH
IS NOT HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR BECAUSE THEY WERE
ONLY SINGLE REFERRALS- SB TEN
INCENTIVIZES- CITIES AND
COUNTIES- TO CONCENTRATE NEW
HOUSING DENSITY. IN URBAN IN
FILL IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS- BY
GIVING CITIES A VOLUNTARY TOOL
AND I THINK- SOMETIMES THERE'S
A LOT OF INFORMATION THAT
SPREADS AROUND ABOUT
LEGISLATION IT'S IMPORTANT. TO
NOTE SB TEN IS PURELY VOLUNTARY
FOR CITIES THAT DO NOT HAVE TO
UTILIZE IT THE CITY IGNORES IT
AND TAKES NO ACTION. SB TIME
WILL HAVE NO APPLICATION IN
THAT CITY. WE FREQUENTLY- TELL
CITIES WE WANT YOU TO DO MORE
ON HOUSING ONE OF HIS OWN FOR
MORE. HOUSING WHAT YOU TO ALLOW
MORE HOUSING. BUT THEN WE MAKE
A REALLY HARD FOR CITIES TO DO
THAT SB TIME- I'VE HEARD THAT
LOUD AND CLEAR WITH CITIES THAT
PLEASE JUST MAKE OUR LIVES
EASIER SB TEN DOES THAT. BY
SAYING THAT IF THE CITY DECIDES
THAT HE WANTS HIS OWN. FOR
SMALL MULTI UNIT CONSTRUCTION
UP TO TEN UNITS IN AN INFILL OR
TRANSIT RICH AREA. OF THE CITY
CAN DO SO IN A MUCH MORE
STREAMLINED AND EXPEDITED WAY
THIS WILL MAKE CITIES LIVES A
LOT EASIER- AND- I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD POWERFUL NEW TOOL.
FOR CITIES WE KNOW THE MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING. A LOT OF TIMES
WE GET THIS CHOICE OF EUROPE
SINGLE FAMILY. OR YOU HAVE A
REALLY HUGE- BUILDINGS MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING NEEDS TWO THREE
FOUR UP HIM UP TO TEN UNIT
BUILDINGS- IS A REALLY GOOD
OPTION IT'S LESS EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD. IT MELTS INTO A
NEIGHBORHOOD MORE BECAUSE IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY- SHE DOES HAVE
TO BE A HUGE BUILDING- AND IT
WILL HELP US TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY. TO
MAKE HOUSING MORE ABUNDANT AND
MORE- AFFORDABLE- SO- THIS-
LET'S. DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
CHANGE HOW INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS.
ARE APPROVED IT'S SIMPLYTHE
ZONING. TO STREAMLINE THE
ZONING PROCESS. INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS WILL STILL BE DONE
HOWEVER THEY WOULD NORMALLY-
HERBAL. APPROVED OR NOT
APPROVED. BASED ON THE NORMAL
APPROVAL PROCESSES CITIES HAVE
IN PLACE NOW WHETHER THAT IS A
MINISTERIAL PROCESS. OR
DISCRETIONARY PROCESS. AS A
COLLEAGUES IS A GOOD BILL
WORTHY OF SUPPORT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPRT OF THE BILL ARE RICARDO
FLORES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. YEAH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DIRECTOR OF
LIST CONSENT SAN DIEGO. AND
ZACHARY HAMILTON WHO IS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN GILROY. THANK
YOU LET'S NOW GO TO YOUR MAIN
WITNESSES TO THE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ALLOW. MR
FLORES AND MR HAMILTON TO
TESTIFY. WHEN THEY'RE OPEN. THE
COMMITTEE FOR SOMEONE TO GO
FIRST. HAPPY FOR EITHER OF YOU
TO GO. OKAY I'LL START OFF MY
NAME IS RICARDO FLORES ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SAN DIEGO
AND NATIONAL NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION. EACH OF YOU TODAY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FULFILL THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF TRUE
INTEGRATION MARKETS WILL EAT
HIGHER PRAISE BUT WHERE WE LIVE
WHO OUR KIDS GROW UP WITH. BUT
N ORDER TO FULFILL THIS
PROMISE YOU ALMOST BE
COURAGEOUS. NOT COURAGEOUS LIKE
JOHN LEWIS WHEN HE CROSSED THE
EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE THE FAITH
THE PHYSICAL BRUTALITY OF
RACISM ON THE OTHER SIDE THE
COURAGEOUS TO DO WHAT YOU ALL
KNOW IT'S RIGHT. I AFFECT YOU
END THE CURRENT APARTHEID IN
CITIES LIKE SAN DIEGO AND ALLOW
GROUPS LIKE LET AND OUR
PARTNERS THE URBAN LEAGUE IT
CHICAGO FEDERATION AND OTHERS
THE BILL CALLING FOR BY POP
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND HIGH WELL LOW
CRIME NEIGHBORHOOD. BUT AS I
SPEAK TO YOU HERE TODAY IT IS
THE LEGAL BY LAW THE BILL THIS
TYPE OF HOUSING AND LOW CRIME
HIGH. WEALTH NEIGHBORHOODS
THINK ABOUT THAT. THAT IS I
IT'S STOCKPILE ALREADY WITH
PALATABLE AND YOU TO PASS AT
THE END. AT STATE LAWMAKER YOU
CAN NO MORE TERM A BLIND EYE TO
THE CURRENT APARTHEID IN ALL OF
OUR CITIES IN CALIFORNIA. IN
APARTHEID IT FORCES PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND POOR PEOPLE TO DIE
EARLIER A TEN LOW PERFORMING
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. EARN LESS OVER
THEIR LIFE IT STICKER AND KATE
HIGHER. LEVELS OF CLIMATE
JUSTICE. FEATURED HERE HAVE
BEEN A- WHAT THEY- AND THE
LEAGUE PART ON OUR- ENHANCE.
AND RESTORE PROPERTY RIGHT. AND
SET IN MOTION A WORLD YOU MAY
NEVER SEE BUT ONE IN WHICH ALL
OF YOU KNOW MY COME TO BE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. HELLO COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS STAFF AND THE PUBLIC
AND ACTON RESIDENT OF YOUR
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ADVOCATE ANY
DURING CITY COUNCIL MEMBER WE
ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
DREAM OF OWNING A HOME IS NOT A
REALISTIC OPORTUNITY FOR
EVERYONE. YOU MUST CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT OF MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR ALL
INCOME LEVELS. WHILE LOOKING
TOWARDS CREATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE
AT THE TIME. I'VE HAD STRUGGLED
WITH HOW THEY KNOW THEIR LITTLE
FAMILY GROUP. AT THE BAY AREA
FIREFIGHTER I WASN'T ABLE TO
AFFORD A HOME WHERE I WORK. I'M
STILL WORKING AS A FIREFIGHTER
IN THE KEEP YOU CAN SOMETIMES
BE AN HOUR AND A HALF OR LONGER.
LAST YEAR'S OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
HOUSING HAS LED ME TO BECOME
OUT IN ADVOCATE ENJOYED OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE REGION
IN SOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS
IS NEXT MINUTE CYCLE GONNA
THINKING CREATIVITY. ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND ADEQUATE SMALL
PROJECTS THE BIG ONES WE CAN'T
GROW IN A MAJORITY OF OUR LAND
IS OUR FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND GO RIGHT
IT'S ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED IN
MEETINGS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT MISDEMEANOR HOUSING.
DUPLEXES TRIPLEXES IMPORT LEXUS
CALIFORNIA HAS DESCENDED INTO A
SUFFOCATING HOUSING CRISIS
CONTRIBUTING ABOUT MIGRATION
OUT OF STATE SKYROCKETING
PENSION RATES. RECORD LEVELS OF
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AND A
GROWING CLASS OF LOWER. LOWER
INCOME COMMUTERS UNABLE TO
AFFORD OR ACCESS HOW THE WITHIN
SEVERAL HOURS THEIR JOB. SB
TENTATIVE SYMBOL BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
RENO NEIGHBORHOODS FOR
INCREASED HOUSING DENSITY OF
THE TOWN HOMES PER PARCEL. THIS
AUTHORIZATION WILL REQUIRE THAT
A LEGISLATIVE BODY AFTER
LEARNING TO ADOPT THE PLAN AND
EXEMPT THAT DON'T NEED ACTION
FROM BEING CONSIDERED A PROJECT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA CAUGHT
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT. I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT SB TEN WHICH
DOES NOT CHANGE LOCAL HIGH THE
NEXT STEP BACKS. OBJECTIVE
DESIGN STANDARDS RESTORED
SANDERS OR DEMOLITION
RESTRICTION. SB CAN CREATE THE
PATH THE AUDI MODELS DENSITY TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
SHORTAGE PRESERVE SIGNIFICANT
LOCAL CONTROL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO MAKE THE
FASTER. LESS EXPENSIVE AND LESS
RISKY FIRST STATE BERTH CITY TO
UNDERTAKEN COMMUNITY PROCESS.
TO INCREASE DENSITY IN OUR
COMMUNITY SB CANDIDATE AFFECTED
SUPPORTING FIXING WHAT HAS BEEN
A HISTORY PROBLEM THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE. THANK YOU ANY
CONCLUSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BUT- THANK YOU NOW LET
US GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO SPEAK. TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- AS
WE HAVE BEEN DOING ALL
AFTERNOON IF YOU COULD PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME. YOUR
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT SO AGAIN DAVID CHIU SAN
FRANCISCO SUPPORT WITH THAT
WITH A COUPLE OF FOLKS HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. PLEASE MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DHINGRA FEEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN THANK YOU CENTER
WINTER FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU. OUR
STORES WITH THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MODEST AND DENSITY THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK YOU-
LET'S NOT GO TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. SEE NO ONE
THERE LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION SUPPORT. I'D
BE GLAD TO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY
FOUR IN Q. NINE TWO FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. EVENING THIS
IS JACQUELYN WITH UT ACTION AND
THE BANK- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE SIX THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MARIN
DILANSIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. NINE FOUR NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ROTH OF SADDAM HELD
ON BEHALF OF SANTA CRUZ IN THE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. LINE SIX
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIMBERLY DOWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE SIX EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE SIX EIGHT THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IF
I NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU. AND WHICH ARE RESPONSIBLE
ALONG TO LINE SIX EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX EIGHT
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALLERGIES ARE KEEPING FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AUTOMATICALLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THREE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DOESN'T MATTER THAT
WE HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT- FACEBOOK ASSEMBLY FOR
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION ON ITS BURKE TMG
PARTNERS DECAMPED COUNCIL
MENTAL BUILDERS. CIRCULATE SAN
DIEGO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION BAY AREA COUNCIL
FEELS THAT AND TIMES
OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. NINE SIX NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANASTASIA CULTURE QUICK
CALIFORNIA VISORS ON BEHALF OF
BELOW IN SUPPORT OF THAT YOU
CAN TAKE YOUR. SIX NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR MIND
IS A NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU SIX NINE SIX. TO RESPOND TO
MOVE ALONG TO LINE SIX SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS TRACY MELANCHOLIC
AND I REPRESENT THE CITY OF
ENCINO SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN
B. R. AT THAT THE NBA
CALIFORNIA BE ABUNDANT HOUSING
LA WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS
CERTAIN CRIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT. THANKS SO MUCH.
SEVEN OH SEX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON FROM THE OPEN
PALO ALTO AND POTENTIAL FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT. SIX NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI KEVIN MOM
AB TWENTY FAR WITNESSES FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT SB.
TEN THREE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO ALFRED CUTE WITH
EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE IN YOUR
BE ACTION BOTH OF THESE ORG
SUPPORT SBTECH THANK YOU. LINE
SEVEN HUNDRED AT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROBERT
SUTTON I WOULD- SAN FRANCISCO
YOU. CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GABRIEL BATTED IN CINEMA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK
YOU. SIX NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS M. PAULSON FROM THE LOS
ALTOS. A PORTABLE HELPING ALIGN
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FOUR NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS A PUBLIC
MORE- CALIFORNIA BEAT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SEVEN OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. RIGHT FROM
CULVER CITY CA MORE OPENS ARE
GOING TO TRANSPORT. YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI OUTLINES SELLER
TRONG COURT YEAH YEAH. SEVEN OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
TO BE MORE SHAUNA CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES ON BEHALF OF
WEBSITE FOR EVERYONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIVE THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ABSOLUTE
MONARCH GENERATION HOUSING AND
SONOMA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SIX NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CANNOT BROUGHT INTO NOW
MICHAEL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SIX EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI NORMA GOODMAN FROM
NAPA CALLING WITHIN THE ACTION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FOUR NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS COMING OUT
LATE FROM BEAUTIFUL EIGHTY
FIFTY THREE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SIX FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
BARBARA NORRIS A MEDINA
RESIDENT AT FORTY- CALLING FROM
SUPPORTERS BECOME. SIX SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS BRIAN PRESCOTT
CALLING FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA- I'M A MEMBER OF
STOP A UNIQUE AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TEN. SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO JOHN
FRIENDS UP IN NORWALK
CALIFORNIA AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SEVEN ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT IT'S A SEVEN ZERO KI<c.cyan> A</c>
MEMBER OF SANTA CRUZ HAMBY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVEN
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN HIGHER
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP MORE PROBABLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
SEVEN SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TRICIA CRANE SHARE OF
NORTHEAST NEIGHBORS OF SANTA
MONICA PROUD TO REPORT THAT
SANTA MONICA CITY COUNCIL VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
CAN. I'LL JUST REMIND FOLKS
THIS IS THE SUPPORT LINE IF YOU
COULD JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SEVEN
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS STEVE MARA SIR WHAT'S
OUTSIDE TOWARD IN CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND BEFORE WE
OPEN LINE SIX EIGHTY THREE AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE SIX EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SIX
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO OPEN
NINE SEVEN TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SHARE MEMBERS THIS IS JIM
CARREY AND- FROM OUR OUR
SUPPORTER BASE BE CARE. THE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS GREEN I
LIVE IN PLEASANTON AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL DEFINITELY IN
PRESSURE. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORNING Q. BUT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE SIX EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. SIX EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SIX
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WITH NO RESPONSE I WILL
HOLD THE LINE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU NOW LET'S
GO TO THE OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
WE HAVE TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
INTO THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW MAYOR BRAND FOR
AND ON THE BEACH AND MARK
STIVERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP TO SPEAK- I
AM. I REALIZED MARKETS HERE IN
THE CHAMBER- WHEN WE START WITH
MR STIVERS WHO'S HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM MR STIVERS. GREAT
MARKS DIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. I WANT TO
START BY SAYING WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE CENTER WINNERS ROLES
THE CHAMPION FOR HOUSING. AND
WE'RE VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL TO GROW THE
HOUSING STOCK- GENERALLY.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO ONE SINGLE
PROVISION THAT WAS ADDED IN
LATE MAY WE MUST- REPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- THIS PROVISION
ACTUALLY REDUCES THE ABILITY OF
EXISTING OPPORTUNE REDUCES
EXISTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNDER TWO
SCENARIOS. BY LIMITING THEIR
ABILITY TO USE THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING AND OR THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS THIS LEGISLATURE
SPENT SO MUCH TIME ON OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. WE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR WE
HAVE OFFERED HIM AN AMENDMENT
AND WE'RE HOPING TO HEAR BACK
VERY SOON ON THAT WERE WE
APPRECIATE HIS IS
CONSIDERATION. AND IN GENERAL
THE AMENDMENT WOULD TREAT THE
UP SONY TO TEN UNITS PER PARCEL
AS AN OVERLAY ZONE SO THAT
DEVELOPERS COULD STILL USE THE
UNDERLYING ZONING THE OF THE
CURRENTLY IS OWNING THE CURRENT
ZONING. TO DO PROJECTS THAT ARE
LARGER THAN TEN UNITS SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU LET'S NOW GO TO MAYOR
BRANDS ON THE PHONE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE CHIU AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
BILL BRANDON HAVE BEEN ELECTED
MAYOR OF REDONDO BEACH FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. RECENTLY
REELECTED FOR ANOTHER FOUR
REDONDO BEACH IS ELEVEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS PER SQUARE
MILE MORE DENSELY POPULATED IN
LONG BEACH IN FACT WE HAVE THE
SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM HERE IN
REDONDO BEACH. MUCH OF S. B.
RESTATE THE OBVIOUS THAT CITIES
CAN REZONING A PARCEL FOR TEN
RESIDENTIAL UNITS PER ACRE. WE
CAN ALREADY DO THAT AND WE HAVE
FOR MUCH MORE WE DON'T NEED SB
TEN. THIS BILL DOES ALLOW US TO
CIRCUMVENT SEEK WITH- HOWEVER
BUT WE WOULDN'T WHY WOULD WE
NOT WANT TO ANALYZE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE
CHANGE THAT COULD MEAN THE
ADDITION OF HUNDREDS OR EVEN
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTIAL UNITS.
SHE WAS AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO
ALLOW GROWTH WITHOUT DESTROYING
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE. SB TEN AT
THE MARKET RATE OR LUXURY
HOUSING BILLS. IT DOES NOTHING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHAT IS
REALLY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN FACT SIMPLY
ALLOWING MORE MARKET RATE
HOUSING DRIVES UP THE DEMAND TO
BUILD MORE MARKET RATE HOUSING.
AND THE COST OF BUILDING FOR
EVERYONE INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
WHAT IS NEEDED. CITIES DON'T
BUILD HOUSING THAT THEY DOESN'T
BUILD HOUSING DEVELOPERS BUILD
HOUSING AND THEY WANT TO BUILD
MORE MARKET RATE LUXURY
HOUSING. BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE MONEY'S AND WHO CAN BLAME
THEM SB TEN ENABLES MORE OF
THIS. NOT ONLY DID THAT THE
TENANT NOR THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. MOST
IMPORTANTLY A SECTION OF IT
VIOLATES ARTICLE TWO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
SIMPLY STATES QUOTE INITIATIVE
AND REFERENDUM POWERS MAY BE
EXERCISED BY THE ELECTORS OF
EACH CITY- COUNTY. UNDER
PROCEDURES BY THE LEGISLATURE
SHALL PROVIDE. THIS IS NOT
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT IT'S JUST
VERY SIMPLE NISSHIN SHIPPING
REPRIMAND POWERS MAY BE
EXERCISED BY THE LECTORS IN
EACH CITY OR COUNTY. THE
LEGISLATURE CAN'T SIMPLY PASSED
THE LAW TO UNDO THE POWER OF
THE PEOPLE PROVIDED BY THE
CONSTITUTION. AMENDING THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES A
STATEWIDE PUBLIC VOTE NOT A
SIMPLE MAJORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. CENTER WIENER WITH
THROUGH THAT SECTION OF SB NINE
OH TWO LAST YEAR YOU SHOULD
REMOVE IT AGAIN. SB TEN IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE
DOES NOTHING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOU CAN DRIVE UP THE
COST OF HOUSING. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND THAT'S THE
REAL PURPOSE OF THIS BILL OVER
RIGHT VOTER APPROVED
INITIATIVES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU KNOW VOTE ON S. B. TEN I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THIS POINT NOW LET'S
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
THAT OPPOSE SB TEN. FIRST HERE
IN THE CA. RESEARCHER MEMBERS
RAN LONG ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOW HOUSING FOUNDATION
WE HAVE A SUPPORT UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION WHICH
REASSURED WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION SEE
NOW LET'S GO TO THE OPERATOR
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ACKNOWLEDGE. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION AGAIN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND THE FACT THE OPPOSE DAVID
CHIU SAN FRANCISCO OPPOSE FOR
EXAMPLE. IT'LL START LINE SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY I THOUGHT I WAS
PLACED IN THE SUPPORT QUEUE BUT
MY NAME IS JOSH BEHIND FROM
ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPEECH AND. NEXT TO A
LINE FOR TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS ON
RUSSIA METERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF PALO ALTO HALF MOON
BAY IN THE TRI VALLEY CITIES
DUBLIN LIVERMORE PLEASANTON
CHEN AMOUNT IN DANVILLE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. STE FIND SIX
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MAILING SEPTEMBER FROM
SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL ONE SIX OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE
ENTERTAINMENT CISCO BARBARY
COAST NEIGHBORHOOD STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. TEN ONE SEVEN OH
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
GREAT LOWER BURKE WITH CATALYST
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN.
SPECIALIZED THREE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY CHANCE
AFFECT ON BEHALF OF THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED REVERE HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION RESIDENTS
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
QUOTE TEN UNITS MELT INTO A
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS
SENATOR WIENER'S HALLUCINATING
AND THIS WOULD BE LARGER THAN
TEN UNITS THANK YOU FOR
OPPOSING AS I STATED PLEASE
JUST KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU
OPPOSED TO THE OPERATOR AS
WE'VE SAID BEFORE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CUT OFF SPEAKERS IF THEY
GO BEYOND THAT. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. ONE FOUR SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEWMAN IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OKAY
FOUNDATION STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SB CLAM MEAT THE TRANSFER CASE
AND FIERY THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE FIVE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOSH THIS IS MARCIA FROM
MIRACLE MILE LOS ANGELES I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE FIVE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
JENNIFER KENNEDY FROM PASADENA
L. A. COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED.
SPECIALIZED FOUR OH ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CLARK
YEAH I'M NOT CALLING FROM HIS
CELL BAY AREA AND SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SIXTY SIX I'D SAY
CAñADA SPACE TO MANI AND
STRONGLY OPPOSED S. B. TEN
THANK YOU. ONE SIX NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH YOLANDA
PERSICO OUT RESIDENTS LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TEN THANK YOU. LINE
FOR ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
ANY GEGEN HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN
COURT OF COMMUNITIES OF RENTERS
AND HOMEOWNERS WE SUPPORT
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
REPUBLIC CALIFORNIA UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN LOS ANGELES CHIEF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. LINE THREE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B. CAN
AND SB NINE THANK YOU. ONE
SEVEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SCHERING BURN MONITO BUT
THE ASIAN OPPOSED. NINE SEVEN
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS LEARN
THE TOTALLY FROM HELPING AT THE
HUMAN RIGHT AND I OPPOSE SB TEN
THANK YOU. LINE THREE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD- A GOLD AND A
HALF OF THE EARTH CARE GLOBAL
TV WATER FLOWS FREE NOT TESTED
TOMORROW. AND FOR QUALITY
GROWTH AND A MEMBER OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ABOUT SHASTA. ONE SIX EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
TERRY TAKE MAINTAIN ON BEHALF
OF WEST WITH HILLS PROPERTY
OWNERS ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
OUR SIX HUNDRED FAMILIES IN LOS
ANGELES AND A MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED. ONE THREE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARIA PABLO
CALVIN SHERMAN OAKS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CHAIR OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE
SIX SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURELY LEWANDOWSKI ALONG
WITH MY CITY OF DUBLIN AND
CALLIE AND LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND BCLC UNITED NEIGHBORS AND
CATALYST I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. LINE FOR TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARBOR BRADY
WENT TO SOUTH HOMEOWNERS THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED HELPFUL UNITED
NEIGHBORS LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
HOPING THIS LOOPHOLE THAT
UNDERMINE THE BOARD HOUSING
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS FOR OTHER
PROPERTIES. ONE TWO SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HOLLY OSBORNE I'M A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEER IN CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
REDONDO BEACH AND MEMBER UNITED
NEIGHBORS POLITICAL OPPOSE SB.
TEN ONE TO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GORLICE PLEASE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE EAST SIDE BOYS
AND CITIZENS ABOUT RESPONSIBLE
PLANNING IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. TRYING TO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
YES THIS IS LISA MORE WHERE
ABOUT PERCENT OF OUR A
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION AND FOR
THE REASONS MAYOR BRAND STATED
WE ARE VERY MUCH OPPOSED THANK
YOU. WINDS SIX TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIX TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARLENA TO STRAIN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND I'M OPPOSED TO SB.
TEN WINDS FIVE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES ERICSSON AND
IMPRESSED WITH CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE
THREE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE TEN. WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
HEAR YOU NNE THREE TEN. OKAY
MOVING ONLINE SEVEN OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
NANCY O'CONNOR SUSTAINABLE
RAFAELI AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS ENVIRONMENTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE LEGISLATION. S.
B. YEAH THANK YOU. ONE SIX
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
VAN DYNE VIDEO ALAMEDA LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA THE ONLY OPPOSE
STATE MANDATED ZONING SB. TEN
LINE FOR SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JENNIFER
HOLDEN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
PARK NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
OF SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINE- WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT
REMOVES THE CHOICE FOR CITIES
TO. MAKE THIS OP. IN LINE TO
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT I'M NOT
A GABELEIN DAY PASSED MAYOR
BURBANK LIVABLE CALIFORNIA A
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY SPEAKING
FOR THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS. I
THINK TENANTS NO LONGER CAN USE
AS A VERY SHORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIX SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS SANDY
HUBBARD REPRESENTING BETWEEN-
FIFTY HOUSEHOLDS AT THE VALLEY
VILLAGE RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION
WHICH THE MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND LOCAL BOOK
CALIFORNIA MORE STATE ARE
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS JERRY L.
JENSEN ON COMPLAINER. ARE THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH WATER FOR FTTN.
NEXT IN LINE SEVEN OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TELL THE POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS
AND SANTA MONICA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES VIRGINIA
CONNECTICUT AND THE TAIL WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE- S. B. TEN.
THANK YOU. ONE SIX NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. H. MORE SOLO
SERRANO OF LOS ANGELES AN
AFFILIATED STRONGLY OPPOSED
THIS ONE AND I'VE BEEN MANAGING
UP THE MESS. NINE SIX SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YET
JAPANESE GROWTH FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WITH THE EIGHT
HEALTH FOUNDATION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. LINE TWO
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
ALL RIGHT RENDON COUNTERPART
LITTLE CALIFORNIA- I OPPOSE SB.
TEN ONE SEVEN TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS BETH
WALLACE FROM THE MAGNOLIA NEW
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION OF
SILICON VALLEY WE OPPOSE SB.
TEN LINE SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO HEAR YOU. HELLO ARE
ENCOURAGED HIM FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NEXT TO A LINE SEVEN OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THEY
PASSED A PERISH- LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND A REALTOR IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE FIVE
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU THIS IS AND GREENSPON.
RIGHT FROM FOUR THOUSAND NORMAL
HOUSEHOLDS AND THE TENTS EIGHT
MILE NINETY ONE THOUSAND
POPULATION OF MONICA PLEASE
LOOK AT THE ALTERNATIVES AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN THANK
YOU. LINE THREE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH
HENRY LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIANS
REPRESENTED- SAVE LAFAYETTE-
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN. IS DISINGENUOUS. AND
THAT'S WHAT ONLINE SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL. HI
SORRY RIGHT I'M REPEATING IT HI
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH
OVERWHELMINGLY APOLOGETIC AND
ALONG ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
LET ME RETENTION THERE.
STRONGLY OPPOSED. ONE TWO THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE EIGHTY SEVEN OKAY GO
AHEAD. THREE TWO SEVEN IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO HEAR YOU. SH
HELLO YES YOUR. YES MY NAME IS
SANDRA FORTY NOW WITH AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AND SPEAKING.
INDEX OF MOVED ONLINE SIX
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RECALL WITH LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL. AND
ACTION DECLINED TO NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ANY THREE
YES. GENEVIEVE DOUGLAS- MEMBER
OF EASTSIDE VOICE IN LONG BEACH
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NEXT YOU LOOK GOOD ONLINE THREE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN
STEIN- COMO RESIDENTIAL
ORIGINATION OF LOS ANGELES.
OPPOSES THIS BILL. LINE TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THERESA ALTERADO IN PAUL
BABCOCK MEMBERS OF THE SITE
VOICE IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN. LINE
FOR SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATIE TWENTY A RESIDENT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. TEN THE TWO EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO
EIGHTY FIVE. WE WERE NOT UP
THERE. TWENTY FIVE YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU CAN HEAR ME
BECAUSE I DIDN'T GET A NUMBER-
ON BEHALF OF INDIVIDUAL
CALIFORNIA GREETING. THE BILL
KELTY FIFTY- WE STRONGLY
PROTEST BEGAN. ONE SEVEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THE HEARING. YES MY NAME IS AN
AUTOMATIC UNIT IN AND COMING
FROM A FRIEND THAT WAS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT IS V. TEN
MISTER WINNER PLEASE WALK AWAY.
THANK YOU. LINE FIVE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH MONTGOMERY
AND WITHOUT HIM FOR A LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL CITY FOR
LOCAL CONTROL AND KATELYN AND
WE ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN.
ONE SEVEN EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE ROBINSON AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE GREAT
VALLEY NEIGHBORHOODS GROUP
REPRESENTING THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS AND THE PART
BALLOT AREA FIFTY PLUS YET FELT
CIRCUMVENT THE LAFAYETTE
HOMEOWNERS COUNCIL WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER SIXTY H. AWAY
IN THE CITY OF LAFAYETTE. BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE MEMBERS OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE PLAN THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE JUST WANNA KNOW
WHERE E'RE AT THE FIFTEEN
MINUTE MARK SO WE'RE GOING TO
BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION.
COLLEAGUES ANY DISCUSSION. THIS
PROMOTION OF THE BILLS ARE
SECOND THERE'S BEEN A SECOND
ANY COMMENTS MR GABRIEL. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ME FOR THIS BILL
COULD YOU JUST- MAYBE WALK
EVERYBODY A LITTLE BIT THREE
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS. THAT
YOU ALLUDED TO HERE-
PARTICULARLY AS THEY WOULD
RELATE. TO OPEN SPACE AND VOTER
INITIATIVES I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF THOSE. ARE SHORT THANK YOU
ARE SORRY WRONG FOLDER ON THE-
I TRIED DIFFERENT WITHOUT HER.
YES SO THE WELL THERE WERE TWO
AMENDMENTS THAT WITH THAT ONE
IS- TAKING THE- IT'S ALWAYS OUT
OF THE BILL WITH THE ZONING
CHANGES VERY COMPLICATED WE
DECIDED TO WORK WITH THE FOLKS
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
TOWARDS POTENTIAL FUTURE
LEGISLATION HOW WE DEAL WITH
HOAS WE DON'T FEEL LIKE WE
DON'T NEED TO HANDLE IN THIS
BILL- BUT THE OTHER PIECE. WAS-
ABOUT THE LOCAL VOTER
INITIATIVES IN THE BILL AS IN
PRINT RIGHT NOW. I CITY COUNCIL
IN IMPLEMENTING- AND ESCHATON
REZONING. COULD DO SO EVEN IF-
AN INITIATIVE WOULD HAVE.
PREVENTED THAT- THE AMENDMENT
THAT WE HAVE REQUESTED THE
COMMITTEE TO- IMPOSE WHICH IS
NOW IN THE COMING THREE FOR
ACCEPTED TODAY. DRAMATICALLY
NARROWS THAT POWER OF THE CITY
COUNCIL- AND SO IT BASICALLY
WILL COMPLETELY REMOVE THE
ABILITY OF A CITY COUNCIL TO
TOUCH ANY KIND OF. OPEN SPACE
PROTECTION GREENBELT. PARKING
RECORD PARKER RECREATIONAL
SPACE ANYTHING THAT'S LIKE A
NON RESIDENTIAL. OPEN SPACE FOR
LACK OF A BETTER BROADER TERM.
ON IF YOU HAVE THE CITY HAS A
OPEN SPACE PROTECTION AGREE
ABOUT IT CETERA. DOT MEASURE.
BE AMENDED- MUCH NARROWER-
PROVISION HERE WILL NOT WHAT
WILL MEAN TO THE CITY COUNCIL
CAN NOT DO ANYTHING. TO
OVERRIDE THAT BALLOT MEASURE-
SO IT WOULD LIMITED ONLY WHERE-
WHERE THE VOTERS HAVE SAID YOU
CAN'T CHANGE THE ZONING ITSELF.
AND WE ALSO ARE PROVIDING EVEN
IN THAT NARROW CIRCUMSTANCE
WHICH IS MUCH LESS COMMON- IT
WILL REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS VOTE
OF THE COUNCIL. TO DO THAT- AND
AS YOU KNOW ONE OF MY
pTO ME WHO VOTED FOR THIS BILL
WHO DOESN'T NORMALLY OVER MY
HOUSING BILLS. THAT CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR VOTES SO WE
DRAMATICALLY. NARROWED THAT
PARTICULAR PROVISION. YES YOU
CENTER I THINK I HAVE A I HAVE
A SUSPICION ABOUT WHO THAT
MIGHT PAY- THAT VOTED FOR IT
AND AM I CORRECT THIS THIS THIS
TOOL THAT YOU WOULD BE PROVIDED
CITIES. IT'S COMPLETELY
VOLUNTARY CORRECT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I CITY COUNCIL
COULD DECIDE TO USE IF THEY
WANTED AND ALSO A CITY THAT
DIDN'T WANT TO DO THIS WOULD BE
FREE NOT TO USE IT THAT'S
CORRECT- I HEARD A LOUD AND
CLEAR. OF MY LIFE A LOT OF
PREVIOUS HOUSING BILL I DID
CITY SAYING JUST GIVE US MORE
TOOLS. AND I THINK SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO HAVE STANDARDS AND
RULES AND SOMETIMES YOU NEED TO
GIVE VOLUNTARY TOOLS. AND THIS
IS A TOTALLY VOLUNTARY BILL
BILL IF A CITY THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO ASK TO OPT OUT. IF THE
CITY DOES NOTHING TO SING NOR
IS IT. THEN THE BILL HAS NO
APPLICATION THAT CITY ONLY IF
THE CITY AFFIRMATIVELY. THE
CITY COUNCIL PASSES AN
ORDINANCE OR RESOLUTION ONLY
VAN THE CITY OFTEN OTHERWISE IT
HAS NO IMPACT PURELY VOLUNTARY.
YEAH I THINK I THINK YOU CENTER
ONO THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT I THINK THERE'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINTS THAT THAT ARE
WORTHY OF BEING ELEVATED. YOU
KNOW I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH FOLKS
IN MY COMMITTEE AND ALSO WITH A
LOT OF LOCAL IF. ELECTED
OFFICIALS ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO- YOU KNOW HAVE
HAVE WANTED TO TALK TO ME ABOUT
HOUSING POLICY. AND ONE OF YOU
KNOW IN IN SOME OF THEM HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED ABOUT
THINGS THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
DON AND I'M FRUSTRATED WITH
VOTES THAT I'VE TAKEN. IN YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS HAVE SENT TO ME AS-
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
ANTI HOUSING WE CAN ALL IT'S
THAT THERE'S A HOUSING CRISIS
WE JUST BELIEVE IN LOCAL
CONTROL. WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AND I THINK WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN TODAY WHICH
HAVE ADDRESSED THE PRIMARY
CONCERNS THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
FOLKS IN MY COMMUNITY- AND JUST
WITH THE ENTIRE THRUST OF THE
BILL. I THINK IT REALLY CALLS
INTO QUESTION FOR A LOT OF
THOSE FOLKS RIGHT THIS IS THIS
IS THIS IS A BILL THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY PRESERVES LOCAL
CONTROL- IS VERY MUCH IN LINE
WITH THAT I THINK THAT'S WHY
IT'S YOU YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BELIEVE US. SENATOR
GLAZERS WHO VOTED FOR WHO IS A
STRONG PROPONENT OF LOCAL
CONTROL SO I THINK THIS IS. I
WOULD HOPE THAT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT A LOT OF THE
FOLKS WHO CALLED IN TODAY WHO
MAY NOT BE AWARE OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS. WOULD WOULD COME
OFF IN OPPOSITION IN THE BILL-
BECAUSE IF YOUR CONCERN IS
REALLY ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL IF
IT'S REALLY ABOUT PRESERVING
OPEN SPACE. THEN YOUR CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED- AND SO I WANTED TO
YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO FOLKS IN IN MY
COMMUNITY HAD SOME CONCERNS
YEARS YOU KNOW- PROTECTING OPEN
SPACE PRESERVING OPEN SPACE A
SACROSANCT IN MY COMMUNITY- AND
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN TODAY I AM VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL WE
DO HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS WE DO
NEED TO PROVIDE MORE TOOLS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT WANT TO
ADDRESS IT I THINK THIS IS. A
THOUGHTFUL POLICY THAT THREADS
THE NEEDLE. ON ADDRESSING A LOT
OF CONCERNS. AND WE DO NEED TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT ABOUT OUR
HOUSING CRISIS AND SO. ON EVEN
THOUGH I KNOW THAT THE NOT
EVERYBODY IN MY COMMUNITY- IS
GOING TO UNDERSTAND ALL THE
DETAILS OF THIS I THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP. FOR IT AND
I'M PLEASED TO VOTE FOR TODAY.
THANK MS WORKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT. TO THINK.
WIENER THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FORTH THE BILL. ALL THE WORK
YOU DO AND HOUSING AND WOULD
JUST LOVE TO ADD MY NAME ON AS
A CO AUTHOR. AND I'M SURPRISED
I'M NOT ONE ALREADY BUT- LOVE
TO BE ADDED. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES MS WORKS OF THIS
KEEP IT SHORT AGAIN- THIS GIVES
JUST ANOTHER TOOL TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CHOOSE TO USE-
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE TO GO
DOWN THIS ROAD BUT IT'S AN
OPTION AND THAT IS WHY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT I WILL ALSO
JUST ADD MY THANKS TO YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS- I THINK
MANY OF US PARTICULAR MYSELF
BELIEVE IT IS A GOOD IDEA FOR
US TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR CITIES
TO ALLOW FOR- MODERATE. AND
MODERATE MODERATE DENSITY
INFILL HOUSING I ALSO JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS AND FOR TAKING
COMMITTEE MEMONS TOP ADDRESSES
CONCERNS ARE YOUR TO KEEP
WORKING WITH OTHER PARTIES-
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND WITH
THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION COLLEAGUES AND- I
WAS A SAY IN TERMS OF OPEN
SPACE IT ACTUALLY GOES BEYOND
THE BALLOT MEASURES. BECAUSE
CENSUS FOCUSES ON AN INFILL
DEVELOPMENTS- OPEN SPACES EVEN
IF THEY'RE NOT PROTECTED BY A
BALLOT MEASURE. PARK FRANKLY
NOT EVEN GONNA BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS BILL SO THIS IS FRANK
FUNDAMENTALLY ANTI SPRAWL- BILL
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. AND WITH THAT
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHU. HI CHU I SAY
ARE CHAU. GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KALRA KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SILVA. OKAY QUICK SURVIVE
WICKES. WICKES ADDED THAT BILL
HAS FOR BOTH. THANK YOU YOUR
BILLS ON CALL. AND WITHOUT ONE
WE GO TO FILE ITEM FIVE SB FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THIS. THEIR SECOND
pTHIS AS BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN AS A
DATA COLLECTION BILL- THE
SEXIEST KIND OF BILL THREE
HONEST- AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OF
THIS BILL BILLS OFF OF THE
EXISTING ANNUAL PRODUCTION
REPORT THE CITIES ARE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE THE STATE TO PROVIDE
DATA ABOUT HOUSING PRODUCTION-
BUT IT'S INCOMPLETE I'M THIS IS
A NUMBER OF CATEGORIES
PRIMARILY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KNOW HOW STATE HOUSING LAWS ARE
WORKING- SO THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
THE LAWS WE PASS AND SEE HOW
THEY'RE WORKING HOW MAYBE WE
NEED TO APPROVE THEM WHETHER
THE NOT WORKING AT ALL- SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ARE WITH ME- TODAY'S
TESTIFIES DAVID GARCIA- WITH-
TURNER CENTER AT UC BERKELEY.
LET'S GOING. MR GARCIA. THE
GOOD EVENING THE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID GARCIA ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE TERRACE
ENTERPRISING INNOVATION UC
BERKELEY AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN- AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW OUR CENTER FOCUSES ON ALL
MATTERS HOUSING ISSUES AND AS A
RESEARCH CENTER THE KEY TO ALL
OF OUR WORK IS ACCESS TO GOOD
DATA AND GOOD INFORMATION SO
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY. AND
QUANTIFY THE SCALE OF OUR
HOUSING CHALLENGES IN ORDER TO
CORRECTLY IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR POLICY
INTERVENTION THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT AND WE'VE
MADE SOME REAL PROGRESS IN LAST
YEAR'S IN COLLECTING BETTER AND
MORE ROBUST DATA FROM CITIES
INVOLVED INCORPORATING MORE
TRANSPARENCY US SPECIFICALLY
THE QUALITY RELEVANCE OF THE
ANNUAL PRODUCTION REPORTS HAS
APPROVED THE NPR'S NOW WHICH
HAS BEEN CRITICAL PROCESSING
THE IMPACTS OF SOME STATE
POLICIES CASE IN POINT-
REPORTING- EIGHTY USE HAS BEEN
USED BY OUR CENTER. TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE A USER
INCREMENTED IN CONSTRUCTED IN
THIS WORK AND WORK SIMILAR TO
IT IS CRITICAL FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF COMMUNITIES
WHERE EIGHTY YOU UPTAKE HAS
BEEN- LEVEL SO THAT WE MAY
PURSUE POLICY INTERVENTIONS. TO
DRIVE MORE EQUITABLE GROWTH
STATEWIDE. NOT JUST WORK ALSO
CAN THE OF. WHAT IS HAPPENING
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND TO THAT
POINT MORE INFORMATION CAN AND
SHOULD BE COLLECTED TO THE APR
SIX SPAN UTILITY. OF THIS
IMPORTANT TO ALSO BY REPORTING
INFORMATION ON HOMES ARE BUILT
USING STATE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
STREAMLINING FROM HOMES AND THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW- WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THESE PROGRAMS ARE
AFFECTED EACH. AND USE THIS
INFORMATION TO STRENGTHEN.
STRENGTHEN THEM THROUGH THE
ADOPTION OF BETTER POLICY
THAT'S OF MORE OF A STATE
REPORTING IS A VITAL COMPONENT.
THE DRESSING OUR STATE'S
ONGOING HOUSING ISSUES AND
ALLOWS OUR CENTER AND OTHERS TO
CONDUCT THE BEST RESEARCH
POSSIBLE FORM. OF THESE VERY
CONVERSATIONS SO THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL- AND WANT TO
THANK WATER TO WORKING ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE- AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO. HAVING MORE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LET'S NOT GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL NOT
SEEN ANYONE HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM OR IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY. LET'S GO TO THE
OPERATOR LINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PART OF SB FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIX NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU CULTURE WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS FROM BEHALF
OF BILL UP IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU.
LINE THREE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE MATTER THAT WHAT
HAPPENED OKAY AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ORGAN
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE TMG PARTNERS THE
COUNCIL INFILL BUILDERS
CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO THEORY
COUNCIL. HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA- AND FIELDS AND
COMPANY THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHARE MEMBERS ALEX TORE THE
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE SIX THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LAUREN THE LAND CARE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT IN APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR ON SOME RECENT
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
FIND SIX SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING KIMBERLY
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. FIVE SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ON THE
VALUE OF THE ASSET BMB
CALIFORNIAN BE ABUNDANT HOUSING
LA MANERA TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
ONE THREE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THE COULD HAPPEN
TO YOU BAKER EVERYONE INTO PORT.
NINE SIX EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
AND CINEMA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CARE NUMBERS STARTING
CRIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO THE STRONG
SUPPORT. FOUR NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A
PROBLEM CALLED ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ EMB IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SEVEN FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ADAM
BOOKBINDER CAMPBELL IN DISTRICT
TWENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY ABOUT THE
UNIQUE PRODUCTS AT THREE FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ACT
BOWLING WITH GIVE ME YOUTH SAY
AND- IN THE ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BRIAN PRESIDENT CALLING
IN FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
WITH SOUTH BAY YOU'LL BE AND
YOU'LL BE ACTION I EXPRESSED MY
STRONG SUPPORT. SEVEN FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BRIAN OLSON FROM CULVER CITY
MORE OWNS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SEVEN FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LEWIS BONTA ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN PIER IS A
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
A SUPPORTER THANK YOU. SEVEN
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHANKARA'S MILWAUKEE
CALIFORNIA- STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ATHLETE
FROM BEAUTIFUL EIGHTY FIFTY
THREE IN LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SEVEN FIFTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
JOHNSON HIGHER WILL COMBINE
READERSHIP GROUP AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
PUBLIC FOR CALIFORNIAN BEACH-
IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND BEFORE
WE OPEN LINE SIX FIFTY THREE AT
THE REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME LINE SIX
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIFTY THREE CAROLINE IF NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. DOES
NOT RESPONSIBILITIES THE LINE
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOW- THERE ARE THERE
IS NOT AN OPPOSITION WITNESS-
NOT SEEN ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM OR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LET ME ASK
YOU TO OPEN UP THE LINES TO ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO OPPOSE. SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE SB FORTY SEVEN
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
ROLE APPETITE. LINE THREE FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOKAN
SUNSET PARKSIDE DISTRICT SAN
FRANCISCO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SP FROM SEVENTY SEVEN AND FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. TWO
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SANTA MONICA IN OPPOSITION TO
THE FOUR SEVEN SEVEN. THREE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A MAJOR SETBACK ON BEHALF OF
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED REVERE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR
LOCAL CONTROL UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND CATALYST I'D LIKE TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN AND IF I MAY FOR SEVEN
EIGHT AS WELL WOULD BE REALLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. FOUR
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE URBAN COUNTY FOR
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDED
AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE THAT WOULD REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON WILL BE A
POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THREE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOSEPH
KLEIN ON BEHALF OF THE MIRACLE
MILE RESIDENTIAL ASSOCIATION.
NOBLE CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS OPPOSE BOTH. FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN AND FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. NO FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH OKAY OKADA
TO IN A BOWL SPELLING WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THREE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI DAVID WHEATLEY
OF LOS ANGELES PARK AVENUE
OWNERS ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSED. SIX TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RECALL LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE. SIX
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARCELLUS SERRANO- FROM CITY
LOS ANGELES IF YOU USE PORTABLE
I'M OPPOSED TO IT. SIX SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURELY
LAWNDALE OKAY ALONG WITH THE
CLC CALLIE LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND CATALYST I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THREE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ELIZABETH HANNAH. OFF THE ACT
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA UNITED
NEIGHBORS STRONGLY OPPOSE. FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
FIVE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JENNIFER KENNEDY PASADENA L. A.
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED FORGIVE
ME SEVEN AND FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. SEVEN FIFTY THREE
YEAR AFTER LINE IS OPEN. GREAT
LARGER WITH CATALYST TO CLOSE
PORTION OF THE SEVEN. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN NINE FIVE TWENTY
TWO AT THE REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO SELL OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. LINE FIVE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI DAN GREENSPAN COMPLETELY
NORTH MONTANA ASSOCIATION IN
SANTA MONICA THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND AYE OPPOSED FOR I MEAN YES
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN IMPORTANT.
TENER THANK YOU. ONE FOUR A ONE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY
NAME IS MIKE SPEAKING YEAH- OFF
OF THIS HOUSE DAY AND-
CERTAINLY OPPOSED TO BE. NINE
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU. FIVE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
CLAUDIA ERICSSON COMPRESSED
WOOD. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
BOTH BILLS FOR SEVENTY EIGHT AS
WELL THANK YOU. AND I DO HAVE
ONE MORNING CUTER CURRENTLY
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. SEVEN FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALL THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY OPPOSED.
NINETY ONE YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
THAT SEVEN FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI- KERRY **** IN EAST
BAY U. M. B. THIS IS NOT THE
HELP THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SITUATION I AM OPPOSED TO FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN THANK. FOR SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME I JENNIFER HOLDEN AT THE
MACON PARK NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
NINE AND- A MEMBER APPLICABLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
AND WE OPPOSE- SB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN. I SHOW NO ONE NOW
SHOWING OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY
SEVEN SEVEN CONTINUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I THINK THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND. I
JUST WANT TO THANK CENTER
WIENER- FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD
I THINK. OFTEN TIMES- POLICY
MAKERS WERE CRITICIZED FOR
MAKINGPOLICY BASED ON
ANECDOTES AND WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT DATA IS TO MAKING
SMART. INFORMED DECISIONS- OUR
STATE H. C. D. DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY ELEMENT
IS IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING. A STATE HOUSING
PLAN THAT RELIES ON DATA AND-
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TO INFORM OUR EFFORTS TO
INCREASE SUPPLY. WITH THAT THIS
WORKS- AS I THINK THE AUTHOR AS
WELL WHEN I WANT TO THINK ABOUT
TOO I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF
DATA- WE'LL CONTINUE THAT.
FIGHT NEXT YEAR FOR RENTAL
REGISTRY BUT WANT TO ADD MY
NAME IS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
DON'T WANT TO- HAVE. ANECDOTAL
POLICY MAKING WHAT EVIDENCE
BASED POLICY MAKING IN THIS
BODY. I'M SO APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. MR GABRIEL.
HELLO OKAY ATTY FINAL COMMENTS
BY THE AUTHOR YEAH I WAS IS
THAT I HAVE SO I KNOW I DO SOME
CONTROVERSIAL HOUSING BILLS
FROM TIME TO TIME THAT'S OKAY
IT'S A HARD ISSUE AND HOUSING
BILLS ARE OFTEN CONTROVERSIAL I
REALLY HAD HOPED THAT'S JUST
THE BASIC DATA BILL- WOULD BE A
LITTLE LESS CONTROVERSIAL- BUT
WHAT WE SEE FROM SOME OF THE
SAME EOPLE WHO CALL AND ON ALL
THESE BILLS OPPOSING THEM.
DON'T TELL THE CITY'S WHAT TO
DO WE OPPOSE THAT. BUT DON'T
GIVE ANY VOLUNTARY TOOLS TO THE
CITIES WE OPPOSE THAT TOO. AND
DON'T COLLECTED ON HOUSING-
THIS IS A GOOD BILL WE NEED THE
DATA I ASKED HER I DON'T.
WITHOUT MADAM SECRETARY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHE'LL HI SHE LIVES
HERE TO. GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
KALRA KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SILVA. HI QUICK SILVA I WICKS
WIXII THAT BILL HAS FOR VOTES
YOUR BILLS ON CALL IN THE FINAL
BILL OF THE DAY. FILE ITEM SIX
S. B. FOR SEVENTY EIGHT CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I ALSO WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND
ANALYSIS- AS BEFORE SEVENTY
EIGHT IS- IT'S A TECHNICAL BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT ONE OF
CITY HAS VOLUNTARILY ZONES THE
SMALL MULTI UNIT BETWEEN THREE
AND TEN UNITS- ABOUT ARBITRARY
AND RESTRICTIVE SQUARE FOOTAGE
COPS DO NOT MAKE IT PHYSICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE. TO ACTUALLY BUILD-
THOSE UNITS JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
TO CHANGE WHAT THE ZONING AS IT
DOESN'T CHANGES OUR INTENSITY
OR HOW MANY UNITS OF HOUSING
DOESN'T CHANGE THE HEIGHT FOR
THE SETBACKS. OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT THIS IS- OVER ONE ONLY
ABOUT- FLOOR AREA RATIO- F. A.
R. WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A
SQUARE FOOTAGE COP THAT CITIES
OFTEN USE- TO PREVENT FOR
EXAMPLE- SMALL SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES FROM BECOMING MCMANSIONS
BY HAVING THAT KIND OF BOTH
LIMITATION WHICH FRANKLY IS
SOMETHING THAT I'VE ALWAYS-
SUPPORTED. BY F. A. R. IS ALSO
OFTEN APPLIED TO MULTI UNIT AS
WELL AND WHAT HAPPENS IS A CITY
WILL- WILL IMPOSE THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE COP AND F. A. R.
COURSES THE RATIO OF THE LOT
SIZE TO THE BUILDING SQUARE
FOOTAGE- AND THE F. A. R. WILL
BE SO THAT'S WHERE FUNDS WILL
BE SO LIMITED- DIED HI THE CITY
WILL VOLUNTARILY FOR EXAMPLES
ON A PARCEL FOR UNITS- BUT THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE COP MY ONLY BE
NINE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET
DIVIDED BY FOUR IS TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE. FEET PER SQUARE
UNIT A LOT THAT KIND OF MICRO
UNIT AND VERY- SELECT
SITUATIONS MIGHT WORK
OVERWHELMINGLY IT WON'T AND NO
ONE'S GOING TO BUILD IT IN IN
MOST SCENARIOS- AND SO- WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT SAYS THAT
IF THE CITY HAS VOLUNTARILY
ZONE FOR BETWEEN THREE AND TEN
UNITS THIS IS NOT APPLYING
SINGLE FAMILY AREAS THIS ONE
NINE ANYWAY ENABLE MCMANSIONS
ARE LARGE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES-
IT'S ONLY IF THE ZONING IS
THREE UNITS. UP TO TEN UNITS ON
THE BILL ALL REQUIRE. TO THE
FLOOR AREA- B. SUCH THAT IT
WILL NOT MAKE THE BUILDING AND-
SO IF IT IS- ZONE THREE TO
SEVEN UNITS. YES THEY ARE WILL
BE ONE POINT NO- IF IT IS EIGHT
TO TEN UNITS IT'LL BE ONE
POINT. TWO FIVE AND I- JUST BY
WAY OF EXAMPLE IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. I STARTED GOING
THROUGH ITS PROCESS OF REZONING
CITY WIDE TO FOUR PLEX. IT
ADOPTED A ONE POINT NO FIR IN
ORDER TO ACTUALLY ENABLE THE
BUILDING. OF FOUR UNITS THE
OTHER PIECE OF THE BILL IS
THAT- FOR- CITIES AT A MINIMUM
LOT SIZES. IF THERE IS A PRE
EXISTING LOT THAT IS SMALLER
THAN THAT IT'S A LEGAL LIFE.
BUT A SMALLER NOT LOT SIZE. I
CITY CAN'T USE THAT AS A REASON
TO DISALLOW- BUILDING ON THAT
LOT IT'S CENTRALLY COULD BE
GRANDFATHERED AND- SO
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A- SORT OF
BELT AND SUSPENDERS. I BILL IT
DOES NOT OVERRIDE LOCAL ZONING
DENSITY HYATT CETERA IT JUST
SAYS IF YOU DON'T FOR ITS CITY
IF YOU VOLUNTARILY DONE NOT. WE
GOT A LOT PEOPLE ACTUALLY BILL
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AND WITH ME TODAY TO.
OR THOSE GROW TODAY FROM. YIMBY
IN MY LANE FOR SPUR. LET'S GO
YOUR MAIN WE- TO THE OPERATOR
FOR MISTER MARATHI MISTER LANE.
EIGHT THE NEW MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- LUIS MORA DAY FROM
CALIFORNIAN B. SPONSOR OF SB
PORT SEVENTY EIGHT- THE
CORVETTE BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT
IS A REFLECTION OF CALIFORNIAN
BE COMMITTED TO RESOLVING
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION HOME
SHORTAGE- TOOLBOX WITH MANY
TOOLS. ARE PROMINENTLY AMONG
THEM THE TOOL OF MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING COMMITTEE MIDDLE
HOUSNG OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
FOR BIKE THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT HOUSING TYPE THAT
OFFERS SOME OF THE MOST
NATURALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN CALIFORNIA CITIES TODAY.
RESEARCH FROM U. KEEPER TURNER
BY THAT LOW PERMISSIBLE F. A.
R.'S ANTI THOSE REQUIREMENTS
INCREASE THE COST OF HOUSING.
FOR MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING
WHICH OFFICE IS NOT PROFITABLE
ENOUGH TO HIRE BIG- DEVELOPMENT
LAW FIRMS TO HELP WITH. IT'S
BEEN SPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT FAR AND MINIMUM
LOT SIZE- A LOT LOT THAT THAT
ARE RIGHT SIZED. CENTER WINNER
DID A VERY CAPABLE JOBS FROM
THE BILL AND YOU'VE ALL HAD A
LONG DAY BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
HELP WITH ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT. AT
THE POINT OF THE THANK YOU. MR
SURE MEMBERS MICHAEL AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. A
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK KNOWN
AS BURKE. AT THE FORTY SEVEN
YEAR COULD EASILY BE CALLED THE
TRUTH AND DON'T ACT. BECAUSE
WE'RE PART OF WHAT THE ZONING
ALLOWS IS ACTUALLY WHAT CAN BE
BUILT ON A LOT. UNFORTUNATELY
LOW FIR AND MAXIM WHAT COVERAGE
PERCENTAGES AND LARGE. MINIMUM
LOT SIZE REQUIREMENTS
CONDITIONS ON UNDERMINE MODEST
COMPACT. AND SUSTAINABLE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT OF JUST THREE TO
TEN UNITS. ARE PROFESSIONAL
ARCHITECTS AND PLANNERS INSIST
THAT THE DETAILS MATTER. MODEST
NEIGHBORHOOD MULTI FAMILY
ZONING IS NECESSARY BUT NOT
SUFFICIENT TO DELIVER MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING. THAT IS MORE
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN. WE URGE
YOU TO PASS FIFTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT TO ENSURE THAT OUR ZONING
CODES MEAN WHAT THEY SAY. AND
DELIVER WHAT THEY PROMISED.
LET'S. INSIST ON TRUTH AND
ZONING THANK YOU. LET'S GO
MEMBERS OF THE WERE TO SPEAK AN
SUPPORT. OUR SUPPORT. C. KNOWN
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM OR
IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION- LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ELEVEN IN Q. OPEN LINE
THREE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR NUMBER IT
DOESN'T MATTER THAT WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. DEGREE MINING
INSTITUTE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION TEAMS YOU PARTNERS
THE COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS
CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO TO BURY
COUNCIL AND FIELD STARTING
COMPANY THANK YOU. AND SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEVEN DEADLY FIRE LINING UP ON.
YEAH I'M SORRY I MEANT TO BE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ONE SIX
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. NINETY
FOUR NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING OF THOSE
PROFITS HARLEM TOLD ON BEHALF
OF SANTA CRUZ CAN BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NINE
SEVEN FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. EIGHT CAPPELLI OF
NEIGHBORLY SANTA CRUZ CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. ONE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BATIC IN
CINEMA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIX. YUP YEAH THE BILL THANK
YOU. LINE TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THAT GOING WITH- YOU
NEED A AND- GIVE THE ACTION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. SEVEN
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RYAN ALSO UNDERSTOOD. THANK
WITH. THREE NINETY TWO YEAR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO THE
DOCTOR DO YOU IF YOU FACE EVERY
INTO. SIX EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
AGAIN CAROLINE STORED RHYMES I
BEHALF OF PENINSULA PREPPING
AND EMPLOYEE AND IN TWO TWO
STRONG ABOUT THE FORCE EIGHT
THANK SOME. SEVEN FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVEN FIFTY
THREE AM OFTEN BY THE SAMPLE
FROM FROM LOS ALTOS OF SOUTH
BAY YOU MEET IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SEVEN FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SEVEN
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. LET'S NOT RESPOND
TO OPEN NINE SEVEN OH TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS BOBBY
GERRY FROM CALIFORNIA INDIAN
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT. SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
J. ARE TRUE AND ON BEHALF ITS
CUPERTINO FOR ALL IN SUPPORT OF
KICKING TONY. FOUR NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN WE
CAN'T. HI THE TINY ATHLETE FROM
BEAUTIFUL EIGHTY FIFTY THREE IN
LOS ANGELES CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB. FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT.
SEVEN FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT THAT A BOOK
PARTY CITY CAMPBELL AN EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHT AND A HALF THAT
THEY CAN BE PROBABLY SPORTING
SP FOUR SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TRACY
MELANCHOLY AND I'M WITH SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IN THE ARE AT
THE BMB ABUNDANT HOUSING LA
CALIFORNIA B. AND MIR AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE LINE CURRENTLY IN KEUCHEL
IS AN OPERATOR WHILE WE'RE
WAITING AS A REMINDER IF YOU
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B.
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
SEVEN SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK GOD GOOD EVENING
THIS IS JOHN NINE IT- EAST BAY
FOR EVERYONE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SEVEN FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS. SEVEN
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE WE WILL WE
STILL LINE. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORNING Q. THEY'RE COMING WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
CORDYLINE NUMBER SEVEN SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ALL
RIGHT COMPETENCIA YOU'LL BE
CALLING IN SUPPORT. AND I SHOW
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
ARE THERE IS NO MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESS SO. LET'S GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT OPPOSE THE
BILL- SEEN KNOWN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM OR IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. LET'S OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES AGAIN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO- IF
YOU COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION AND- AND
JUST STATE OPPOSE. TO THE
OPERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION PRESS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE TIME AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A SIXTEEN IN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVEN
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY SEVEN SEVENTEEN ARE YOU
TOOK YOURSELF OUT OF QUEUE IF
YOU WANT TO PRESS ONE TO ZERO
WILL CALL HIM OPEN UP YOUR
LINE. ITEM ALONG TO MY TO FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TELL ME
WHY SANTA MONICA I OPPOSE. SP.
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. SEVEN SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES YES BEEN
A LONG AFTERNOON THIS IS GREAT
LORBER WITH CATALYST OPPOSE SB.
FOUR SEVENTY. THREE FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I LEAN
BROKEN SENSIPAR CUPS I
DISTRICTS SAN FRANCISCO IN
OPPOSITION. SIX SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
WILL MOVE ALONG TO MINE FOR
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
YES ANY GIG IN HOLLYWOOD
FRANKLIN COURT OF COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD UNITED NEIGHBORS A
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE SIX
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
JERRY TAKE NAY CAN LOS ANGELES
NUMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS
ANSIBLE CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. FOUR SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER HOLDEN OF THE MANGAN
PARK NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINE ALSO A
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS AND
LITTLE CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE
AS BEFORE SEVENTY. THE ONE TO
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. AND TWO NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR LINE IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW WE CAN HEAR
YOU THINK YOU- GENEVIEVE
DOUGLAS ON THE WITH THE EAST
SIDE VOICE OF LONG BEACH AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. THANK SIX SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SURELY
LOANED OUT THE ALONG WITH THE
CLC TALLY LEVEL CALIFORNIA
UNITED NEIGHBORS CATALYST I'M
HERE AGAIN MISTER WINNER
TALKING AGAINST MY RIGHT AYE
OPPOSED. ONE FIVE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CLAUDIA
ERICKSON- IN BRANTFORD AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE FIVE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS AND GREENSPON FROM
DENSE SANTA MONICA AGAIN OR
CITIES BEEN DOING A GREAT JOB
WITH DIVERSE HOUSING AND I UP
IT CAN TO DESTROY OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCE
MARKET RATE HOUSING TO LUXURY
SO I WOULD OPPOSE FOR SEVENTY
EIGHT. HE ONE THREE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS KATHY
ITH FRIENDS OF SUNSET PARK
AND- WE STRONGLY OPPOSES-
ESPECIALLY DON'T TAKE AWAY ROOM
FOR YARDS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THANK YOU. ONE TWO SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
LISA MORE OF THE CRESCENTA
VALLEY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL-
BECAUSE YET- CREATE A HIGH COST
HELPING. THAT'S ALL. NINE TO
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN THIS CALL WILL FORM A
RESIDENT OF REDONDO BEACH IN
MEMBER UNITED NEIGHBORS CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO AT THE FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. LINE SIX TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
CLOSING THIS BILL. ONE SIX
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MARIN KIRSTEN OF LOS ANGELES I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE THREE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ELIZABETH HAMMERING LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA NUMBER OF SAVE
LAFAYETTE LIVABLE CALIFORNIAN
EITHER NEIGHBORS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL MISTER WINNER
SHOULDN'T BE TELLING PEOPLE
THAT- BANK. TO THE OPERATOR
AGAIN I'LL JUST REITERATE FOR
THIS PORTION OF PUBLIC COMMENT
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
OPPOSE. TO THE OPERATOR. Q. ONE
FOUR SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KATIE SWEENEY RESIDENT OF
THE STAFF AYE OPPOSED SB. FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. LINE SEVEN OH
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANCY
OKADA THE STATE OF THE LAW
KELLY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU AND HAVE A NICE
EVENING. SIX NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARCELLO SERRANO
WELL STRUCK IF. ARE BOTH THE
BILL AND WE. NINE SIX HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE. LINE SIX
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS JILL STUART IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FOR ANGELENOS
COULD TREES AND THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS TEARING DOWN THE BOULDER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THREE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS DAVID WADE LANE-
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR LOCAL
CONTROL- CALLIE A LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA CATALYST STRONGLY
OPPOSED. NINE SEVEN SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR MIND IS NEEDED UNABLE TO
HEAR LOCAL HEADLINE SEVENTY
CORRECT I HAD TO HEAR YOU HEAR
ME- HARKIN ARE NOT THAT I WAS.
HI MY NAME IS KRISTEN RASMUSSEN
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONALITY OF THIS GROUP
REPRESENTING THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS MOST. VALLEY
AREA YEAH AND I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING THE LAFAYETTE
HOMEOWNERS COUNCIL WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER SIXTY H. AWAY.
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE MEMBERS
OF UNITED NEIGHBOR SOMEWHERE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
A JOSEPH SECRETARY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL LOCAL
CONTROL UNITED NEIGHBORS CALLIE
CATALYST TOO MANY OTHERS TO
MENTION AN OPPOSING KITCHEN
CATCHES BEFORE THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO EXCEPT
THESE ARE NOT THE WAY TO GET
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TRICKS IS
QUITE. ONE SEVEN FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. J.
GARFINKLE- MEMBER OF COMMUNITY
HARBOR BAY ISLE OF THREE
THOUSAND HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
IN ALAMEDA I OPPOSE- FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JOHN FRITZ OF NORWALK
CALIFORNIA STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE SEVEN THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN- ONE
SEVEN THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY IT'S HOW ARE YOU.
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE LINING
THANK. ARE WE WANT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. SHE JENNIFER
KENNEDY FROM PASADENA'S
BUNGALOW HEAVEN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED.
FIVE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ELIZABETH MONTGOMERY WITH
pCALIFORNIA CITY FOR LOCAL
CONTROL AND CATALYST WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL DOES
NOT PROVIDE AFFORDABLE. SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD EVENING THIS IS TRICIA
CRANE I CHAIR NORTHEAST
NEIGHBORS OF SANTA MONICA- WE
LOVE OUR CITY- I'M A MEMBER
ALSO APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND VERY PROUD
TO HAVE EXCELLENT CITY
MANAGEMENT AND WE OPPOSE. FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT. OR TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO BARBARA BRADY
FROM LOS ANGELES REPRESENTING
WESTWOOD SOUTH THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS AND A MEMBER
OF LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND
NEIGHBORS UNITED- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY TO SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CORNER THREE
FROM THE INSIDE VOICE LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA ALSO A MEMBER
OF LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND WE
OPPOSE THIS ITEM. ONE SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JENNIFER CAMERON- CALIFORNIA
GREEN JEANS ARE THE ELEVEN
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS AND
CALIFORNIA SO CALLOUSLY FIFTY
AND PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS OF
AMERICA THAT'S NINE ARE LETTERS
OF OPPOSITION JOINING THE
POSTING SB TEN AM EXPLAIN IN A
LETTER THANK YOU. AND BEFORE WE
OPEN LINE SIX SIXTY SEVEN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE SIX
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. NINE SIX SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU
LINE SIX SIXTY SEVEN. BUT NOT
RESPONSIBLE LONG- WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE PERSON THEY'RE CUT
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ALL OPEN WIDE SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI TAMMY TAPIA- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- IT THEN THE-
RESIDENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS AND I
OPPOSE SB NINE AND SB TEN. AND
FOUR SEVENTY SIX SOME FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION. SERVER THE MOTION
MOVE IT FORWARD AS OUR SECOND.
THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR ADVOCACY
OF THIS BILL AND FOR TAKING OUR
COMMITTEE MOMENTS- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS ANOTHER
STREET FOR BILL TO HELP
FACILITATE HOUSING PARTICULARLY
WHEN THEIR HUSBANDS OWNING THAT
HAS MADE IT PRACTICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING AND MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS IN AREAS THAT ARE
ZONED TO ALLOW FOR THEM. AND
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL
WILL MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL
POLICIES ARE INTERNALLY
CONSISTENT HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT.
LACERTAE FINAL COMMENTS. WHEN
ASKED IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
ANY PHONE COMPANY SEPARATE FROM
MADAM SECRETARY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHU BY XU I SEE OUR
GENERAL C. R. TONAL GABRIEL.
KALRA KILEY. KILEY I AND
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I COOK
SILVA WRITES BOOKS SILVA I'D
FLICKS. WITH HIGH. THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES. YOUR BILL PASSES
ENTER WITHOUT THANK YOU SIR AND
ALLOW ME JUST A C. SERGEANTS TO
CALL ANY THE ABSENT MEMBERS SO
WE CAN GO THROUGH THE ROLE. THE
BILL WAIT FOR THIRTY SECONDS. I
THINK WE'RE WAITING FOR MR.
OKAY WHAT WILL GO THROUGH THE
RULES AND I'LL JUST ADD ON
MISTER KALRA- AFTER WE FINISH
SO IF WE COULD START WITH THE
CONSENT ITEM FIVE ACTUALLY
LET'S JUST GO IN ORDER OF FILE
ITEM ONE. FILE ITEM ONE SP
EIGHT DE PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
KALRA KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NOT
VOTING. THAT BUS FIVE VOTES THE
BILL PASSES. FILE IN TWO. S. B.
TWO NINETY TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT KALRA MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE WICKS AYE LICKS
AYE. THE BILL HAS SEVEN MIL THE
BILL PASSES FILE ITEM THREE SB
NINE CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NOT
LOADING. CARS HERE KALRA FIVE
THREE SB SB NINE NOTHING. HI SB
NINE AYE KALRA. THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES SEVERAL PASSES ARE
FILE ITEM FOR SB TEN WIENER. C.
A. R. TELL NOW NO KALRA RIGHT I
HIGHLY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NAAT VOTING. CAN
YOU TELL US ABOUT ON OFFENSE B.
TEN- SIX THE BILL PASSES FILE
ITEM FIVE SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
WINNER. SB FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
AT SARATOGA HI THEY ARE TôI
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY I.
MANGER MAIN TRANSIT. DEVIL OF
THAT BILL HAS SEVEN VOTE THE
BILL HAS PASSED OVER COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM SUCCESS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT. SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT WINNER. DO PASSED- AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA
HI THE BILL HAS. SEVEN THE BILL
PASSES- THE CONSENT ITEMS FILE
ITEM SEVEN SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GABRIEL APRIL I KALRA KALRA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I A
QUICK SILVA. THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES SHE SHOULD BE COMING
BACK- LET'S NOT GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
RUBIO. DO YOU PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMING ON HUMAN
SERVICES KALRA. RIGHT KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I THAT BILL HAS
EVOKED THE BILL PASSES AND FILE
ITEM NINE SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
HERTZBERG. DO PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT KALRA. KALRA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN IN CHENNAI WICKS
WICKES I. AND THAT VOTE IS A
START- EIGHT. ZERO THE BILL
PASSES WILL DO ONE AROUND TOO
AND I MISTER CARR I THINK JUST
FOR THE FIRST TWO ITEMS OF FILE
ITEM ONE S. B. EIGHT. SKINNER
SB EIGHT SKINNER KALRA. KALRA I.
AND OF FILE ITEM TO SB TWO
NINETY SKINNER. SB TWO NINETY
SKINNER KALRA KALRA HI. THE
BILL HAS EIGHT FOLKS NOW. HELLO.
THE LITTLE. EXCELLENT. THE
LITTLE WE'RE JUST GONNA SEE IF
SHE'S STILL AROUND ADAM ONE
BILL SHE LEFT SHE MISSED. OR.
ALL. AND WE'RE GOING.
ALL RIGHT.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE NOW
OFFICIALLY TURNED.